want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
youtube you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only grant cardone enjoy
first thing you got to do is decide as a
business owner do i want to make more
money see see if this dude this dude
with the camera if he shot if his if his
pockets are empty
he's walking around empty pockets
and he's got his fancy camera this is
the the problem with the artist
they starve their whole life
they starve their entire life and then
and then you wonder why they're grumpy
there's no money i'm eating at littles
all the time sooner or later
sooner or later you hit the reality he
hits the reality i got a nice camera i
love taking photos i got to shoot grant
cardone he watches large sugar leave on
his jet and says hey why
does he get to fly
free everywhere do whatever he wants and
i'm stuck with my camera and no money
how many believe that
sooner or later sooner or later after
days of going to work months are going
to work years of going to work sooner or
later if he works for this man he's like
i resent this man
i resent this man i resent that man
business owner i resent paul mcfadden
the business owner i resent you so i
know i won't work for you in fact what
i'm going to do is screw things up for
you
it's called disengagement the only
business people that will survive the
only entrepreneurs that will make it in
business are those people that decide to
grow their businesses little little
will fail
not the little grocery store
okay if you try to stay small if you try
to stay small
you will fail
okay i'm telling you this from personal
experience
i tried to stay small
i tried to manage the business i tried
to be the king of the business i tried
to have no employees because employees
cost money
i'm like i'm not going to have any
employees
i'm not going to pay the camera man i'll
just hire him when i do a gig
and the next time i'll hire another guy
and that'll keep my expenses low how
many are brought up like this keep the
expenses real low where we can manage
the expenses
the expenses are going to be so small
that that no matter how much we make i
keep it all
you have to advertise
you have to advertise in your career to
blow your brand up you cannot
not advertise and save money it costs me
probably
400 i even say a number this big yes or
do i lose everybody
400 million dollars we have estimated is
what it cost me because i didn't
advertise for the first 20 years of my
career but
before you spend one dollar in
advertising and and even if it was
wasted it'd be a great dollar to spend
even if you don't get a return you
should do it but before you do that what
you need to do is spend a lot of time
energy and resources on branding
i made a mistake here not spending more
money in advertising i made a bigger
mistake not spending more
time energy and resources on branding
and you are making a mistake if you do
any kind of metrics
on did it convert did it pay off
branding will not pay off
zero you will get a zero return if you
don't brand
okay you will get a zero return for
branding in the beginning
you will get you will never get a return
on advertising if you don't brand
branding is a must it is senior to
advertising you hang around guys and
gals my friends you hang around people
that are changing will not change you
i know this whole mastermind thing we
have masterminds i believe they're great
they're awesome but
if ryan back there
hangs around me and i'm changing that
don't mean he's going to change
so look i've seen this for 30 years
you know i've gone places where the the
only reason everybody went there was
because they were
working on themselves changing improving
courses classes education elena and i
actually great story about elena and i
the only reason people went to these
places was to improve themselves okay
i gotta tell you something only about 10
of the people that went there
flew
they were changing they were actually
making the changes
the other people were hanging around
people changing just because you're
around people changing doesn't mean you
are going to change you got to do the
work to change my brothers and sisters
you got to change
it you know you know ryan hangs around
me if i change my clothes that don't
mean he changes his if everybody in the
house changes their clothes takes a
shower
put some deodorant it don't mean if ryan
does not change his clothes and take a
shower and put on his deodorant he gonna
stank dropping bombs to change you got
to change it doesn't matter how many
people you hang around that are changing
if you if you hang around everybody just
getting rich getting wealthy doing great
creating stuff and you're not you're not
going to change to change
you got to change
i heard a man tell me once he's like
grant money won't make you happy i'm
like son
son you ain't got any money
quit giving advice on something you
failed at
right if you're taking notes you want to
write this down never ever ever
ever
take advice from a quitter
never ever take advice from a quitter
particularly financial advice okay the
first question i asked you today was
this do you
want to make more money
then quit taking advice from people
about money that don't have any money
this used to be a goal of mine to make
one million dollars a year
that was my goal when i was 35 years old
one day i said to myself one day i said
self
little g-dog
little g-dog one day young man i wrote
this over and over and over again i
talked to myself in the mirror i'd sit
on the toilet and say one day
one day
i'm gonna i'm gonna make a million
dollars one day one day and people used
to tell me that's crazy dude
like why do you think so big this is
when people were telling me not to
they're like why do you need to do all
that why do you just be happy just be a
good person okay be happy that you live
in america be happy that you have meals
and be happy you've got good health and
all the things that the people around
you that quit on money that quit on
financial freedom that quit on
possibility they quit on their potential
all the things those people will tell
you
to try to convince you
to quit
when in reality what they're really
trying to do is make sense of why they
quit
note to self
okay last month i distributed 1.2
million dollars to other people okay
it's not money i made it's money i sent
out so it just goes to show you how
small i was thinking when i was 35 years
old this is uh i'm at the beverly hills
hotel today
if you've never stayed here you have to
okay every single day that i have been
here i have met someone
that will help me in my career i can't
go they don't tell you this in school
they don't teach you this your parents
didn't teach you this you have to go
where the money is
money is not just okay i'm gonna buy a
lamborghini and i'm gonna buy a big
house and i'm gonna buy some jewelry and
i'm gonna get some nice sunglasses i'm
gonna go buy a big watch and i'm gonna
go on vacation it's about going where
other people are that have money and
that can help you
that can help you so you can help others
so you can help your parents so you can
take care of them
so you can take care of your kids so you
can be a good example look money's not
going to make you happy you guys already
know that everybody knows that i don't
even know why we're talking about it
money will not make you happy
but
it'll get you an uber
it'll get you an uber it'll get you a
hotel room it'll get you access to the
polo lounge it'll get you breakfast this
morning to sit at the right place with
the right people that maybe someone
someone discovers what you're doing what
you're up to and that takes interest
every single breakfast every single
lunch that i've been here and every
single dinner that i've been sitting out
in public i have met someone that can
literally help me with my career
do you want to make your business bigger
i know this seems really simple
but the reality is if it's not simple
i don't care where you are on planet
earth
whether you're in wales
i'm going to go to glasgow tomorrow
we're going to leave here and go into
spain
i'm going to do russia in about three
months
i'm gonna go back to miami and do
business in miami no matter where in the
world i am folks if it's not simple
you're not going to make money
listen to what i'm telling you if it's
not simple you will not make money
over long periods of time it's got to be
simple for other people to understand it
the guy invests five thousand dollars
he's got five thousand dollars in the
bank another guy's got 50 grand in the
bank and another guy's got 500 000 okay
all three of these people invested money
with me this is cliff this is dave and
this is jennifer okay cliff sent me five
grand dude it was his last five grand it
was as hard for him to do this as this
guy to do that do you understand okay
this guy earns i don't know he's gonna
earn 300 bucks a year
this guy's gonna earn three thousand
dollars a year this guy's gonna earn
thirty thousand dollars a year
but they all had to start with this
they all start with five thousand
dollars everybody starts with five
thousand dollars including jennifer
right here she's got a five
just another zero
all of them had to make a decision
should i keep the money this is where
the opportunity comes in you got to
think in terms of opportunity costs okay
is my money better in the bank
or is my money better in an asset that
ad that can grow over time okay do i buy
a watch
okay do i buy something stupid
it is beautiful but it's stupid let's
keep it real
stupid
is as stupid does and that ladies and
gentlemen is stupid paddock
okay however
the reason the way i bought the paddock
was because the real estate that i buy
not this real estate okay i already
distributed these people the real estate
i invested in sent me a little check
check how many heard this statement
before knowledge is power warren buffett
was on tv yesterday he's 88 years old
he's worth 83 billion dollars
okay i want to know where
where the guy is in his cycle
everybody's got a life cycle
i'm young i'm broke
i get a little bit of money i'm middle
class now okay now i'm rich now i'm
super wealthy okay and now i'm going to
die
my data points will change everybody
agree with that
where are you getting the data from okay
if this is probably where i'm at right
now in a number of places in my life
both my finances my brand recognition
my international presence my business
expansion i'm probably
up on a upward slope
i might be down here and not even know
it yet
okay because i might not know how high i
could go
probably this is a mistake i didn't know
how big i could get so
down here what am i telling you right
there get your money save it
like if you go back and read my books
when i was 30 years old 35 years old i'm
telling that save your money save all
your money save all your money why i'm
trying to put some money away
then then i get right here i'm like i
need to get the money to work
right
i get here and i'm like i need to get
the people around me making money
when i'm starting this cycle so you need
to understand when you're listening to
me today
leave here and you go to
to john maxwell's workshop
where is john in
the cycle of his life
the source of data
steve jobs steve jobs was down here
animal
he was an animal him and bill gates were
like
carnivorous
they they weren't thinking about giving
money away they didn't have any money
they were in a garage
right scrapping out man buying tacos
probably stealing a little bit
warren buffett warren buffett down here
took 500 shares of ford motor company
stock for free to pitch it
to tell people i have 500 shares of
the ipo
in 1957 ford motor company went public
he got 500 shares from the company to
say he was buying ford motor company he
didn't buy a ford motor company they
gave him the chairs it's against the law
okay he's outside the statue of
limitations that's what he did then
that's not what he's doing now raise
your hand if you've ever given up before
giving up and quitting are very
different things
one you never try again the other
you might
it's a hospital
if you refuse to give up i promise you
you will have a victory and when you do
you gotta get a sweet victory day
most people are getting just enough to
compare themselves to be better off
than other people if you have desire in
your heart
if you want to do better
you have
to put your money
your energy where your commitment is
they're going to tell you
like they told me and i believed it for
a while i did but i didn't it's look
you're a drug addict you can't help it
you're powerless
it's in your genetic code and you have
no control over it
now i'm going to tell you right now that
i believe that to be complete
complete
garbage so
if i was a drug addict and it's
completely out of my control then i
would have had to use drugs today yeah
and i didn't
so
using drugs is a choice yeah i would
tell you and i would tell everybody that
that has that addictive
nature is congratulate yourself and pat
yourself on the fact that that you have
the ability to be addicted to something
and take that addiction dude and put it
into something unbelievable
because every every super successful
person that i have studied and or met
is has the ability to be obsessed with
something to the point of losing sleep
to the point of i don't need to need to
eat
uh i'll go in debt i'll go bankrupt i'll
go down with this make this thing happen
and that's really what turned my whole
life around was just flipping the
addiction not trying to
not be in control not trying to turn it
all over just saying hey i'm gonna take
this energy and i'm gonna dump it into
into
work
you gotta advertise and you gotta spend
money on marketing and advertising if
you if people don't know you it will
cost you a fortune it cost me
400 million dollars over the last 20
years because i was not spending money
in marketing and promotion and
advertising and social media i actually
thought social media didn't work
i was so wrong about that
i started a social media company
where we actually now run ads for
companies
so that you get known the way i've
gotten known today with i don't know a
million 1.4 million instagram followers
a million subscribers on youtube six
million people on facebook trust me if
you don't advertise on social media
i would call you a dumbo you know why i
have the right to because i didn't think
it worked either
all people men and women they should be
more greedy about their personal
dreams
well what what if they could i think
about these five kids and i've got this
responsibility and yeah you do but you
also have responsibility yourself
like how can i if i can't take care of
me how can i take care of somebody else
yeah this has always been my
battle cry like i have to take care of
me
you know and and i how can i help anyone
i'm broken
i'm messed up you know i'm i'm i'm
coming out of a treatment center for
drug addiction
i didn't need to help anybody else i
needed to get i needed to get on solid
ground you know and i needed to make
sure i wasn't going back to treatment
and then i needed to clean up the mess
that i mean i needed to do this for me
because
uh
and that has been my contention now for
many years like just keep slowly taking
care of your neighborhood until you're
in another zip code they say your
network equals your net worth
your ability to move this planet to
change things to get investors funding
money is determined by who you know if
you got a money problem i guarantee it's
got something to do with your network
okay if you if you're having marriage
problems i assure you with 100
certainty if you're having marriage
problems there's somebody in your
network
that believes in marriage problems if
you're having kidney problems
you know not kitty kitty now i'm talking
about if you've got problems with your
kids it's because your network is having
problems with chilling if you have a
time problem i don't have enough time i
can't find enough time i'm working too
hard i never have time i can't find time
to work out i can't find time for the
kids i can't find time for the marriage
you have a network of people that have
time
problems i thought
i thought people cost money
none of these people cost anything okay
do you know that only four percent of
companies in america make a million
dollars a year
67 of all companies in america have no
employees okay so if you stay with no
employees and you're the only person
working there promise you you will not
make money
less than four percent of all companies
in america make a million dollars a year
when i was at mcdonald's and i got fired
from mcdonald's flipping burgers or
drinking fries what were we doing
whatever they had me do they had me they
had me do what you know they're this is
what we do right it's a road it's a
factory
and um
i was 16 years old and and um my dad had
been dead six years so
like you know look i'm uncertain i'm
15 16. i've just had sex for the first
time
everything is so complicated
making five bucks an hour that's
whatever it was no it's probably like
280. wow
yeah but that wasn't that wasn't the
problem i was grateful for the 280
but i was awkward i was not confident i
didn't know how to talk to people
um
you know you know i hated the job
but if somebody said dude go learn this
game so you can own 50 mcdonald
restaurants
like if i would have had that
that idea i'll bet you i would own a
bunch of mcdonald's franchises today but
i went there just for the 280. yeah
not not far hey i want to do something i
think i truly think that the the thing
that i've suffered from the most in my
life as i look at kobe and
you know all these pictures of these
great people you know dude i just
thought too small i was worried about
the 80 bucks
and i was worried about what the car
dealers thought about me
that audience i was managing the bottom
half of my financial statement not the
top
one inch
today i spend 95 percent of my time on
the top
literally inch inch and a half
and i ignore the rest i might spend 3
percent of my time on managing expenses
and costs and budgets i spend 95 of my
time on the income of the company
on how to increase the income
how to blow up the top line let's see if
they even let me in my office yeah
how to blow up the top line
in hopes that
i can spend more money in marketing
spend more money in branding and spend
more money employees i don't think i was
built to be quiet like like they tell
you when you're growing up you know be
quiet be seen not heard
or be be hurt whatever the deal is you
know don't touch your own horn
don't get too much attention and don't
promote yourself and
but look man god was a show-off man
look what he created
just didn't stop he's not quiet no
okay rainbows you know suns planets like
waterfalls everything yeah crazy man i
think we love people that are
grateful and have humility but we also
love to see people do great great things
yeah is there a balance that they should
have like also be grateful and humble as
opposed to kind of like the
mcgregor uh dude i love mcgregor yeah
see i like that that's your that's your
energy you're like you're on that
frequency i i you know
who doesn't like it dude look at how big
the audience is yeah
you know look at the rock he doesn't
have little muscles
right
but he's he's got more humility let's
say if you're cool he knows how he knows
how to play that game oh my god i mean
there's nobody better than the rock at
that obama was unbelievable with that
yeah it's staying connected
that's what i'm terrible at i'm
awful at
i am so bad at it why
i don't know why
i don't know why i am i just know i'm
bad at it i don't want to talk to you
about execution and management and
business planning and
culture i want to talk to you about
money because money we believe
is the number one problem in your
business
it's not mission it's not purpose it's
not all these beautiful things everybody
tells you it's not planning and
organizing i have seven businesses
there's seven little companies there's
been no plan
there's been minimal organizing
tremendous speed
tremendous speed to market okay it's one
of the things that that has made us
successful but mostly
in all the businesses every business was
created
around the concept
it needs to make money
[Music]
because if it doesn't make money
[Music]
you'll call yourself an entrepreneur
because you're not gonna be able to call
yourself a business person
and so this industry of entrepreneurs
that that is now
so popular
i never even knew the term until like a
year and a half ago
okay before that i was in california
somebody said i was an entrepreneur
uh 15 years ago i'm like well that's
that's code for
i don't have a job
okay today today look if you want to be
an entrepreneur good but really what you
want to do is evolve to being a business
person that makes money
and that provides a good living for a
lot of other people right
so number one problem in your business
is employee disengagement it is not
actually money
[Music]
money is their problem
employee disengagement how many of you
here own uh run a department let me see
if you run or manage more than more than
just yourself let me see a hand
how many of you here run or manage a
household
okay good well if you can't manage the
household
by the way
you have disengagement at a household
level would you agree
husband and wife are disengaged
one's doing their own plan this one's
doing their plan 50 of those marriages
are gonna fail okay that's what they say
they're gonna divorce truth is way more
than fifty percent fail people should
not be looking at the divorce rate they
should be looking at the failure rate
there is no shortage of success
regardless of their culture race
religion economic background or social
group most people would agree that
success is vital to the well-being of
the individual the family unit and the
group and certainly to the future
survival of all these things
look without success your group your
company your goals and dreams and even
the entire civilization would cease to
survive and thrive
winning over and over again and
everything in which you're involved
ensures you're going to be able to
further expand and survive and it
guarantees that both you and your ideas
will survive not just get by but survive
into the future
if you quit caring then you're going to
quit winning
and if you quit winning long enough in
this thing called success you're gonna
just plain quit
how would being successful be important
to you and how would it improve your
life look success is needed in order to
perpetuate to push forward people places
and things
you must never reduce success in your
mind or in a conversation to something
that doesn't matter
on the contrary you must treat as though
it's vital
it's important
anyone that minimizes the importance of
success to your future has probably
given up on his or her own chances of
accomplishment
and it's spending now his or her life
trying to convince others you in this
case
to also give up
individuals and groups must actively
accomplish their goals and targets in
order to carry on with their goals and
targets if not look they'll either cease
to exist or be consumed
and become part of something else it's
not enough just to play the game it's
vital you learn how to win at this game
human beings are trapped in as spiritual
beings they're trapped this is what i
believe i believe i believe the
spiritual being is trapped in a body
okay i believe i'm a spiritual being not
a human being the spiritual being would
have tremendous potential unbelievable
potential it would be the light on the
candle not the candle the body would be
the candle
okay and and the spiritual being would
be the flame i i'm not i'm the flame
and and i want to see how hot can i burn
okay how far can i go how much light can
i bring the world how much positive
truth message can i bring this planet
how much more can i do and i think the
problem is people are settling out
with just enough pay the bills
take care of my family get my little box
get my little house put my little
welcome mat on the front put the little
gate around the yard
we're all gonna be happy i don't want
the box
i don't want one location i don't need
to welcome that i want to know the world
i want to travel the world i want to do
more i want to be in more places i want
to have friends in every country
i want to inspire people in every
language and i want other people to see
and they can do the same thing you know
and and maybe maybe maybe at the end of
all this
i just become everybody's uncle
that i never had if you're a business
owner you have to see the future if
you're an entrepreneur you have to look
forward to into the future what's going
to happen next
if you're driving a car it's responsible
to look ahead everybody agree
if you're skiing down a mountain you
might want to keep your attention out in
front of you if you're riding a
motorcycle
you might want to not pay attention to
right where you are but where you're
going
pay attention to the future what dreams
and goals do you have that are more
important than the money you have invest
money to hit your targets quit
telling yourselves lies about money
exchange money the only purpose of money
is to exchange money for time and
connections
the only reason you have money is to
exchange money for time
and people
you need people folks
[Music]
you need people man
you're going to grow your business with
people people that work for you and
people that you sell products to
be so obsessed
with the idea of freedom and making a
difference that you will do anything
anything i'll go into debt i'll spend my
last dollar this is how you're going to
be successful folks i'll borrow money
from my mom i borrow from my dad i
borrow from from family members
i'll go raise money i'll go beg on a
street corner i'll go sell t-shirts and
hats
failure after failure i'm obsessed so
much with my freedom that i'm willing to
talk to people even if i'm an introvert
okay i'm willing to go talk to old
people if i'm young i'm willing to go
talk to young people if i'm old i'm
willing if i'm out of work i'm willing
to go take a dumb sales job just to get
my feet back underneath me
become so obsessed
that everybody's like
[Music]
what's wrong with you man
you change it you got to change your
friends
if your friends
you need to make these people your
friends
people that have time to get away people
that are working
people that are creating
surround yourself with people that are
doing things
that that are
seeking to be better
i was i was hanging around people that
were destroying themselves every day
people that were criticizing others that
were successful
that were wasting time
beautiful rock
they weren't looking for anything
except how everybody else was wrong
how they had been wronged i know because
i was doing this
spent all my time talking about
how the rich guy
that was had his kids in tennis classes
and golf classes
and they had a boat and they went skiing
how he was such a prick
and when reality oh sorry guys didn't
mean you to hear that
when in reality she didn't hear that
when in reality i should have been
looking at dude what did this guy do
to create
a situation
where he could pay for his kids
to learn
tennis
if they want to golf
and skiing
i was asking the wrong questions
i would tell my 20 year old self change
the questions you're asking
change the way you look at things
quit being so resentful hateful
you know quit quit get get your game
together my business is kind of
different i own a hair salon
um and i have
started a brand for myself and probably
went about it the wrong way i started it
um
doing booth rental instead of commission
and in the business i'm kind of maxed
out at making as much as i can make for
the size so i know i need to expand but
i also know that i have to be taken
serious as a woman and i feel like it's
a it's a difficult thing to do
and i don't want to do it the wrong way
this time so i don't really know how to
be taken seriously i'm petite i have
blonde hair i always have crazy
fingernails or sometimes it's purple
sometimes it's blue yeah
so i guess the question would be where
where do i go from where i'm at to get a
lot of attention i know i i think you
just got to get a lot of attention
you know everything the red the blue the
long nails the shortening anything that
gets attention like you have to get
people's attention you guys have to get
interesting
so
again she doesn't like some of the
things i do i have to do that i believe
in my mind i have to do some of that to
capture attention whether that's true or
not true i don't know i don't know maybe
it's not true you know i know this if
somebody wants to have a movie and it
wants to be a great movie at the
theaters they got to get a lot of
attention and get somebody to go to the
movie you got to be willing to get
people not to like you
and what does that look like
just by promoting so much that you
irritate people like what does it mean
to get people not to like rush limbaugh
who's a pretty pretty divisive guy
uh says uh
you know the people that love him
listen to him two hours a day and the
people that hate him listen to him for
four hours
people that hate him listen to him for
four hours a day
so i'm just saying everybody wants to be
liked yeah everybody wants to be the the
popular person you guys got to be
willing to tell people your hair looks
terrible
oh i mean i do i'm i'm actually very
very good at my job i just don't know
how to um
take it take it to the next level i
guess maybe it's maybe i'm scared or i
haven't done it
what's your facebook
would right there nope the one
underneath that
see i don't have a picture of you so i'm
gonna go is that is that you yes
or is that your kids um that well
there's a picture of me and then it's my
daughter yeah so i mean
i don't want to see your daughter right
now i want to show you right i have a
hair therapy page um i don't it's under
hair therapy yeah i see hair therapy i
see it right here
so like right okay now we got the dogs
yeah but now i'm oh yeah she's a
veterinarian
right
so like okay now i got hair okay that's
good before and after round like like
you guys gotta like get clear on what
the message is right she needs a fa you
need a personal you need a business page
right
the trick is you got to get attention
elena just wrote a book called build an
empire okay she has to get attention for
the book which means leak out data about
the book not about anything else but
that book what is it what chapter what
audio what am i listening to why am i
listening to it what do i get out of it
like constant pushing into whatever you
do with hair therapy
okay
and and see good good but but dinner
date but what do i do with the dinner
date yeah
so see like you
did this is where everybody's like
when's enough enough man when do you
just enjoy yourself
i don't know i'm gonna enjoy myself when
i'm in a position to just enjoy myself
you live on an economic planet
regardless of your race regardless of
where you came from regardless of your
religion you live on a planet that has
two things on it gravity i can't fly
and i'm reminded every day of gravity
right or wrong every day day i'm
reminded i'm reminded of it so much i
don't even know that it's not normal
that i shouldn't be able to jump seven
feet
right
and number two
money every day you were reminded this
is a financial planet okay i got a
little credit i don't have any cash on
me today not because i'm a real estate
guy
real estate guys are always broke
okay but i got me a little card
i can use this to open boxes
and i can use it to buy a box
right see how many were told all credit
credit cards are bad how many been told
debt is bad how many been trained that
oh
all debt is bad debt i got about 500
million worth of debt i got to tell you
i love it almost as much as my wife and
kids
i do love it man because it generates
income for me
[Music]
now i'm telling you all this to tell you
look you have been miseducated if you're
having trouble with money it's because
you have the wrong data
it's not because you're stupid it's not
because you're lazy it's not because you
have a bad job okay i've had all those
excuses
you have the wrong information the first
25 years of my life i use the
information that is being disseminated
by tv and mass media
save your money say yeah if you heard
that one
okay you were brought up on that one if
you were brought up poor middle class
say yay
no no you can't say it like that say it
like you're proud yes i must pour
say yay
no no well you brought up poor middle
class
[Music]
i'm gonna tell you something it's gonna
take you forever if you don't get your
enthusiasm right look if you're poor
admit it
[Music]
but damn i'm poor and then hate it
because you shouldn't be
if you're in the middle by the way if
you're middle class and you got three
meals a day you got a car out there you
can make the payments on you got a
little education that you think is worth
something and it's not
okay
and you got a good mom and a good dad
and you're brought up in a good family
good for you but dude i don't pay the
bills you ever ask yourself dude when
are you gonna make it are you do you
ever suffer from this idea that you
could do more than you're doing
and no matter how much people around you
love you or
oh you're doing great patching in the
back you're doing phenomenal amazing
i've been told my whole life i was doing
amazing i remember being i was 29 years
old i was the leading sales person where
i look where i worked
i mean i wasn't the best sales person i
was the best person by like three or
four people
breaking records doing stuff that had
never been done
everybody's telling me how great i was
and i was like but i know i can do more
i don't know if that's suffering
suffering some kind of like
mental disease some kind of never
satisfied with i've heard all these
people talk about
i remember the guy said hey your
disappointments are
your disappointments in life are equal
to your expectations
suggesting that you not have
expectations
if you lower your expectations then you
won't have disappointments i got to tell
you man i i mean i can't even make sense
of that i'm like i have to have
expectations of myself i know i can do
better i know i can do more
so
if
me having big expectations of myself
and i'm going to be disappointed from
time to time that's the way it's got to
be the one other thing that i would tell
my 20 year old self look i own seven
businesses
and
i would not tell you
i would not tell the 20 year old grant
to go get six six businesses
i would tell him
to learn everything you can about real
estate
everything
real estate is the business
that's allowed me to go on these
magnificent trips that i'm taking my
family on i've been in business for
myself for 30 years
okay six businesses do not
six businesses combined do not allow me
to go on these trips it is the real
estate by and of itself
it's allowed me to take my
wife and kids
employees partners friends on these
magnificent trips when you're hating on
somebody in your same space right or
they're hating on you remember this you
keep focused on creating massive massive
success
okay because
when you get up to the top of the food
chain whatever the food chain is in your
space whether it's financial or
insurance or real estate or influencers
or podcasters
or or maybe you're doing a real business
you're not doing it you're not an
influencer and you're not a podcaster
you're like why all these guys spending
all this time doing podcasts i got a
business to grow i got employees
maybe you're doing that
so
what's my point
anytime you watch any of my videos you
say dude what's the guy really talking
about
i'm doing this for you i don't get paid
to do it
so if you're getting any value out of
this i'm telling you when you get up the
food chain and you will because you're
watching it you will get up the food
chain you will become a super successful
person but you won't if you hate
you will not become super successful
if you take the time
to worry about these other people in
your space flowing power man
love on them send them love send them
customers send them deals but don't be
surprised
when they don't send it back
because they're not
no book
tells you this
all these guys doing their little quotes
talking about abundancy
scarcity but watch how they act when you
get up there man watch it man it's gonna
be crazy you're gonna be like cardone
told me
while i was eating snow
the dude told me
that they were gonna hate on me i had i
had somebody call me the other day and
said hey dude i want to give you some
you need you need to know how to handle
some of these situations you're running
up against okay because there's a way
for you to prevent some of this
some of this these people hating on you
i said dude i don't i'm not gonna try to
prevent somebody from being stupid
that's just dumb i got enough insurance
in my life already
most of the time the accident never
happens the way to ensure that these
haters and criticizers and little
thinkers don't bother you is don't be
them number one number two
keep following them love and power baby
number three number three number three
get to the top
get to the top of the food chain
where everybody at the top knows you
and the people that wouldn't flow you on
the way up
or wish they didn't do what they did we
saw the fight last night
just goes to show you man you can't take
eight months off eight months of
drinking and showing off and bragging
and running your mouth you can still get
cracked
you got
you know huh
yeah too many days off man too many days
off you got to pay the price every day
folks otherwise you lose
period
you will get beat
you're going to get beat in the
marketplace if you don't train every day
i'm wearing my cardone university
t-shirt
because if you don't train every day
don't expect to make the sale
if you don't train every day when you
leave here do not expect your people to
follow up if you don't train every day
do not expect your people to answer the
telephone correctly if you don't train
every day do not expect your people to
be motivated to do the right thing if
you don't train every day if you don't
require training every day if it's not
mandatory every day you will not get the
cash flow
you will get just enough money to pay
the bills and by the way everybody's got
that figured out
everybody on the planet has figured out
how to pay their bills
even people that don't have any money
are figuring out how to eat everybody
agree so don't be bragging about your
bicycles and your two bmws and your
country club that you paid for and the
roof over your head and you paid your
utilities and your gas and don't tell me
that all somebody else has got it worse
than you of course somebody else has got
it worse than you i hear this all the
time from people
okay somebody gets whacked they have a
bad situation and they're like but i'm
grateful
well you mean you're grateful man you're
filing bankruptcy i know but i still got
my health
but you don't have your financial health
you shouldn't have gone bankrupt you
should have prepared for it don't make
sense of the failure okay if you're
taking notes quit making sense of the
failures i want to talk to you about the
cash flow
i'm talking about the cash flow not the
snow i'm talking about getting that
third flow
you work your wife works
yeah y'all cracking some
smack daddy money you getting some long
green
you made your first million dollars last
year that's right between the two of you
after you paid your taxes you end up
with four or five maybe 600
if you know how to play the game
but what you don't have is number three
your cash don't work you got scared once
you put away your first milli you and
the wife are like oh no what do we do
now you called your uncle not me not
uncle g you called your other uncle the
confused uncle he said pay the house off
you called your financial advisor start
investing in 401ks in the iras
and then you saw something i said about
cash
it's trash
a home is dumb equity
what are you doing folks get that third
flow
it's like a good snowstorm baby you need
that third flow when you can't work
you can't crank
you can't create
the third flow of income is the one you
buy you take your debt money cash is
trash take that dead money and get
invested in hard assets
and only make a decision to invest in
those things that pay you cash flow
you invest cash you get back cash
every single
month muhammad ali said he was the
greatest i am the greatest
he said that before he got in the ring
i know a lot of you out there think
you're like i am the greatest but but
you ain't the greatest you're out there
like i'm living the dream you ain't
living a dream that ain't a dream you're
living so when you're hearing this and
you're like man i like what he just said
yeah because you agree with it or you
needed it because if you agreed with it
that doesn't help you grow things that i
agree with do not get me my growth
growth is typically painful
it hurts
doesn't feel good i have to push through
it right think about the tree roots
growing they're having to push through
cement probably doesn't feel good
so are you pushing through cement are
you getting that extra segment in are
you doing this every day you know are
you pushing for the sale if you can't
push yourself how are you gonna ever
push somebody else in the completion of
an activity in the successful completion
of an activity is where ladies and
gentlemen
you will find yourself okay i don't end
up doing things that are destructive
when i'm busy doing things that are
constructive the truth is i was never a
drug addict
i just had too much free time and made
bad choices
this planet is filled with bad choices
pornography strip joints casinos if you
were filled up all day long with
activities if you were addicted to
productivity if you were junkies out on
potential
you wouldn't have time for all the other
garbage i would i wouldn't be i wouldn't
spend money on stuff i don't need when
is that money spent when do we waste
most of our money on this planet during
the holidays
when we have free time
when do you spend your money when do you
go in debt on the holidays free time so
if i can just stay busy if i can use
time and create time how do i create
time i have 24 hours and i'm like i'm a
jam as much in those 24 hours as i can
and then i'll let you worry about me
burning out because that's what i'll
hear next
what about burnout when you you're going
to burn out look i'm 60 years old
the more i do the more i can do and the
younger i get the more i do the younger
i feel the more i do the younger my body
feels
i'm not going to burn out i'm not a
candle
i'm not wax
hey hey hey a lot of people talking
about showing up
some people denigrating denigrating on
my showing up rule
it is ladies and gentlemen not 80
of success
regardless what anyone tells you
it is probably more like 99.9
of success
and anybody that says otherwise
is just trying to get some attention
unnecessarily because i already love all
you guys
check it out like if you don't show up
you have no chance of anything happening
and once you show up
physically show up
then you got a chance of the rest of you
showing up and you being
unbelievable superstar but if you don't
show up for the audition
the sales call the speaking gig
uh whatever it is you don't show up for
work man nothing if you don't show up
and buy that lottery ticket you can't
win it
then you got to get a little lucky then
you got to persist then you got to do
all the other things you got to do but
first she gots to show up look man i've
been labeled ocd acd
compulsive obsessive
cod bipolar you know they wanted to put
me on lithium prozac all this medication
okay i mean real real like serious drugs
i'm not talking about smoking weed on
the weekends and that was supposedly to
handle my energy
or my creativity or
the fact that i didn't like sitting in a
chair for 45 minutes at a time in school
listening to a history class of
something that happened 300 years ago
that had nothing to do with me when i'm
sitting there saying hey listen i just
want to learn how to make some money man
so you know it's finally when i quit
letting everybody all these average
people label me
and said you know what i'm going to take
this obsessive compulsive this this
whatever this energy is that that has
been
you know made wrong by society i'm going
to take this energy and i'm not going to
suppress it anymore i'm going to use it
so for all the kids all the kids out
there teenagers that are being
mislabeled millennials millennials a
label man introvert is a label
lazy is a label nobody's lazy nobody is
born lazy these labels are being given
to people incorrectly and the truth is
nobody's actually lazy okay you're not
born lazy you're made lazy you're
allowed to be lazy you're encouraged to
be lazy you're surrounded by a bunch of
people that are lazy and then you become
lazy people that are being labeled ocd
add adhd i think they're geniuses it's
waiting for you there's this big gift
sitting there waiting to bubble up
don't medicate it and don't push it down
give it a voice let it be greatness and
genius rather than something bad the
president of mexico
was on the phone with me today
now that is so cool but
no i'll tell you what it was because
i've been making decisions to change my
network
i'm turned i'm tired i i overnight i am
sick and tired
of
the same group
that
maybe for whatever reason they're just
not happy with something i did
and
and oh he did that and he did this and
he said that not even like that
but
i need a new story right so i made the
decision i went on the chalkboard and
started saying new friends new network
don't complain about them they are where
they are it's not anybody else's fault
no whatever i'm getting in mind it's us
we're not satisfied with that game we
want a different game yeah a new game
because everybody else is hanging around
those people they're fine they're all
having a good time and i'm the one
disappointed so i'm the one that has to
go to the white the chalk board
and map out oh i need a new network it's
not his fault
it's not don't be disappointed with him
i need to change nobody else in the
world needs to change
and so ever since i was 25 years old
when i went to a treatment center and
and had to confront my drug addiction
the one thing i learned there that was
so valuable was you ha you are
responsible
then they confused me with you're
responsible but it's not really your
fault because you got a disease i'm like
which one is it am i responsible
or do i you know and i chose to say hey
it's not the deceased i i am responsible
and i haven't used drugs for 35 36 years
so um
super well done now i need to apply that
same
that same calculation to oh i want to
change my network on the phone with the
president
of mexico you need to learn how to
communicate with people
okay the the the the site here says the
powerpoint says learn to become a
professional salesperson
when i know when i think of the
professional salesperson
i think about a professional
communicator
someone who knows how to make contact
someone who knows how to control a
conversation i don't think about a
swindler i don't think about a tricky
dude i don't think about a huckster i
don't think about a scam artist i think
about
dude this guy showed me something i
didn't know you know how many things
that i almost bought were the wrong
thing but a professional salesperson
with a full pipeline and said no no you
don't want that
one of the best salespeople i know okay
guy named robert i'm not going to give
his last name because i don't have
permission i'm sure he wouldn't mind 25
billion worth of real estate hey robert
is this a good deal
yeah you know but that's not the one i
would do i would buy this one over here
if i were you okay
see
he's a professional he's a communicator
he'll tell me what i'm doing wrong he'll
tell me when i'm right tell me when i'm
wrong he'll challenge me he's not
playing games trying to like
match tones i saw this video the other
day matching people's song did you see
it okay get
right at the right moment
at the right moment
lower your voice and i don't want to do
that i'm talking about a professional
salesperson that doesn't have to rely on
tricks because their pipeline's so big
there's seven billion people on the
planet that are qualified and interested
in buying your product you do not need
to trick people and that's why so many
people think commission i don't want to
be a salesperson equals i don't want to
be a huckster well you don't have to be
if you're a professional my mother was
there for me when i didn't need her to
be there for me okay okay she didn't she
never let me down but but that doesn't
mean she pushed me up
you understand the difference
my mom was a great mother she was always
there for me it didn't mean she pushed
me up to the next level though because
every time i went to my mom and said mom
let me tell you what i'm doing she would
be like that's awesome
but just son remember i love you just
the way you are
how many of you have a parent that will
tell you that just remember
[Music]
i was 50 years old and she would still
tell me that she's 70 she was 78 at the
time she's like
just remember
[Music]
i love you just the way you are
you've done enough when's enough enough
grant you're doing fine grant i love you
just the way you are love yourself the
way you are man i'm like but i don't
i can't lie to myself i do not love this
i don't chuck knows what i'm talking
about chuck hates himself
chuck knows he can do more
am i right chuck
and then he's trying to communicate that
to his wife or his wife to get it and
his wife is like chuck what's wrong with
you are you broken chuck you need a
therapist
okay and then he's gonna go see the
therapist like i did and the therapist
can be like oh yeah you got add
you got you got that the ocd you got the
the the opd you got the
ocdacddd you know
i said no i got the the the
the osd
i'm obsessed with success disease
i'm obsessed
and i want my damn two hundred dollars
back don't tell me i'm an add i take an
offense to that okay i don't add i
multiply
[Music]
i'm trying i'm trying to figure out how
to run 70 businesses and have 70 000
employees i'm not worried
what you worried about you worried about
how many browsers i got open in my mind
the people that operate this planet the
handful the one percenters
have different information than you have
okay they're not talking about going to
college
they're not talking about saving money
[Music]
you don't hear wealthy people talking
about i need to buy a house
[Music]
warren buffett you know warren buffett
warren buffett is not like i need to buy
a house
[Music]
i have to have a home to live in
warren buffett bought one house his
whole life
he never talks about it
what's he buying
he's buying businesses what's he
investing his money in businesses
right he's not buying a house where
money dies
when steve jobs died
when steve jobs died where did his money
come from
one place was apple he owned some apple
stock but that was not the majority of
his wealth
majority of steve jobs wealth when he
died
was from
no itunes is apple
no
it was an investment
uh look it up uh what's the name of the
company uh everybody's going to know the
name of the company
pixar pixar pixar he owned he was he was
one of the founders three founders of
pixar
that's where most of his wealth was from
investment so to get to the top of the
food chain you got to
to get to the legacy well to be able to
leave your family something which is
really what everybody wants to do er no
every once you have the bmws you have
the bmws once you have the country club
you have the country club once you have
the gucci belt you have the gucci belt
once you go on a yacht trip you go on
the yacht once you fly first class well
you've done it even when you go out and
buy your own plane you've done it at
some point you're gonna be like okay now
what
now what when do i start giving back
you're not going to give back to society
until you create indestructible wealth
which is really what everybody wants to
do everybody wants to give more and help
out more and make a difference how many
of you want to change
two things if you want to change
number one you gotta change
[Applause]
you want you want to change a little bit
change a little bit you want to change a
lot change a lot
to change you got to change
and number two
you have to learn how to talk to people
you got to learn how to communicate you
have to learn how to stand on a stage
and communicate
maybe it's not this stage
maybe it's not 35 000 people
maybe it's one person
that's a stage
your house is a stage you're going to
talk to your spouse
your business is a stage you're going to
be talking to the treasury department
selling them stop the madness
stop the madness we're not going to save
money here we're going to make money
here we're going to go get money here
you're going to have a stage with your
lawyer your lawyer's going to say don't
do it stop the madness
you're a lawyer dude i'm running a
business tell me how we can do it
i don't ask lawyers and accountants for
business advice
record the data you're an accountant
do the job you're the lawyer
me run the business into the ground
okay we're gonna run it into the ground
we're gonna do it grant's way
not the lawyer's way
and not the accountant's way
two things you gotta do to change folks
you gotta change
and you need an audience
when you're in front of a customer do i
have your intention
when you're getting attention you need
to know
something else is trying to get their
attention too
you're in competition with everything
and you don't need to make attention
you need to get attention
they're tied together attention is money
get it keep it multiplied that means
when i'm in a meeting i need to get your
attention i need to get it i need to be
sure i have it
i need to keep it
and then i need to multiply that
attention because if you don't keep my
full attention you ain't gonna get none
of my money grant rant of the day the
one you need to live with wake up to
every day is that right there
okay beat the sun up folks you gotta
beat the sun up if you can't beat up the
roll-up of the sunnah
you're going to get beat up in life okay
i've been doing this for a long time now
say beat that thing up that monster out
there that warms this planet that
nourishes and gives us light but you
can't live a 10x life if you're not
beating the sun up so many of you
complain about how much time you have
you don't have time man because you
don't beat the sun up get started early
and when you get started early that
means you need to shut it down early
okay shut it down early so you get sleep
i was i was i was asleep last night at
nine o'clock so i could beat the sun up
tomorrow this morning and see
the world wake up with me
i don't need to spend time with a mentor
i need to study a handful of people that
have proven over time that they were
important
and and that they did something walt
disney he's a mentor of mine one guy
almost went bankrupt three times that is
a spiritual adventure
like like hey man how do you do that how
do you have a dream how would schultz
with starbucks i don't like his
political viewpoints
but i do like the fact that
no everybody told him starbucks was a
bad idea he's like yeah okay well
whatever it's a terrible idea steve jobs
total maniac like neurotic i wouldn't do
any of that stuff but i do i do like the
guys ferocious commitment so if i can
take rob those pieces from different
people right
and say hey man i want to be more like
that guy or that gal right you know so
so you know what i'm saying like like
that that's my that's my deal like how
can i mix it up with jared how can i i'm
interested in leaving something
that lasts longer than i do i know a lot
of people say they they learn from their
losses but i i don't
i i learn i get better because of my
successes i i don't need a lot of
kryptonite moments
i'm not interested in those yeah it just
takes longer to grow again to get back
to where you want to be you know mike
mike told me something the other day in
the hot box he says you know
because he started thinking differently
about some of the stuff i was saying to
him
and he said i said you know mike i know
you blame you know you think your
success is what hurts you but i
guarantee if you look back
those first fights you were winning
everything about everything brightened
up in your life when you started winning
in life
he ran you know
my grades got better um
he's got more confidence dude of course
he even learned better i said you know i
i don't i don't learn from losses
i learn from successes and then i try to
repeat those things do more of those
things that are and then get the get the
get the get the the bucket gets bigger
yeah the right the rim gets bigger the
field goal gets bigger right everything
gets bigger it's easier to make the shot
because i have the winds and i think it
make it
i feel so bad for people particularly
around money that they never have the
victories
back to back enough victories to be like
wow what else could i do when i walked
out of treatment center the counselor
phil i think his name is bill phil was
confused he's like look hey man
because you know in in the treatment
centers you know you you basically share
all your secrets i always tell them like
i want to be rich i want to be famous i
want to write books and the guy's like
dude if you don't give up on all that
you will be back here in 30 days
he's like you need to be satisfied i
never forget the speech on the 28th day
health insurance had run out so they're
going to kick my right because the money
ran out he says if you don't give up on
all these ideas these these grand grand
illusions
the grandiosity you don't give up on all
that you will be hated
and i threw all that addiction and
obsession with destruction that you you
like understand as well as anyone and
have talked about so eloquently
i threw all that obsessive energy into
work
to become a master at
a few things
and and that's what's really changed my
life my direction to where i can just
run down a path and
and over the period of 35 years create
something for myself that you know i'm
sitting in a room with
makes you obsess
25 years ago
i had three friends
[Music]
my life has not always been this
i had three friends
one was a drug dealer
one was my girlfriend who didn't love me
she loved the drug dealer more than she
loved me
she loved the drugs
she's still on drugs today
and my third friend couldn't be a friend
to himself much less to me
i had three friends in my entire life
i was the black sheep of my family
five kids
everybody in my household was worried
about grant
everybody my two sisters
my brother
my mother
were convinced
i would end up in prison
or i would end up dead
i should not be here today
so at 25 i recommitted to my education
but this time i started studying not
things that were in books but people
that it actually created wealth
not people that had made money but
people that he created wealth
this is completely different i was no
longer studying accounting and economics
i was studying wealthy people and only
wealthy people i'm not talking about the
doctor that was a neighbor that makes a
million dollars a year and he's working
18 hours a day and he hates his job
right he's working seven days a week he
can't ever spend time with his family
i'm talking about the yacht people i'm
talking about the people that are
spending as much time as they want on
vacation i'm talking about the car
dealer that had uh 28 car dealerships or
82 car dealerships
that has indisposable money and i
quickly realized something that the
wealthy people
had financial freedom and no one else
did okay a very small percentage of
people lots of people have money my
uncle had millions of dollars he was
terrified about his money wouldn't spend
it acted like a miser buried money in
the backyard
i realized my parents had it wrong the
information i had that was wrong i
started comparing the wealthy people to
what my dad did my dad worked every day
every day of the week if he wasn't
working at the office he was working in
the yard
they saved money they cut their own
grass okay
we ate all our food we turned the lights
off we didn't waste anything
and that was uncertainty it was
insecurity and it was fear and it
perpetuated uncertainty insecurity and
fear and and all the lessons about money
money doesn't grow on trees a penny
saved is a penny earned eat all your
food people are starving okay money
money you don't waste it don't play with
it all that creates insecurity
and it's incorrect once i decide i'm
going to do something it's like
there's no let the the chance of me
letting go of something that's important
to me
a friend
like
i am
either the best or worse friend a person
has
why so because because like if if if you
and i are in a club and something goes
down i will be there
swinging it out
okay i have no chance of winning the
fight i can only be a distraction to the
thing
but you're not going to see me just run
yeah right so so
um
and i'm not going to run for my dreams
like i'm not going to run for my kids
i'm not going to run from elena i'm not
going to
there's nothing elena could do to cause
me to like run away from her i'd get
comfort and nurture from them when i
failed that's not what you need you need
to expand your network when i was
getting comfort from the people that
loved me and accepted me as i was i
should have been expanding my network by
investing in conferences summits and
masterminds to get access to the way
other people think the way other people
operate and to their success so i could
learn from them and possibly as
importantly with the network you get to
collaborate with other people we look
for
compliance and willingness before
intelligence um
so you don't look for skill you look for
someone who's i don't look for potential
i never look for potential
what do you look for then just like yes
i'm willing to do look we hired the way
the patriots do
right
you know they don't hire the best guys
right
they never do
they get all the rings though they do
okay there's three people in charge on
that team there's not
33
it is a dictator
there's a dictator on that team
if you study all sports i mean it's
pretty much like that too you know i
mean portland portland doesn't really
have that you know he leaves curry alone
and he leaves you know um durant durant
alone
and they're doing good you know that
means a different style right but but um
but somebody's those are with superstars
yeah man it's got to be so hard yeah
cause everyone's got a personality yeah
opinion yeah but so let's see how long
that legacy can last what are they three
years now yeah so you know that area
let's see if they tear themselves apart
but i know that new england patriots
thing works consistently there's an
owner he's not involved
he just trusted the coach this guy bill
runs the deal yeah
and then and then bill gives the ball to
brady and says a good deal yeah you know
so
uh they hire they they they they
hire from the lower half of the draft
they don't overpay for anybody
and if and if you don't comply you're
looking off the team they're going to
win without a great person
i like that
i'm in the desert right now doing deals
okay i mean and literally look
what's the difference 141 million
or 140
million dollars on a 140 million dollar
deal
let's just do this thing and get it done
i'm out here in the desert how how odd
is it out here
in the moment sir i'll say about 100
let me just get my it's a cool winter
day it's a cool
106. it's 106 degrees out here dude look
look at you jacking me around about what
million dollars
let's do the deal just do the damn deal
just say yes to me everybody you should
have no money my financial advice to any
young kid is like dude invest all the
money in yourself first
every penny
in yourself
educating yourself education brand
clothes looking good uh teeth whatever
whatever whatever you need to make
yourself feel good about yourself right
and and then invest in yourself in your
friends in in your neighborhood like
like so you feel good when you walk up
if you need to go to rehab go to rehab
pay the 30 grand
go there clean up you know if you've
made a bunch of mistakes with people go
pay go go clean all that [ __ ] up so you
don't have your attention on it and then
whatever invest in yourself and then
sooner or later if you're doing
investing the right things you're gonna
do better i can't build something big
and not need people
i have to have people i become more and
more dependent upon great people loyal
people
uh competent people as i get bigger so
that's what you're really looking for
opportunity will change my life when you
go work for a company when you guys make
a a a career change go work for somebody
that has opportunity that can change
lives
don't go where you're good at a job it
doesn't matter if you're good at a job
go where there's a vehicle
that can take you on a journey you guys
leave this environment right now you're
going to go to some job
you're not going to get this every day
you're not going to hear this every day
you're not going to get the stimulation
they're like what am i doing and but we
all need this every day i need it every
day man i got every day i got to be like
what's the opportunity man i got to wake
up every day what's the opportunity man
huh
i got two picks up in my eyelids i'm
like
what is it
what's the opportunity man
huh what is the opportunity what is
opportunity where
is the opportunity
and it looks
you look good
dude
and dude i want to be able to have so
much opportunity to do so much crazy
stuff that i can act like an idiot dude
i don't want any of that stuff i made a
commitment when i was a 25 years old and
broke okay i came up with a new plan
first thing i did was this okay
i made a plan so i could
retire rich
actually with me you could just drop the
retire thing because once you start
making money you're like i don't want to
retire i just want to make money man fun
okay no but most people don't like money
because they never have enough man to
have any fun with it
right or they make a little bit of money
and they blow it
and then the next thing you know they're
out of work and they're like oh i hate
money because the last time i had money
i blew it all i went to strip joints i
bought a ferrari erected i got in
trouble next you see what i'm saying
michael tyson probably doesn't really
like money because every time he got in
he
screwed it up
but but for those of you you need to get
rich plan
you need to get rich plan you don't need
to get by plan right now you got to get
my plan i want to get rich plan so you
need to understand what that takes and
the first thing it takes on the get rich
plan is income
you got to increase your income if you
make if you make if you got a job making
36 grand a year you got to wake up and
say you will never ever ever ever have
anything if you keep that job at 36
grand a year by the way the job is not
the problem it's the 36
that is the problem okay
so you got to figure out dude how do i
get from 36 to 360.
oh my god that's gonna be hard not
really if you take a look first of all
look at your commitment okay man i'm a
waitress okay good there's other
waitresses that are making 360 grand a
year you have to first make the decision
i know this sounds esoteric
nothing happens without
the decision
to get rich and understand the plan you
have doesn't work okay because the plan
your mom and dad had was never a
decision to get rich
it was to get by
right that's why they said diversify
that's why they said buy a house
remember the house that was one of the
plans a house does not make you rich
it's impossible it ties you down there's
no income associated with it okay so
every decision has got to be this i got
to get this number up to that that's why
i don't buy a house because me buying a
house doesn't get me 360 a year you get
it or 3 million a year
right what gets me that is income
there's a way to make a cold market warm
right you need a team you guys all of
you need a team you're going to start
with primerica that you know the entry
is cheap it doesn't cost a lot to get
involved but you need a team
and and what happens is you can only
knock on so many so many doors you can
only make so many phone calls so this is
a mistake that i made when i was uh 25
years old i i wanted to keep all the
money for myself well there was no money
right i was making everybody needs to
understand grant has not always been
this guy flying in a jet
okay i was making 60 000 a year and
trying to figure out how to make another
10.
okay okay now i'll make 70.
nothing changed
your life doesn't change you got 10
grand left over what do you do with it
typically people spend it
that didn't change anything so i
wouldn't hire anybody i didn't have an
assistant i didn't have anybody doing
the stuff i didn't know how to do nobody
was loading up the crm nobody was
calling my customers i was one little
sales guy i looked around me and there
was a bunch of other sales guys and none
of them had assistance so i kept doing
what these
uh uh uh
igmaranus people were doing
and then i looked at businesses what do
businesses do
oh they got assistance they got help
they got support they got phone lines
they got a business they got an office
right so i'm like i got to get a company
i didn't need to go start my own
business i needed an assistant
okay i needed somebody else making calls
i needed somebody to collab you need to
think you need to start thinking how
could you make 10 times more contacts
into that cold market some of you asking
every day like every day i get this
question dude why do you keep pushing so
hard why because i'm passionate about
charity
i
want to give back
i want to help
i wanted to help my mom when i was 16
and i couldn't i'm finally in a position
to help out the reason i have worked so
hard for 30 years was so i could have
money this is the way i looked at
everything hey hey grant get your money
right
get your money right take that extra
money the reason i worked hard extra
hours you were working a 40 hour week
and i was working 100 hour a week the
reason i worked the extra 60 hours was
so i had extra money
all extra money all extra money went
into real estate y'all didn't know i was
doing this
nobody knew i was doing this i was
working for car dealers and ashley
furniture and big retailers and big
companies i would travel on thanksgiving
to canada to get a check for 30 000 for
speaking miss my family on thanksgiving
day leave my family on thanksgiving day
man i miss so many thanksgiving every
thanksgiving for 20 years i went to
canada you know why because they don't
celebrate thanksgiving and i could get
money on that day and everybody's like
you're missing thanksgiving i missed the
super bowls i missed the world series so
that i could get extra money and drop it
into this thing and this money would
then create passive income for me
passive income that i could then give to
charity
okay i have either given or raised 200
million dollars for charity you can't do
that without money
it's impossible if you don't have any
money you should be doing flips
but you only should do flips and host
sales until you have money to find a
flip to find a flip i find a place uh
uh he wants to sell it i tell him i got
a buyer for it i i've never done this
this is not my space but i know guys
that teach us successfully and then i
put a contract on that and then go out
to the marketplace and sell that and
pick up the spread between
uh
what we contracted and what it's worth
what somebody else will pay for it okay
or flip could be hey i find a piece of
property i buy it with a little bit of
money as mine hey i'm gonna live here i
put three or four percent down or
nothing
fix it flip it that could be a flip okay
can you flip in on a descending mall is
it only working up anytime you can
always flip it only works in up markets
you you can always probably flip but
look when the footage is over it's over
when it's all over it's all over
everybody needs to think bigger go
bigger natalie she's over there would
you make a couple hundred grand last
year what a damn shame okay she needs to
start thinking about how would i go from
150 grand a year she's probably so happy
with herself right now this is the most
money i've ever made in my life people
around are saying oh my god you're doing
so good natalie this is great okay kayla
goes back to wisconsin oh my god you
worked for that maniac that barbaric
grant cardone that guy must be tough to
work for but she's getting paid good
money and they're all oh my god you're
doing so good kayla kayla needs to think
about how can she 10x
how do you do that
right how do you go from being a
personal assistant making 100 whatever
100 000 a year let's say i don't know
what kayla makes
okay it's below my pay grade i don't
need to know that how does she start
thinking about how do i turn this into a
million dollars regardless of whether
she's 20 or her position or wherever how
can she
multiply time how can she multiply money
how can she multiply opportunity go big
or
go go bigger
get rid of this go home option
okay i don't know who gave you guys this
option that's not an option i can't go
home i have to go bigger and by the way
i'm not interested in home i'm
interested in prosperity and paradise
i'd like to never go home so i've got
about 700 000 just sitting in the bank
yeah and it's been sitting there for
about two years now anyway we've got
there just kind of as a safety net we've
got about
1.5 million in debt and then we bring in
about 500 000 a month
and so my question is should i should i
keep that 700 000 there as a safety net
or should i be looking somewhere to
invest it or should i just invest it
right back into the company
okay well
well i mean like okay number one the
first thing i would tell you to always
do is keep investing in your company i
would not i would not hold this money on
reserve
okay money is to be used okay i got i
got a bunch of money sitting in my
pocket right now it is of no use to me
zero use to me
sitting in my pocket it's like is it a
cushion i mean what's gonna happen like
the only way that money helps me is if i
fall on my face and like it cushions my
you know it's stupid man but you see
we're all brought up save the money save
the money save the money save the money
reserve save for a rainy day something
bad's going to happen what i would do
with this dude is some portion of this
but i would expect because your business
is doing well you're already invested in
your money in your business right
yes so at some point if your business is
working bro what i want to do is i want
to get this money over here i would not
pay this debt off
this wouldn't even bother me by the way
okay
i don't even think about debt somebody
said the other day cardone said he
doesn't like to use debt not you need to
you need to pay attention to what i'm
teaching you
i want to use good debt debt
that i can use to make me money is good
debt
okay debt on a home isn't that good
okay so i don't know what your debt is
for
but i know this
yeah go ahead
the debts just uh operating costs you
know we've got a
buildings truck yeah good good good so
it's making you money that's part of
your business now this is what i would
do with this money though okay i want
this money how much do you earn a year
uh me personally or as a business you
personally
uh about 80. 80 000. so i'm gonna take
that 700 by the way i would take every
penny of it
and i want to put it in some i want to
put it into an investment
okay i want to put in an investment that
cannot be lost
so that excludes the entire wall street
okay okay
i want to put in an investment by the
way there are investments that cannot
that will not be lost i can show them to
you okay and i want that to earn me
seventy grand fifty to seventy thousand
dollars in year one passive income i
don't want you working for that money
what was the
so it was fish was the first thing you
saw well yeah but but but you know yeah
i had a drug problem really did you
really sell the car what was it like
when did you know when you really like
snap in zombies the way that you sell
right is there a strategy or no it's
just hot it's like it's mostly hard work
you think or there's a strategy of a lot
of stuff you teach is strategy yeah
that's right yes
there's there's no strategy that works
without somebody to talk to right so
what's but what's the ultimate what's
this
ultimate ultimate like like i've been
teaching strategy for 20 years but again
like if people would just spend time on
the funnel
on the traffic on the opportunity on the
market on the marketing side equation it
is the it is the it is the the holy
grail
like look around man look you know you
don't go to amazon and have anybody sell
anything to you it's the funnel
it's it's the traffic
so i made that i made that mistake of
thinking i'm going to be great at what i
say to them i'm going to close the deal
right you know
i got to keep my funnel closed uh uh
full i got to keep the funnel full so i
have something to close okay so how
about how about let's say assume that
you have that side figured out you're a
master of the funnel right yeah then you
don't need to then you won't even ask
this question you need to sell you won't
need you want but you have a sales force
right yeah yeah and there are things
they need to say but at the end of the
day if he's talking to 10 people a day
and another guy's talking to 200 people
a day
the guy that talks to 200 is going to
win the game and if there's one skill
you want to learn is how to how to move
through 200 without it causing you it's
like the ball players you see these guys
play involved they don't get upset
because they lose the game
like it doesn't bother them they're in
it for the long run they're they're you
know and this is what the sales guy or
sales manager doesn't know you got to
get people ready for the long game
every time we raise money for cardone
capital or somebody buys a seat for the
10x rug conference we come out here
yeah man
yeah you do it then okay
and then every once in a while my kids
come out here and they're like oh i
gotta throw you in pop i gotta throw you
in i gotta tell you wow wow
hey when
people should be studying the most
successful companies in the world not
not individuals
don't worry about dave or gary or tony
or grant
what are successful people doing
you know i
one of the biggest mistakes i've made in
my life was tracking
people that were doing better than me
[Music]
so what
like like like i made so many
decisions because
uh dave did it
or the millionaire next door
that that book
i don't want to be the millionaire next
door i want to know what jeff bezos is
doing i want to know what the boys at
google are doing okay why why does a guy
like mark zuckerberg go from college
dorm room to one of the richest people
on the planet
that's who we should be studying
and and don't listen to everybody else
because those people have financial
freedom to the point to where they they
can do anything they want
like you cannot mess up some of these
people's situation they couldn't screw
it up if they wanted to
so uh the 10x rule is is a it says hey
look you want to scale to a point
to where you have the life you deserve
it's not about the money you want or the
money you need
scale your business so you can walk away
from it and money never stops taking
care of you and your family you don't
need to study 27 different warrants
you study one more and you're probably
going to be good
most of us because of instagram and
facebook and youtube we're listening to
so many different people
that that people do nothing
this this is the new crisis of our era
people are doing nothing not because
they're lazy because they have data that
is conflicting
so if you listen to dave dave says buy a
house then you listen to grant grant
says that's stupid you're not going to
do anything
and if you're never going to buy any
real estate hey go ahead and buy one
house yeah you're going to regret it
later and you're going to be like i wish
i had done what cardone said but but you
got to do something and what you don't
want to do is listen
to god and the devil
because then you get stuck in purgatory
and you don't have any fun at all look
for somebody to help man there's people
all over this planet man just lost i
told my mom when i was 16 years old one
day one day i'm gonna be successful one
day
one day i'm gonna be successful and one
day i'm gonna help a lot of people
and i said that to her because i wanted
somebody to help me
see i've always loved helping people
always
i am most happy when i'm helping someone
else
nothing to do with money
if i can help somebody
not give them something but if i can
actually help somebody to feel better
about themselves
to know what to do in a phone call to
know what to do on a sales call to know
how to follow up their girlfriend or
their boyfriend or to solve some problem
in their life or how to get some money
why don't we do this man
why don't we make it 100 thank you man
and you keep it thank you boss thank you
yeah you see that big smile on his face
when i did that just like pop
help somebody looks like i'm showing off
all the time here's what you don't know
you don't see all the hard work the
years the years
don't quit okay if i had to quit
i wouldn't have the wife wouldn't have
the kids wouldn't have the bird wouldn't
have the cars wouldn't have the real
estate wouldn't have my middle my my
physical and my mental health i wouldn't
have the success nobody would know me
nobody would know me
so you see where i'm at today but you
don't see all the days that i got up
when i didn't want to get up
all the days when i went to work and
made a call when i didn't want to make a
call all the days that i called somebody
back that had rejected me over and over
and over again all the book publishers
that wouldn't publish my books all the
tv people that said no man you're too
noisy
all that
all the things that are happening to you
right now the sick days the illnesses
the family that's pulling against you
the friends that counted you out
the problems you've had in your past
whatever it is look you can use it as an
excuse or you can use it as fuel i just
had a coaching call with some friends of
mine they come in every month and and
they're working on their business
they're going to bust a million dollars
this month when i met them they were
literally the company was not making
money they're going to make a million
dollars they asked me a question today
that i want to talk about they're like
dude how are you
everybody we talk to talks about being
nice to their people taking care of
their people doing this for their people
why is it the the the answer you have is
different i said what do you mean well
it seems like you're hard on people
i said no man i'm not being hard on
people
i'm just trying to take care of my
environment
i'm not trying i don't practice being a
a dik
i'm trying
to take care of my environment my
decisions are about my environment right
so little grant a little grants this
this little phone right here this is
little grant he got issues he needs to
clean up his issues grant's got to get
hard on grand
okay you you guys out there y'all y'all
so soft on your people is because you're
soft on yourself
right that's why you end up with no
money
you end up with people betraying you you
end up with people taking advantage of
you even your kids don't appreciate you
do you got to be hard on yourself i'm
hard on everybody around me but mostly
i'm hard on me the theme that runs in my
life is just disappointment throughout
the whole thing particularly the first
from fifth to from 10 years old to 25
and then 25 to
50
you know
yeah i was doing better because i i had
a drug problem at 16. oh you did yeah
was that the disappointment or was it
like no no no no the drugs were just the
drugs were a byproduct you know it was
the disappointment was
uh you know
the school thing
school was disappointing no uncles no
dad right no i didn't know direction
just boredom
that's why what you do with these
the races at least keep somebody
occupied for some moment of time that
gives them a goal big enough and a
challenge sure i didn't have any
challenges you didn't have anybody like
setting some goals up in front of us no
no no when my dad died i kept waiting
for one of the uncles to step up and
they didn't
and that pissed me off because i'm like
dude somebody's got to step up and give
me a little guidance here but you but
you had older um brothers my older
brother died when i was 20. right so 10
years after my dad died
so there was no men
just a bunch of women and mom mom wasn't
like setting big goals for you no no my
mom my mom my mom grew up in breadlines
so
you know i'd go to my mom i remember i
did a deal when i was 30.
bought my first piece of real estate
and
mom i bought this piece of real estate
it was three million dollars a 1.9
million dollars and she's like wow
that's great but you know i just i love
you just the way you are
right and i hung up the phone she said
that to me a thousand times
and i hung the phone and said yeah but i
don't love me the way i am
and then my counselor buddy dale says
you need to love yourself the way you
are i said ain't never going to happen
dude
right i said that's the big lot
i don't want to love me in the way i
want to become the guy i should be
nobody ever taught me when i was going
to school 17 years of school nobody ever
said hey maybe you want to stack up some
experiences
and then what happens is kids rather
than going to college what they do today
is they'll go travel for
for a year
what you ought to flip it
go get your work ethic again
bank some money
make some money i'm gonna do this
left-handed
bank some money and then go on the trip
of your life
oh left-handed i'm so good i'm so good
at
everything
you got to have confidence man so look
look look and by the confidence comes
from doing stuff
comes from doing business
not from traveling right like i know
people that traveled when they were
young and then they go back into the
workplace into the business place and
they're like i don't have any confidence
in business
you want to have confidence in business
confidence and money confidence with
your family confidence that you can go
places and look money might not make you
happy i know some of you believe that
but
it gives you the security to go where
you want to do what you want and stay as
long as you want if you can get that
money right yesterday i had to make a
phone call to a guy hey bro you're not
getting the deal
let me tell you what the deal is it's a
115 million loan
okay and there's two groups doing the
deal
they're going to hate seeing this when
they see it one group is at .40 one
group is point twenty five zero this is
my friend right here my friends too much
money man and this guy this other guy
over here got me more proceeds he gave
me more assurances
i had to tell my friends sorry bruh
sorry
i gotta go with my boy down here
oh man grant we've been friends we've
been friends you like me i like you
we've been to dinner you know my family
sorry bro
i don't know what to tell you dude
it would not be fair to my family to my
children to my investments to my money
to my hard work to this deal to my
investors it would not be fair by the
way if there were no investors it would
not be fair to me
to pay more money to do business with
you because you're my friend sorry i
don't know what to tell you
this is where you guys all get confused
he's my friend if he's my friend
then i should not have to pay for that
relationship
by the way if he's my friend
he will be my friend after i make this
hard decision did i remember hearing a
story my twin brother told me years ago
about this dude i think his name was
vincent
wealthy wealthy dude in london
everywhere he went
[Applause]
he went on a choppa what a way to ride
on
okay i knew i was not in a place that
ever knew that
but i always thought every once in a
while i'd be like dude what would it
take
you know what i did i quit on the dream
before i even had the dream i'm like
i'll never have that quit on the dream
before i had the dream
i've done this my whole life don't make
this mistake
don't quit on the dream before you have
the dream okay and when i heard that
vincent was flying around on a
helicopter all the time i quit on my
dream
before i even had it i just assumed i
could never do that i'll never have that
and then one day i went back and started
looking at dude what do i have to do to
go back and make my dreams a reality
and even if they don't become a reality
at least have the dream
i was in a deal i was in a deal and
i sold the deal i made four million
dollars on the deal i already knew and i
made the mistake of judging based on the
profit rather than the opportunity okay
the guy that bought the deal from me
ended up selling it for
um
13 million more
so you would have made 17. i made 17
million rather than 4 million okay so
now why do i tell you that because i did
not know when i was a young salesman at
25 26 27 years so any more than jared
yeah when he started working here or
when he had a job at that that corporate
company cut your bonus yeah they jacked
you um he did not know then he would be
negotiating
100 million dollar contracts at a
company
i did not know when i was selling
automobiles in 25 26 years old that i
was preparing
for
100 million dollar deals when i would be
55 years old yeah like you you guys
don't like you got to be more positive
about where your show ends up right you
got to train today like i'm going to be
in a big deal tomorrow
right because it's going to happen if
you just stay focused on it so for those
of you jared made a good point about the
sales thing you don't think you're a
salesperson because you're you're
running a dental business yeah your top
line is your revenue line that's called
sales dude have you got a problem guys
if you if you get a lot so much
distraction right okay so let me know
right if you if you buy a car and you
pay too much like like you could every
time you could deal poorly and you could
pay too much money and interest you
could pay too much money for the car
that could cost you
five to ten grand you could buy a house
and negotiate a bad loan you could buy
at the wrong time you could negotiate a
bad deal that could cost dude in 2008
people lost hundreds of thousands of
dollars and people made millions and
hundreds of millions watching the
opportunity so it you can't see
opportunities you're not ready for okay
you cannot catch a wave
you're not prepared to surf
it is impossible facebook instagram
twitter
snapchat
uh linkedin
i probably posted about this event more
than the entire room combined
today
in addition to all the other stuff i'm
doing how many old people here let me
see your hand if you consider yourself
an old person
okay thank you thanks sir appreciate it
you're like dude it's just kind of like
i i didn't do it i'm 61 years old man
i'm 61 years old and and i'm banging on
these mechanisms because they're gifts
they're gifts they're gifts from the
gods
if you have a great service and a great
great product and you have a great
company raise your hand if you have
those three things
do you got to tell the world
okay because the the cycle the business
cycle your business survivability okay
your business success is dependent upon
first marketing why i can't do it i
don't have the money it's because your
goals are wrong
you're not going to pay for the
marketing and advertising who's going to
pay for it
the guy that paid for the 15 000 package
what what's the roi what is the roi on
nothing
okay
what's your return on investment
[Applause]
i grew up in the roi school okay i have
14 businesses today started four of them
in the last 60 days
[Music]
okay i i want expansion
what is the roi
this is the business consultant i need
to see the roi dude i don't i don't do
rois on any
of my businesses
i make a decision is it a good business
decision
do people need to know who i am okay i
have never studied the return on an ad
that i did on youtube or facebook or
instagram or cnbc i don't need a return
i need people to know me
okay you guys need to switch this thing
you need to switch it how many have cash
in the bank let me see hands if you have
cash in the bank good good then you're
not committed to your business to the
degree that you have cash in the bank
how many have equity in your homes let
me see a hand if you have equity in your
house raise your damn hands y'all proud
of it okay if to the degree that you
have equity in your house you are not
committed to your business and you will
never take big pharma down
do you need that money to fight the war
i don't i don't have equity in a house
okay i have equity in my business
okay i get cash
i put it in my business
i get more cash i put it in more
business right i put it in people
knowing me because if they don't know me
who's going to win the war whoever's
best known wins best product never wins
you want to write this down best product
never wins never has one never will win
best known always wins if you don't have
your thing whatever it is the job the
money the girl your goals your dreams
you gotta leave where you are
you can't win a mission from home
we don't win wars at home
you understand you got to go someplace
the world is changing how many agree the
world's changing right now
dude the world is changing it's changing
so fast right you got it you got to take
the old ideas that you have and you got
to look at them again today and say hey
is this true anymore
is it true what am i doing what are me
and the wife doing what business are we
building do i need to work for myself do
i really or do i need to find the right
vehicle that can go far enough long
enough provide enough revenue for the
right people and get to the top of the
food chain you've probably heard me say
set a target and never drop that target
ever we don't drop targets here okay i'm
not a communist
i'm not the enemy and i eat the devil
i got enough people pulling against me i
set a target okay if i set a target if
i'm honest i don't lie to myself either
by the way like a lot of you sales
people out there
you sales people that lie to yourselves
you sales people that are dishonest you
sales people that are unethical you know
what i'm talking about i'm talking about
most of you
you set a target below your potential
you're unethical right you have this
potential and you set your target here
or somebody else set your target
you're a damn liar lying to your mom
your wife your husband your kids
lying to yourself today i have about 300
million dollars worth of equity
earning
about six percent a year
on average
18 million dollars a year
before i go to work
and i still work
so
houses don't do that cars don't do that
businesses do that rental properties do
that
you take equity out of a house or a car
you put it into a business that produces
cash flow
and you create personal financial
freedom for yourself your household your
family your friends and your investors
okay this doesn't stop you can't stop
this the economy tanks it still keeps
coming
this is how financial wealth has been
created for hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of years
and it's not going to stop these these
are tried and true methods get the
equity out of your car in your house and
get it into something that produces cash
flow everybody's going to lose something
dude i've lost dogs i lost my older
brother
you you're not if if the reason you're
going to become a drug addict because
you lost your daddy
man everybody should be a drug addict
everybody that never connected i'm like
oh you were abandoned by your father he
abandoned you i'm like he died heart
blew up in his chest yeah okay so i'm
like what what is the problem here the
reason i got on drugs broke was because
i was bored you're bored i would have
taken anything
you could offer me homosexuality yeah
let's roll i'm in uh you could have
offered me a uh
a marathon
yeah i'll do i'll run a marathon you
could have offered me
anything that would have been
interesting
right i would have i would have taken it
i was looking for leadership man i was
looking for activity i was looking for
aggression yeah what can i do
you know it's interesting mcgregor he
talks about he's like look i don't win
because of my skills i win because i'm
obsessed
and and so i took out of that treatment
center um
they introduced me to other drugs by the
way they wanted me to take this these
other uh adderall or phenobarbital or
something did you take those or no i
brought them home with me and threw him
away
and said you know what my new drug is
going to become
success remember this 64 of a businesses
in america break even or lose money okay
check this out 22 out of 28 million
small businesses in america have no
employees zero employees what kind of
business is that man
i am the master and the slave
i am the prisoner the warden the
jailhouse the system
dude you're stuck that's not a business
you cannot do the solopreneur thing even
though you see some guy on instagram
rolling out with a lambo
okay
that's not a business a business is
people in a company
anybody know any major successful person
that that didn't have a bunch of
employees anybody here know any great
company that had one employee
one flow of income
that didn't use debt
okay caterpillar debt coca-cola debt
ford motor company debt they had to use
debt you got to use debt to expand you
can't stay small and expect the world to
know you it's impossible how many of
your parents told you this don't get too
much attention
fly under the radar don't touch your own
horn be seen and not
heard dude you don't get attention today
you have absolutely zero chance of being
successful
money
follows attention let me tell you the
thing that i'm most proud of this month
every month
these are checks okay about 300 checks i
think i got a bunch more coming here
that i just finished signing these go
out every month what john
okay this is not payroll
we got 100 people here to get payroll
this this is not payroll checks
these are people that i pay every month
because they invested money with me in
my real estate
cash flow baby cash is not king
cash flow is king
and it's the strong people that make the
hard decisions that end up with the cash
flow
you softies end up spending all your
money
the softies have the cash flow bleed out
of the organization and it goes back
into the marketplace my cash flow ends
up in the hands of my friends my family
my momsies my dadsies my uncles my aunts
my cous my friends my buds my johns
jared the people that like hey grant i
like what you're doing dude let's just
start with the aggression thing okay so
like when i tell you guys like hey you
know like i am aggressive and i and
aggressive works for me
the reality is everyone's aggressive
yeah like from the very first moment
like if you watch sperm's sperm cell
is it a cell i think sperm right so when
it's finding an egg you're talking about
massive aggression yeah you're talking
about obsessive
uh
tremendous
like if if that was the original
beginning of the individual which i
don't think it is we're talking about
a trajectory
more violent
uh with more purpose more driven that
means all of us have that
you know and and like if you ever just
go go google well you know the the
activity of a sperm right yeah that is
it's pretty violent yeah right now it's
a crazy stack because like you're like
like the chances of you being born are
like one in a billion or something like
that yeah there's a lot of them a lot of
them competing for that for that
connection right so
um and then even when you make it you
might not make it
so
when people say man you're too
aggressive you're not aggressive enough
right you're the the only people that
have problems with aggressive again i
would talk about mike tyson just because
it's so fresh in my mind yeah he's like
man man but granted you know the
aggression thing and the ego and the
accomplishments and he's like it's too
much and i'm like no dude
it was fine yeah mike when you were
winning you were doing better in all
areas of life
the only people you didn't have a
problem mike the people around you had a
problem with it yeah they were trying to
filter you down yeah and i said you know
i said when you
i'll bet that other areas of your life
were actually affected because of your
winning
not when you were losing when you were
winning he's like you know actually his
grades he was terrible student he says
when i won my first fight my grades got
better
i said that's right bro because you're
winning
and winning's important even in our
society day we say don't be aggressive
don't be noisy don't promote yourself
too much don't win too much don't
succeed too much don't get too much
money you know and
this is probably why school didn't gel
with you dude because you you had this
you you were able able to keep awake
this this mission that you're gonna be
somebody this is what they didn't teach
you in school this is the only reason i
went to school i wanted money
64 percent of all businesses in america
break even or lose money
listen what i'm telling you right now 64
of every business in america there's 28
million of them
break even or lose money and it doesn't
matter if the economy is good or bad
they break even or lose money here's the
phenomenal thing okay
break even shouldn't be a category
who would make break even a category
break in even is losing
if i told you that you're going to put a
bunch of resources a bunch of time
you're going to work yourself every day
you're not going to see your wife and
your kids most of the time you're going
to be terrified every second of every
day
to break even
what would you say how many of you
looked at your finances this morning be
honest how many of you looked at every
account you had this morning let me see
hands
three or four five people i look at my
finances every day every morning i look
at my finances
i want to confront
management of the household i am in
charge of the money in my household
every single day for 35 years i look at
my finances every single day
how much money is in this account how
much money is in this account how much
money is in this guy how much money is
in this account one thousand dollars 1
000 u.s dollars for anybody that knows
why i look at my cash accounts every day
[Music]
no not so i can 10x it so i can get rid
of it i don't want money
i want my money having babies
okay this little dude on this 50 what's
his name
whatever i need him to make some babies
for me
okay i need him to populate my other
bank accounts
so the reason i look at how much money i
have every day is i got i got to put him
to work
this dude needs to get to work even
though he's dead
he needs to go to work for me
you understand money is trash
money is garbage
okay help me out here cash is
king that's what you were told you know
who told you that
the banks told you that
cash flow is king
cash flow say it again man cash flow is
king so if you give someone a call let's
say you've sold a stack of like 200
leads to dial through right and you get
a salesman who wants to
speak to everybody like he's going to
speak some of those they have no money
they have no job and they want to sell a
ten thousand dollar product and they
waste 45 minutes in that call
would that be smart or not smart he he
shouldn't have started that call with
one product
why why because he works at a company
that has one product that's stupid go go
some other place because we're kids
okay who does that amazon doesn't do it
grocery stores don't do it starbucks
doesn't do it no but nobody no matter
how good that one product is nobody can
build a business or any kind of success
on one product or let's say a couple of
products two or three products right the
average company out there yeah
you need more than one product you need
one product okay like like if i try to
hit everybody with a ten thousand dollar
product or even a one dollar even one
even a hundred somebody with a one
dollar product i miss the guy that wants
to spend ten thousand so the itc value
okay so the idea is go work for a
company that has a whole suite of
products give you much you can sell
something to everybody right basically
right yeah okay i like that cool like we
probably have i don't know we probably
have a hundred different products on our
website this used to be a goal of mine
to make one million dollars a year
that was my goal when i was 35 years old
one day i said to myself one day i said
self
little
g-dog g dog one day young man i wrote
this over and over and over again i
talked to myself in the mirror i'd sit
on the toilet and say one day
one day
i'm gonna i'm gonna make a million
dollars
one day one day and people used to tell
me that's crazy dude
like why do you think so big this is
when people were telling me not to
they're like why do you need to do all
that why do you just be happy just be a
good person okay be happy that you live
in america be happy that you have meals
and be happy you've got good health and
all the things that the people around
you that quit on money that quit on
financial freedom that quit on
possibility they quit on their potential
all the things those people will tell
you
to try to convince you to quit
when in reality what they're really
trying to do is make sense of why they
quit i would tell my 25 year old self do
do whatever you have to do
to make sure you don't ruin your name
you have to be the most dependable
person anybody knows
starting with yourself you have to be
the person you depend on okay so if
smoking weed on the weekends or drinking
or having hangovers or hanging out with
those people
like makes you feel less about yourself
less you have less trust for yourself
you've got to knock those things off
when this is done maybe make a list
no no make a list
go maybe make a list of things that you
need to knock off to destroy your own
personal sense of trust in yourself
this is a big thing that i did when i
was 25.
i started doing whatever i told somebody
i would do i was going to do if i told
you i was going to punch you in the
mouth i punch you in the mouth right
then okay if i told you i was gonna be
there at four o'clock i'd be there early
if i told you
uh i was gonna stay late i would stay
late whatever it was i started building
trust back within myself because the
reality is nobody was gonna trust me
i had destroyed so much trust and
respect with others
and told them over and over again oh
it's gonna be different this time so old
25 year old grant rebuild the trust you
have in yourself
and keep doing that until other people
start saying hey you changed
you're different now and that heart that
started happening literally within about
three to six months of me starting to
make that commitment to say hey i'm
going to start
rebuilding my own personal trust in
myself
my personal self-esteem came up i wasn't
using drugs anymore i wasn't using
alcohol anymore i wasn't going out on
the weekends i was working
when my friends were playing so
i'm just going to look it up just so i
don't i'm an entrepreneur yeah okay you
know what you ever looked it up mm-hmm i
i kind of know intuitively
someone who starts businesses and you
know person who organizes and operates a
business or business is taking on listen
but this is the important part this is
good for your young viewer taking on
greater than normal financial risk in
order to do so
by definition the second half of that
most people are not entrepreneurs
because they never take on any risk
like they're they're holding on to their
money they got cash in the banks they
got equity in their houses they're
saving money saving for retirement if
you're doing any of that versus putting
the balls against the [ __ ] wall right
you're like what are you doing dude
you're you're more committed people are
more committed to the equity in their
home
than they are to the equity of their
brand or business so i made this mistake
for years
in your own life yeah you must operate
okay you must operate like
your life depends on it
okay life-threatening life-threatened i
operate best when i am under a threat
time threat financial threat
uh threat to lose something there's got
to be a loss for you to stay on your
game this is why i tell so many people
get your money out of the bank and get
it back into the marketplace
do not have cash sitting in the bank
cash in the bank is exactly what your
mom and daddy told you it was it is an
emergency a security blanket why johnny
has money in in the wall of his house is
because he first had this idea i'm gonna
put money there
to avoid the ir and the s and number two
i'm gonna have it there just in case i
need it i'll go get me a little two
inches or whatever i need of it okay
johnny's got to get that money out of
the wall out of the bank
okay and back into the system so it pays
him i did not come for money
i came from nothing
nothing there was a time when i could
not afford this jacket
that i have on so if you're struggling
with money today i understand
i also understand that if you come from
nothing that should not be a reason you
stay with nothing
once you drop the reasons and the
excuses
and the problems and the economy and the
government and we just changed over
didn't y'all just change over
once you draw i'm too young i'm too old
once you drop the excuses and decide hey
i want success i want to be happy who
wants to be happy
good everybody wants to be happy who
wants to be healthy
excellent who wants a lot of friends
excellent
don't spend money on dumb stuff
25 years old keep this in mind for 35
years i didn't spend one penny on
alcohol
not one penny on drugs
literally what i was saving
about i wasn't i wasn't doing dumb stuff
on the weekends i wasn't wrecking cars
and getting in trouble i wasn't having
to hire lawyers i didn't waste any money
for 25 years on dumb stuff you know when
you don't drink you don't gamble
people to drink gamble
they take risks they would never ever
take
right they don't show up when they
needed to the next day when they do show
up they show up with a hangover none of
that happened to me for 25 years forget
making money forget adding skills forget
getting talented the fact that i was no
longer destroying myself my self-worth
my respect i wasn't making mistakes
wasn't getting in car wrecks wasn't
having to hire lawyers wouldn't wouldn't
have them be thrown in jail none of that
was happening for 25 years if you can
just stay out of trouble
be a wild man but stay out of trouble if
you could just do that i guarantee you
that'll be successful okay and keep in
mind i wasn't wasting money that means
i'm not wasting money on drugs and
alcohol and bad decisions and bad people
and
uh the vip bottles and trips last minute
oh let's go to vegas this weekend we
can't afford it but let's do it
to be life is to be lived you only have
one life that's what my friends were
saying to me they were sucking me down
the vortex of destruction
so
imagine if you spent the next five or
ten years not wasting money on
this is the hard part now it's number
four
watches cars trips and [ __ ]
i wasn't spending money on any of that
stuff
my friends were going on trips to greece
for three days i said dude i i don't i
haven't earned that trip yet okay i'm
not going to greece for three days
because i haven't earned the right to go
to greece for three days
now i just finished i'm on my fourth
week
rome bucharest i'm just telling you the
upside if you pay the price today and
don't do a little grant i'm not talking
to you i'm talking a little grant
okay if you don't do the dump right now
i went to rome bucharest
dubai let's see if i missed one
singapore malaysia
thailand the maldives and now
mykonos okay one day i'm going to spend
a month or two on that yacht right there
i guarantee you i'm going to spend a
month or two on that yeah it's all going
to be paid out of passive income
passive income cash flow okay i made a
decision at 25 not to spend any money
out of earned money see this is what the
super successful do they go all in
okay so at 25 years old i made a
decision until i have extra money so
much extra money that i don't have to
worry about living i don't have to worry
about food i don't have to worry about
bills i don't have to worry about
emergencies
i'm not going to invest any of that
money and when i do invest it it's going
to go into something that will produce
more cash flow for me for 25 years
that's what people don't know about
you guys hear me ranting having fun
throwing my stuff on the internet what
you don't know what you didn't see was
the 25 years of me just stacking cash
waiting
to find the right vehicle to invest that
money in see this is the problem i had
as a young salesman dude i was like okay
i'm gonna make 80 grand a year it isn't
worth it
like like like if i make 80 grand a year
as a salesman
i'm making seven thousand dollars a
month and i live in miami you're not
going to do it changes nothing the
opportunity has to change your life
significantly enough that you're willing
to read study
dive in right you add a zero to that
right there you had a zero to that
eighty now i'm willing to learn
every human being is like this by the
way every human being on this planet
maybe i'm wrong tell me if i'm wrong
comment please i add a zero to that
you're going to do stuff that you
wouldn't have done just a moment befo
ago okay if i can show you how to how to
go from 80 000 to 800 thousand all of a
sudden your creativity you like i think
i just met van gogh
god damn i got some madonna coming out
of my butt
okay
whoa whoa whoa i got music in my head
like like ding ding ding ding you like
you because why man because
yeah maybe the glass underneath my feet
don't hurt so bad
right because why because the goal is
big enough most people do not have goals
that will change their lives therefore
they cannot lean into the opportunity
hard enough for those of you who own
businesses you need to create rings in
your business
okay so that natalie can see hey man i
can go outside this these i can go
outside these rings and there's more
opportunity out here for financial
freedom or she stays right here and she
doesn't resent me she resents her
because i keep throwing them out here
i'm like hey there's a 20 000 product
you can sell right here there's a 5 000
product you can get benefit from here oh
by the way there's a million dollars out
here if you want to when did you you
said like so you weren't successful
early on what was the shift what was it
like that moment where all of a sudden
when i was 51 51 yeah yeah how old are
you
61 years old yeah i like that yeah yeah
tell me what was the shift what was it
2010 man tell me 2010 i was just like i
had i had a little bit of success you
know i had three companies that were
doing well right and what were those
companies was it was there was a sales
training a speaking business okay
that i had been doing for 20 years
and uh it had really become just about
me collecting a fee
we would market we we owned the the
production of the the event the only
difference was i wasn't getting a
speaking fee i was getting a piece of
the gate okay so i i didn't actually do
any speaking for speaking about sales
sales it was all sales and it was
industry specifically yeah it was
automotive because i was very very
dependent upon the automobile industry
so so i realized
number one i'll never be dependent upon
one industry again ever
number two uh the other business was a
consulting business that was similar and
you know auto
yeah that that i didn't run i was a
partnership and and i collected a
royalty with and that was great for
years it was great until it wasn't right
right and then the third business was i
would take all the money from the first
two
and pour it into real estate because i
knew that real estate would live longer
than i could right and it would work
better than i could so the problem with
all three of those though is i never did
it big
like i never did it big big
so i had guys that had worse ideas and
worse products
that were beating me in the marketplace
like that his stuff sucks dude and but
he beat me right because he's
advertising like a madman and poor money
addict exactly he he was like like and i
was making fun of him but the truth is
he was manning up in the game and i
wasn't uh there's a guy named well
there's a number of them i mean there's
a bunch of companies there with a bunch
of guys around me and advertising
marketing another sales training company
they were pouring money on the deal and
i wasn't i was saving money right you
must think in terms of 10x
you have to think about expansion
exponential moves so whether it's 10 000
you have
100 000 you have i'm just talking about
money for a second or whether it's a 10
million dollars okay maybe it's a
charity that you raised last year you
raised a hundred thousand for
make-a-wish okay and you're like what
are we going to do this year we got to
be we got to beat last year we got to
beat it yeah but why don't you not beat
it why don't you stomp it in the ground
and act like it was dumb
that's exactly what i've done with my
businesses for the last seven or eight
years the first 20 years i thought small
i acted small i tried to preserve my
position okay number one you have to
give up your position you must give up
your position
number two the second thing i've done
over the last seven or eight years is
exponentially just grown grown all my
brands my name my recognition the
businesses the top line i have been
willing to put money at risk to 10x my
business four things i want to give you
number one on building a brand all right
first of all number number one because
some of you have a problem right here
you don't even like you don't even want
this
first thing you got to do is commit to
getting known
you have to get rid of this idea that
your mommy and daddy gave you fly under
the radar don't get known some of you
just don't want to get known you you're
literally hiding
well
uh i'm going to open another instagram
account and i'm going to put it on
private
if you're going to have a private
instagram account don't have an
instagram account if i see your accounts
private i will not follow you
why would i follow you i know guys in
solar they go out and make 70 grand in a
month yeah
and one you go on vacation yeah that's
just a violation of what made you the 70
grand it's so stupid yeah it's insanity
yeah
oh i deserved it i worked so hard dude
you're lucky
and double down
all in all like you're you're lucky yeah
okay uh lebron makes a three-pointer he
doesn't go do a layup he make he goes
like he's like dude i got these three
pointers down like what do you do after
you make a three-pointer you throw
another one from the same spot yeah
because the basket gets bigger
you don't take off now dude you lean
into it right when i was 25 dude i was
so scared if i sold somebody something
i'm like oh my god
this is only going to last for another
minute or two go meet somebody go talk
to somebody i'd sell a second person i'm
like oh i'm on fire now like i can sell
anybody people would walk up i sold five
or six cars in one day i'm like
i thought i was a damn like i had been
like
stan lee had somehow
you know influenced me into some super
character and i was like i walked up to
a lady one night it was it must have
been 10 30 11 o'clock at night i had
sold six cars that day i was like i was
in this the zone yeah and i walked out
and i said how about no money down and
nothing a month
and she's like huh no money down no
money a month you never have to pay for
it she's like for how long
i'm like man i got it you got it okay
okay
next thing you know she's buying
something from me yeah i was like
because i was in the zone so what i
would tell people out there is like
look when you make money you need a plan
with money number one get it you don't
have to make it earn it yeah two
keep it
don't buy with it yeah okay don't buy
don't spend money on stuff
until you have cash flow that can buy
stuff
like the when you guys see me out
spending money there i bought in
december i bought two rolls royce i
bought a culinary 449 000 car yeah and i
bought my wife a reef it's 425 000. okay
at least one of them signed a lease on
one of them for 24 months and and and
wrote a check for cash for the other one
okay yeah so
people like how can you do that dude i
earned that much i earned more money
that month from free cash flow i'm not
working for it my real estate paid me
enough money to pay for both of those
cars right there right there no i didn't
pay for the cars my cash flow did so
earn it keep it don't buy watches don't
buy fancy
don't buy lambos don't rent lambos don't
go on fancy vacations don't buy your
little trinkets until your cash flow can
pay for it not your time so like i was
with the shake the the minister
tolerance there i was sitting next to
him he had me at a meeting i'm sitting
to his right in this big beautiful round
room
and there's all mostly men in the room
three women and this this meeting they
people come in and just meet him every
afternoon wow three o'clock in the
afternoon hello how you doing they pay
respects
um he's got me on his right he's got the
minister
the prime minister of uh thailand on his
left
mr10x and mr thailand
and he reaches over touches me on the
name he's like
would you like to fly to dubai we were
in abu dhabi he's like would you like to
fly to dubai with me on my helicopter
i said yes sir i would
now i don't know if that includes elaine
or not so i'm hitting these fixed ideas
i'm like i wonder if that means my wife
is invited so so the point of this story
is like no matter where you're at in
life if you're still learning and you're
still in putting yourself in
uncomfortable or new environments
you're going to be a little
i don't know what the cultures are
you know when i was with the policemen
and they were investigating me and dubai
i crossed my legs like this the guy
walked in and said please please
sit proper i'm like yeah okay man
what's the deal here i ran into like
that that there in in the middle east
dude to see the bottom of the soul is so
disrespectful really but this is also
disrespectful this is considered to be
aggressive my leg was shaking when you
started my food
this is like because i'm not showing i
knew about the soul thing don't show the
soul but this is considered aggressive
by the police gotcha and and so i'm like
yeah man but but you see all these
things are like i think i think people
think oh my god grant's got it made you
know he's successful now everywhere he
goes he's he can talk to 35 000 people
i'm still uncomfortable in situations i
still have fixed limited beliefs and and
and things that trap me right so
you know we're doing we're doing and do
you prefer to put yourself in those
situations
yeah i have to i have to agree
i have to agree to put myself in those
so that i feel like i'm i'm expanding
like like i'm living life like you can't
be a beast
or a savage
if you're not in the jungle
you know you can't i know guys that
think they're beast and they're on their
sofa bro you're in your sofa you're
watching you're watching beast on tv
you're not a beast so you got it to be a
be to be a true savage like a real
living
uh
in a respectful honorable way i say that
and i say that like like i respect
people that are savages and and um to
get things done
that they're like hey man give me the
ball again right uh the cleaner is uh
was it tim grover would say well the
cleaner the cleaner yeah you got to be
in the game to be a clinger you can't
you can't be on a couch you can't be
behind a book
you got to be in environments that are
not comfortable not
oh you're on stage for the 67th time
doing the same presentation that's not a
cleaner that's a guy on on auto you're
just doing the same thing you did over
and over again
no one thing no one thing will blow a
good relationship there's not one thing
i can tell my wife my wife says hey
you're getting fat
okay
what is that how's that gonna hurt me
y'all gotta get hard man y'all gotta
practice being hard y'all gotta practice
telling people the truth y'all gotta
practice being hard on yourselves you
gotta practice maybe not
taking every weekend off
okay i had a bunch of people leave my
office the other night at six o'clock
dave robarts is walking out of here all
these guys walking out at 603 natasha's
leaving at 6 00 30. i'm like oh you guys
are all rich now huh why do you think
you got to leave why do you guys think
you've earned the right to leave at six
o'clock
right why do you guys think you've
earned the right to charge overtime for
everything that you do over time
well i need to get my overtime no you
don't you need to add value is what you
need to do you need to get hard on
yourself if you took everything away
from me right now
the things that are most valuable to me
you can't take away
so you take the plane away you take the
money away
take the real estate poor the portfolio
away
three years from now i'll be bigger than
i was
because now i have courage
if you guys can just find your courage
man
and that that's a muscle you got to go
build the muscle of courage i have
courage nobody can take that away from
you can't steal it from me can't beat it
out of me before you diversify go go
bang on another door yeah you need to
become the
doorbanging
of the universe so i want to talk about
that right because can i use that word
here 100 100 you need to become like you
need to go bang
yeah you need to go bang on the door
they tell you to get out of the
neighborhood and you go figure out how
to bang on it again and not get arrested
yeah
like if you can figure that gig out i
guarantee you you will be the most
successful person your genetic code has
ever generated yeah anyone in your
family everybody i know says man
learn how to cold call i i have the
career i have today because i'm because
i learned how to cold i respect a
hundred dollars
so if you give me a hundred dollars
you know i respect that as a lot of
money gotcha now that being said it's
not going to be a lot for very long and
if you got two kids that need to eat
today it depends on what your needs are
right i got a wife and two kids so
i mean a hundred dollars probably gonna
last the whole day uh but a hundred
dollars for a minute
that's a lot of money now if i could if
i could figure out how to get more money
coming in
it's only a lot of money if you got more
money coming in i understand because i
can i can probably exhaust almost any
amount of money
this is this is the problem with the the
nfl the nba
the mlb the the the rappers when they
move on they got a pile of money but
what they don't have is more money
coming in gotcha and and so
now you know a million dollars is a lot
of money if you got
a thousand dollars every day coming in
because you can't get through it i
always tell elena i said dude as long as
we make a dollar more
because of my net worth if i make a
dollar just one dollar every day
i mean one dollar today is a lot of
money because
it means i never go backwards i have
belief now i know i know what i can do
now once you know what you can do then
you can do it a second time and that's
why so many people can go bankrupt and
then come come right back because they
know now
the first time you do it you don't know
the second time you do it you're like i
think maybe the third and fourth time
you're like i know for sure i can do
this there was a time when nobody knew
my name
all right nobody knew my name
i didn't i hadn't written a book i
didn't have 21 best-selling programs
uh i wasn't doing audiences my first gig
my first gig i talked to seven people
for eight hours
how long
like how long did that go on for three
years oh how long did people not know me
yeah oh
nobody knew me really until the last
three years so i want you guys to hear
that how many i've been doing this how
many years of doing that 20 i've been
doing this i've been doing the pitch
thing since 30.
i'm i'm 61. so 31. 31 years nobody's
known me until the last two or three
years maybe
and would you and then mike tyson you're
like man where you been then
why doesn't everybody know you man yeah
why doesn't everybody know you steve
harvey dude everybody should know who
you are you should have a tv show
that was my fault man i was thinking too
small
i was running down a little channel yeah
but too many of you guys you're trying
to run down too many channels in the
beginning
or or trying to cross all you got to get
good at one thing first yeah
you can't
you're not going to be great at two
things if you're not great at one thing
it's impossible yeah you can't serve two
ways at the same time man get good at
one wave get get good at the left
okay and and so you've got to get good
at one thing it doesn't matter if you
like it either you don't need to like it
to get great at it yeah like everybody's
like i gotta follow my passion
particularly here in l.a yeah i'm an
artist
okay oh
i'm meant to do this dude
you're meant to do a lot of stuff yeah
okay ask steven spielberg he was not
meant to do one thing he's meant to do a
lot of things we all are
and so it's not it's not some freak
phenomenon that a guy can write
uh fiction and non-fiction and do movies
okay and
um you know also be a massive investor
in companies yeah it's not true
it's
it's somebody got oh how can a guy write
you know this and that and do all this
and put together these volumes and help
people and start to you know because
because he can and you can too yeah
everybody can but you got to get good at
one thing you got to groove into one
thing make sure you're certain about one
thing before you move on to the second
thing
because you're just going to be like i'm
still in doubt about the first thing but
i'm trying to get great at this thing
and you know you didn't finish this
thing i need to think like the google
boys or the warren buffets or the guys
that are like dude they don't worry
about all that
they're worried about how big they can
get how big how big can they get how how
long can they survive and and big big is
what works
you can't show me a small company or a
small think that has ever survived
anything is this the your your quote
that says can't can't get big thinking
small you can't get big thinking small
and you can't get big
with small people for me calling on car
dealers you know back in the beginning
as much as i loved calling on car
dealers and as much as they helped me
they didn't appreciate me
um they didn't appreciate their people
they didn't want to invest money in
their people i i was i was the fact that
i made any money doing what i did with
car dealers is actually phenomenal right
because
i should have been in advertising i
actually picked the wrong vehicle
i should have been doing what they
wanted to do
they want to train their people but
really they want to spend money on
advertising yeah no doubt which they
don't want to do that either but but
they know they have to to keep traffic
coming to the front door i picked the
wrong vehicle from the get-go that was
one of the biggest mistakes i made in my
career
in my business career when i wrote the
10x rule i was trying to solve a problem
the problem that i've had in my life
okay was not my marriage
it's not okay i'm not a bad parent
i wasn't helping enough people
see i've always loved helping people
always
i am most happy when i'm helping someone
else
nothing to do with money
if i can help somebody
not give them something but if i can
actually help somebody to feel better
about themselves
to know what to do in a phone call to
know what to do on a sales call to know
how to follow up their girlfriend or
their boyfriend or to solve some problem
in their life or how to get some money
if i can help somebody know how to do
that
i know i contributed to their life
you should be up here you should be
dropping out of the ceiling you should
be helping more people
10x gave me my life back
if you're not 10xing i promise you will
experience depression you will feel
empty okay i wanted my life back
are you committed
no no no are you committed
will you let me help you
welcome to your 10x growth conference
you need to filter down to who you
listen to i don't listen to a lot of
people yeah i mean i hear him
you know but
you know he don't know what he's talking
about totally dude dude if you're not
saying that most of them has no clue
that's not clue i'm not criticizing him
by the way
i'm not criticizing mike tyson yesterday
telling me something he said i said
that's mike yeah
okay i mean who tells the champ
i said dude you don't know what you're
talking about right now he's like
enlighten me man
tell me man i said all this surrender
dude it's all
the guy that told you you need to
surrender the therapist that told you
that
was the confused one yeah
okay so i i just i've learned who not to
listen to they'll get that somebody will
get that i'm not going to get it
april you're going to get that right
see that's the other thing like right
now like like you got to juggle dude
you got to juggle you can't if i get up
now and go answer that phone it's only
because i don't have somebody here to
help me when i roll i gotta have a team
normally i got two other people with me
i got two kids in the other room their
friend who happens to be here so we
joined up
and their mother's a producer in
hollywood and they happen to be here at
the same time in fact the guy that
andrew banks that's on shark tank in
australia he was here we had dinner
yesterday just happened to run into each
other but you got to have a team nobody
was telling me when i started a business
bro you need a team
you're going to need a team man you want
to be super super successful spider-man
pro spider-man doesn't have a team does
he i think he does his own costume but
like how can you be spider-man and do
your own costume
right i mean to be superman i mean
batman's got a team right superman he's
got a team doesn't he have a team
i don't think he does maybe he's got a
mama
but that's for the comic books man you
need a team
well
that's an interesting thing right
because i i
i've like studied you and i've seen like
you know you've got alan you've got
um yeah i got allen on my team yeah
you've got um
a-l-a-n on instagram you've got the
young guy the president
yeah yeah
he was a pilot now he's now he's uh
running a 1.2 billion dollar real estate
portfolio i got sherry hamilton i got
personal assistance i got 150 we got 150
employees in miami another 250 in the
real estate
that could be 500 easily in the real
estate you know there's probably 500
employees between the two businesses
right now and i'm sitting here thinking
why don't i have 50 000 employees okay i
look out i look out here and these
windows central equity okay i guarantee
you they that's not a one-man show right
there you don't get your name on a
building being one person i wrote this
thing on instagram the other day i spent
most of my life trying to please the
whole damn world hating myself
trying to please the bank trying to
please my mom trying to please everybody
to schools
the drug dealer i'm trying to please
people
that are dead man i know they're going
to die i can sell they're killing
themselves every day and i'm trying to
please people that can't even help me
once you make the decision bro this is
one of the hardest things to do
to shift because when you start spinning
another plate here's the trick you
cannot leave this plate
this plate demands that you continue to
spin it right now how much time you
spend spending that primary plate
because all i'm trying to do now is
serve the customers serve any existing
contracts
you don't want to abandon this this
audience that that actually helped you
but you can't give them all the
attention when i first started making
the swing away from car dealers like
they did not like it yeah i bet
you know the audience that made you
or somewhat made you
uh will not want you to go get made
somewhere else sure
makes sense
you know you can you can hear rappers
and entertainers doing uh comedians hey
do the old jokes richard
you know i want the old kanye everybody
wants your old gran you know
right
except the new people so between six and
nine i'm gonna set up my first three
things to do that morning i'm probably
gonna work out in my case because i'm a
father i'm gonna spend time with my kids
then i'm going to come back i'm going to
take a shower i'm going to get ready
have some breakfast and be ready for a 9
a.m meeting nine to noon between nine
and noon maybe i have phone calls maybe
i'm working on a project maybe i'm
shooting a video i'll basically have
those notes again every line every line
on this page should be filled up noon
i'm going to take a quick lunch maybe 10
or 15 minutes have a bite to eat or i'm
going to spend a longer lunch but it'll
always be with a client three to six
six to nine i'm cranking down i'm
turning it off i'm going to sleep if you
over commit and under deliver if you
can't get to everything that's better
than having blank space on this calendar
now the right side is why i built the
10x planner as a journal schedule
planner daytime or day runner call it
what you want your goals these four or
five lines right here are going to be
the most important way to start your day
because this is your purpose this is why
you're living your life this is the
reason you're getting up and going into
work each day underneath this you're
going to see quote of the day
what is your quote today
this is a very creative two lines that's
going to cause you to think about what
you stand for that day these are your
targets things you want to accomplish
this day calls you want to make
appointments you want to have deals you
want to close people you need to see
somebody you got to get in front of this
is your exact target something
measurable then what do we have
successes so so important don't wait
till the end of the week or the end of
the month to write down your successes
what'd you do today you went to the
dentist and had your teeth cleaned boom
that's a success for me that's a major
success because i hate dennis and by the
way make sure when you put your
successes down here tweet me every once
in a while and i'll make sure i either
retweet you or i'll follow you or i'll
get you more followers last thing write
your goals down again you wrote them
down this morning you wrote them down at
night i can't tell you how valuable this
is okay you write your goals down once a
year i'm gonna write mine down
700 times a year who wins this game a
guy smarter than me taller than me
better looking than me better connected
than me writes his goals down once or
twice a year and i write mine down
700 times a year who wins it won't be
taller it won't be richer it won't be
better looking it'll be the guy that
writes his goals down twice a day every
day you've got this incredible team how
like what do you look for like like how
do you find these incredible people how
do you keep them motivated
yeah well i don't i don't find them and
and they find me
and and so what we do is we just we we
get the beacon the you know how does
facebook attract talent
you know they don't need to go find them
it's like
it's like meat to a shark you know it's
like i'm coming i'm i smell the blood in
the water so they're going to facebook
right how do you how do you attract
great talent this is what people ask me
every day how do you attract great
people dude get soap and beam in hot
white light that people are like i want
to work on that project
i went and saw hobson shaw last night it
did 333 million it's got rock and stay
the minute 333 million opening weekend
worldwide a third of a billion dollars
dude like ridiculous great movie by the
way had a blast watching it but
you know how does that much money go to
one place
how did that many great people work on
that movie
you know because who's involved in it
right so uh you know greatness attracts
greatness
and and so these people call hey i want
to work for you i had a kid today come
on i want to work for you it's a good i
don't hire about i don't hire people
like
i'm not the hire guy
i'm the guy that's creating new
opportunities though that people want to
stay
you know they want to stay in the theme
park
and become their own show
so if you notice i show off my people a
lot
i don't like keep them behind the scenes
i'm like here
you know let's have more than the grant
show
let's have the grant the frank kern show
the brandon dawson show the jared show
the ryan secco show the real estate show
let's do a lot of the show the g e show
elena and myself let's bring other
people and partners in
why do i do that where am i learning
great companies great companies grow
their brands and scale out and do a lot
of different things how do you
personally know like when is it time to
pivot a little bit when is it time to
shift i've seen you put layer on layer
on layer on layer but how do you know
when to make that
move when do we go to the next layer
well for me it's you know
it's it's it's
like you see you see the end of
something coming
you know everything's got a cycle every
every sooner look you know uh federer
express i'm watching federer express
this morning
it's getting slaughtered yeah
like the company probably will not exist
in the future this is one of the
greatest companies
ever put on planet earth it's going to
be disrupted by amazon
right so it might come back i'm sure i'm
sure some maybe warren will come in and
figure out how to save it but
um
my point of that is that like
things expire
bodies expire
products expire
ideas expire
and they run a cycle where
one either the passion's not there or
the profits not there
and for me
you know i like to do things that are
profitable
right
and uh
the more profit it makes the more
passion that i get for some reason
right i can understand that so because
because that's the only way i know how
to win i can't make a basket
i can't write a movie
maybe i can maybe i could write a movie
i could just
i can't
you put together some pretty good videos
i think you could probably put together
a good movie yeah so uh
so look if i do a 10x growth conference
and and 12 000 people coming we lose
money on it that's nothing to be proud
about sure i know guys that can do that
we run the only
just to brag a little bit we run the
only profitable event in the world
wow
everybody loses money on those deals so
those events they do i did a deal with
tony robbins
sly stallone gary vaynerchuk
who else was at that gig uh i think
pitbull was there too
two days they lost money on that gig
how you lose money on that wow
how do you line up
like i'm like you got to be kidding
because they couldn't sell their tickets
they couldn't get the appropriate price
for their ticket
so when do you decide to transcend when
do you decide to move on to something
look when it's no longer passionate it's
no longer profitable
and you can't figure out a solution
right you like you've tried and you're
looking at and you know they're maybe
the industry's starting to go away make
money your battle cry
go collect money don't make money just
go collect money have a great product
have a great service over deliver
collect money charge for it
this is where me and gary would you know
me and gary had a cage match i just beat
the [ __ ] out of him but
gary anytime anywhere
okay but but look most people out there
watching this and you need to monetize
yeah you know this is insanity that that
you're being told don't monetize your
your business if you have a good
business have a good service have a good
product sell it
you know but so many guys are they're
they're trying these little kid kid
gimmicks
you know it's fine if my kids flip shoes
on on on ebay
if you're an adult man you got to get
beyond flipping
sneakers on ebay
you need to build a business
otherwise don't call yourself an
entrepreneur because that's not what an
entrepreneur an entrepreneur is not
flipping on ebay
that's not a business
that's you trying to make two dollars
on a toy that you bought at a garage
sale it's a different gig
now if you can figure out how to scale
that
but it sounds to me like you're you're
benefiting ebay more than you're
benefiting yourself
ebay is the pimp
and you're basically the prostitute in
that machinery which is no problem with
that right
but you're servicing the machine rather
than building your own machine
i want to build a machine
i want to build a machine that lives
longer than i do so that if i get a good
partnership with somebody and we cut a
deal and they're 90 of the profits in
future and i'm 10 and my kids and my
charity get to keep that 10 after i'm
dead man i'm good to go anytime you
depend on one flow you will resent the
flow
no matter how good the flow is
the flow could pay you 10 million
dollars a month you will resent the flow
because you'll you're going to feel
dependent
on that and nobody wants to feel
dependent
and so it's really important that people
learn how to how do i actually have surf
two waves
yeah that makes a lot of that makes a
lot of sense and i like how you said
with the you know when you start to lose
the passion or the profit because i
think a lot of people
uh you know especially in the in the
auto industry the the profits will still
be coming in
but they hate to they hate their job
right they hate the 70 hours they've
they've lost the passion but they're
still collecting a check so i love that
you hit on on both of those things
gardeners that hate that that hate what
they're doing yeah i know plenty of them
myself
no it's not like
i know car dealers that are not in the
game anymore
that's why they're not in the dealership
yeah they've lost their fire yeah
yeah man and then i i had a car dealer
call me two weeks ago and said dude
where where where where how much gas you
got in your tank
and i said what do you mean he's like
i just don't i can't find my passion
right
so you've been doing the same thing so
long bro like it's not not
you know you got it you know kobe
retired
right
comes a time where you're like hey next
game yeah time time to move you got to
elevate the game you got to elevate the
questions you got to elevate the
industry you got to go
transition into something else if you
can do automotive you can do anything i
really believe i come in today
i walk you know we fly into london we
get here 11 15. i don't know what i'm
going to do next there's 5 000 people
out there
somebody sends me a text okay this is
what your day looks like okay now now i
start i start running and hustling from
one thing to the next thing
in between what i'm going to do is i'm
going to jam i'm going to jam stuff in
between events so that i leave this
i'm going to be here eight or nine hours
i'm going to leave this and it's going
to feel like i was here eight days
and so i'm going to jam as much in so i
don't get in trouble because the more
active i am i'm creating time basically
i'm not trying to manage time
i'm not trying to manage my day i'm
trying to create my day yeah so i i look
at everything as like i'm creating
something i'm creating always in
creation
because that keeps me from being effect
so i'm either going to be pushing this
thing or it's going to be pushing on me
and um
you know i'm not look i don't fly the
plane i can only push as much as my
skills allow me to yeah so i can tell
the guys from the back hey guys get over
give us a good straight landing right
down the middle okay get us a little
faster give us a little higher but i'm
just
from the back because i can't fly a
plane
you know
i'm in the back i'm in the back of the
plane you guys are doing great up there
right okay so so keep it straight when
you land right don't wreck this thing
don't damage it right i'm just from the
back yeah you guys you guys autopilot
that's all y'all do up there right
so so uh you know i make this joke about
pilots i'm like anybody can fly a plane
not anybody not not just anyone can buy
a plane yeah right but it's a it's a
kind of tongue-in-cheek thing because
i can't fly playing so it doesn't matter
how much i want to i can't so i can't
micromanage that but what i can do when
i'm on the plane
like last night we got on at 10 o'clock
got to the airport at 9 45 walked on the
plane beds are made
two kids a nanny elena all have our
little separate beds bam we knock out we
wake up at 11 15 this morning here so
i'm refreshed ready to go and then
somebody sends me a little thing that
says this is what you're doing today
first you got rob moore i said oh
yeah
that dude okay so then we'll bang bang
bang bang and then we're gonna leave out
uh here about nine o'clock tonight go to
dubai and do that all over again
so that's how every day works okay
except for today when i woke up here
some somewhere this morning somebody
when they wake up is gonna send me the
first thing that happens to me every
morning is i get a cash account yeah
every single day yeah
so i say okay okay nobody's stealing
from me
okay those numbers are getting bigger
okay that one went down okay i know this
money's going here i need money man i
got i'm playing chess those are my
pieces and if i didn't have money it
would be okay what's my time it's either
money or time which one am i which one
am i running how do i start competing
with these banks so they're like you
know what we really don't like all this
noise you're making you're a noisy guy
and we're kind of getting tired of it
now
when you get noisy enough they're either
gonna
uh
when when you get noisy enough they
either buy you
and suppress you
you know that's what bill gateswood did
with with apple years ago the tablet the
original iphone was a little uh called
uh
what was the name of that little beast
um
anyway it had a little pin you wrote on
they buried that project for years um
i'll think of it in a second i think of
it when the interview's over maybe you
guys know what it is okay anyways
probably 20 years ago i actually had a
company built around this thing and bill
gates came in gave apple steve jobs
alone and said look i'll lend you this
money
you got to bury that product
and they did
so that's what you can do or they
consume you they buy you and say hey we
want you to be part of our ryan was
telling me a story the other day about
you know when he was a kid
his uncle
grabbed him and said hey if you come
live with me and work with me every
weekend you can have a car by the time
you're 16.
and i'm like i wonder why why is that
the dream
the car a car i remember because i have
the same thing i'm like i want a car
when i'm 15 years old
why wasn't i thinking about a car
dealership
or building a car
like why do we think so small why why is
everybody got these similar very similar
i bet you wanted a car yeah i bet you
weren't thinking about a car dealership
or building but elon's thinking about
building a car about rocket ships rocket
ships going to mars i'm like why does he
think so big and i always felt so small
so i i don't i don't know what goes on
in elon's mind
but
i would love to not have insecurities in
little think
i i don't know what the little thing is
there's a little little thing
little thing little think little man
think look i don't think
um
i i don't think that people burn out
i think it's impossible i'm not i'm not
a piece of wax i'm not a candle
so the burnout thing was put on us
by people that quit already yeah you're
gonna burn out dude you're gonna burn
out burnout is never about work nobody
burns out because they work too hard oh
you're burning the candle at both ends
i'm a spiritual being i create energy
this is an irresponsibility
like i've never met a human being that
was made of wax
you know oh yeah but you know burning in
both ends you're you're a being you're a
being okay like quit saying something's
happening to you this goes back to cause
and effect i create energy
and i love your example of the kids okay
that kid can play that game it's always
a game though yeah oh die oh not it's
always a game
there's nothing that entertains people
more than a game
and so when i was
uh 18 years old man i was playing a game
called asteroids i would play i would
play
80 of it a day because it cost a quarter
every game right and i'm just piling
throwing them in doing anything i can to
get quarters so i can dump them into
this into this game
and i was trying to get to the next
level look at how people play candy
crush 700 levels and they're still
looking for the next level over and over
it's games
and that energy doesn't run out until
you hit boredom
because you can see a kid play a game
too long
and then they start getting like kind of
smashed in and their attitude gets bad
because they've been playing that same
game too long yeah
so i know that as long as i'm interested
not for me not passionate
for me
well for me for me i need to be able to
win at a game
if there's a chance i can win
i'll be excited about the game
if there's no chance to win i have no
interest
so for me for me the idea that i'm going
to follow my passions is a little bit
deluded for me i i think people are
looking for their passion i would not
follow my passion i would i would follow
the wins right so are you saying there's
things that you can really enjoy but you
don't think you could win is that what
you mean i i think if
yeah i think that if you're
if there's no victory
the passion is is a little bit
um
narcissistic
like oh i'm gonna i'm meant to be a
artist
maybe ain't nobody buying your art
nobody's buying it all you do is
stacking art
okay who is so selfish
i do this for me it makes me feel good
seven billion people on this planet man
like if you keep all this to yourself
sooner or later you're still gonna look
like a junkyard around you
and at some point you're gonna see this
person cave in in depression
and and it's like like where's the
where's where where do you get the art
out
like you know like i love watches right
mostly huh so do i yeah most of my
watches end up on somebody else's arm
yeah like i like i have it for a while i
love it for a while and then i'm like
here you have it yeah and so for me like
it needs to get out and
um i have a victory in that yeah i see
it on somebody else's arm it makes me
happy yeah
and and so if if i write a book
and the book doesn't get sold i'm not
going to be excited about that book i
need the book and hands of other people
one people should be invested in the
beginning and just in themselves every
chance you get to to go to something
that help could possibly help you has a
if it has a one percent chance of even
adding to the value you have in your
spend the money
don't sit on money money's useless
so
if you have five thousand dollars left
in your account i would spend
the whole 5 000 on yourself
when you spend money on yourself you're
going to start getting better at
whatever you're doing
if you just keep doing it if you keep
spinning it just because you spent it
once and it didn't work go do it again
and then again and then again
that that that has been one thing in my
life like if you ask me hey what's one
thing i always invested me first
not the business not the business not
the real estate me
my condition how am i doing am i around
the right people am i listening like i
don't care what it is dinner lunch
charities i just go to anything anything
where i think there's other people doing
well
like i just want to hear somebody say
something that just inspires me
so how much you reckon you invest in
yourself every year right now
last year i probably spent
you know
a couple hundred grand
i've spent more than that
and i would i'd still spend more than
that
so like it starts with me right how good
a condition i i know people out there
spend more money on their car than they
do themselves
they pay three four five hundred dollars
a month on their car think nothing of it
won't spend 500 on themselves it's
ridiculous it's completely backwards
you're paying the man you're paying for
food you're paying for groceries you're
paying for movies you're paying for
you're paying you went and bought a
house that was the dumbest thing anybody
could do it's the dumbest thing i ever
did was buy a house i bought a house and
i didn't improve myself i was improving
the how i spent more time picking
furniture out than i did hey how do i
fix me
how do i get faster
more confident
because i bring my confidence or lack of
confidence to every table when you talk
about women that's not what i think
about all right tell me
i don't think about the jet
uh i mean i think about my kids my wife
all the time i love my kids like
like oh my god man right the fact that
this guy lost his kid like like it's
just i know i know so anyway um
when i think about winning dude i don't
think about though i don't think about
stuff
i think about crushing people
okay i got a huge chip on my shoulder
nobody's ever asked me about it but it's
massive
my ship
okay
so tell me about it man why is that chip
so big
i don't know why don't that it doesn't
matter it served me so well that i'm
you know you're just good with it
yeah i'm like let's roll you know
well because there's there's
stallone told me this too uh interviewed
stallone in california up in
san mateo
he's like got grant you got to have got
got to have an adversary
he's like you look like one of those
guys it's like
he's like you're aggressive
i said bro you're rambo
right
[Laughter]
he's not he's like not really really i'm
rocky
so so he's like my dark side's rambo got
it i said my lighter side is rambo
right on so he's like hey you got to
have an adversary
he's like arnold arno he's like if it
wasn't for arnold grant i probably would
not be where i'm at
arnold was not a friend arnold was a
total adversary got it we repeated for
roles
people compared us
you know so i've had a lot of that in my
career i would rather fast than perfect
yeah i would rather i'd rather
i'll post something that's got
grammatical uh issues the first book i
ever wrote had hundreds of misspelled
words not a few hundreds of them
and a guy i remember a guy first person
told me about him i didn't see him
i wrote it it wasn't a ghost writer i
wrote the book bang bang bang bang so
um
the guy calls me says man you got
hundreds of misspelled words i i have a
spreadsheet he's trying to be of service
to me he's like he sends me a
spreadsheet grammar choline semicolon i
use semicolons where there should be
colons uh commas where there should be
periods and he's like run on sentences
and he sends me this whole spreadsheet
like 40 pages
of corrections
i said man thanks for doing that
yeah i mean he's like uh i just want to
be sure you get it right i said bro it's
a best-selling book it's a best-selling
book
and he's like huh i said it's a
bestseller son
it's not a best written
yeah it ain't a perfect grammar book
like i've never been perfect
i'm sloppy
i'm i'm you know i'm i push hard i push
fast but i'd rather i'd rather you know
i remember bill gates bill gates says
look if if microsoft can't be the best
let's make it look like it's the best
you know when china was ripping bill off
he's like if they're going to rip
somebody off let's make sure they rip
off microsoft
like the attitude is like get to the
market
you know get to the market be in the
market put in put it in people's hands
we can fix it later if you look at if
you look at the the the this little
device right here they came out with an
11. the 11 had so many bugs in it
every day people were getting
you've been updated
updated his code for phone was
and we had to push it out because we
want to hit our quarter we want to keep
people excited with new products
so we're willing to hit people with a
new product that's got bugs in it
now the perfectionist says no no we need
to wait okay we got to get it perfect we
got to get it fixed which means you're
going to get slaughtered in the
marketplace by a beast that runs faster
and dominates the market
and overwhelms the customer with new
products uh while you're sitting back in
your laboratory saying hey we're gonna
make it perfect
that goes for the artist to the
businessman to the musician to everyone
to the to the this is why men have an
advantage in social media over women
because women
got to do the filter
got to fix their hair
got to do their makeup
oh bodybuilding world championship he's
got to go pump first yeah
is back there lopez he's back there ty's
a friend of mine he's back there pumping
up right now he's trying to get his back
swollen
you know so so
like like you watch you watch my social
media like like most of it's not planned
not 90 of it's not planned i have bad
hair days
i say the wrong things i want to push
the i want to push product out i want to
get i'd rather frequency
frequency and speed over quality
and i'll figure the quality out as i go
what's your definition of success then
i don't know i mean like like you know
just it's not a thing or a it's not some
kind of
it's not some kind of race or
result time or number
you know it's like hey am i can am i i
think for me it's more
am i fulfilling my potential
you know you ever feel your potential
i don't know i mean
probably not i just keep finding a new
thing right yeah
you know i go to the gym i mean a year
ago i couldn't pick up i couldn't do a
push-up
now i can do 100. wow so will i be able
to do 110 one day you know will i even
want to at some point you're like i
don't want to do any more right
so until then i just keep like you know
playing the game man it's a fun game and
i get to you know the beautiful thing
about preston is that you don't know if
you're going to win or
[Music]
and
it's easy to quit playing
yeah and that because you can you you
don't lose
but if you keep playing the game if i
keep
trying things i can't keep experiencing
the insecurity and the fear
that that personal thing that it's got
nothing to do with the checkbook or
what you bought or how you live but that
experience of like can i figure this out
i was insecure
before the event
thinking the night before
you know there's no way all these people
aren't gonna show up this place is gonna
be half empty oh
biggest fear i have that's gonna be if
you're walking on a stage and seeing
crickets
nobody's in the room or or
you start and everybody starts leaving
oh you walk it out people start walking
out like this is
two biggest fears i have
so that that was scary all the way up to
the night of the event like i was
terrified
you know and you know fearful like
they're not going to show up then
even even once we did that
we have a room a third the size of last
year
i have worried every day
since
the last event whether this one will
work really yeah why
i don't know man
i know how hard they are yeah it's hard
to get people to show up and i just
even when we're sold out
well i'll keep pushing
it keeps selling yeah because i don't
trust the numbers i don't trust that
people will show up
that's the 10x rule though the 10x rule
says look you don't stop when you get
there
you keep pushing
and that way the place will be full i
look at some of my contemporaries you
know some some of the top
speakers in the world
and and predecessors you know those some
of the guys that went before me
they didn't have companies
and they didn't have anybody
else uh with a light with a with a star
and one of the things i wanted to do was
i didn't want to be the only star in my
universe
um
if you notice that maybe you don't but
but my wife does she's like i've never
seen anybody share the limelight as much
as you do yeah
she comes from hollywood so she knows
it's very hard to get the light off
the main star sure
dude i like i want it on other people
i was doing a gig in uh
in oakland
and
the guy running the gig
who's been around the top like like
a-listers in the world
he told one of my people he told ryan
secco somebody asked ryan to sign an
autograph and bill went up to ryan says
don't do that when grant's here
because because grant needs to be the
star
and i told bill i said bro i want
everybody to be the star right i want
everybody around me to be a star
okay the more stars i got around me the
brighter my universe gets absolutely and
so that's strong
and and and i'm not i'm not worried
about anybody outshining me well let's
all shine right
so
um
you know i got jared sherry
steve dave roboards mike bonnett
ryan secko
like i want more nobody's got more
haters than that but it stops a lot of
people and it doesn't stop you
yeah because because because i i you
know it's a different
for me
like
i understand
that
if you get if you're going to get
success
you're going to get the haters that's
the price
or one of the costs that's one of the
prices okay so because it goes back to
what i said earlier all haters
first of all we should not admire haters
the way we do we even call them haters
they're not haters
they're quitters
they're quitters all haters are quitters
like this should be this should be the
title of your your thing is a quiz all
haters all haters yeah including me
anytime i hate on something
okay i am a i quit on that thing like i
hate drugs i quit drugs i hate drugs i
hate people that use drugs i don't trust
people that use drugs like no drug is
safe for me
and and i know i believe that no drug is
safe for other people now some people
will be like no no i'm using cannabis uh
recreational it's cool man and i use
psychedelics and i do this good dude i
hate drugs i want to make it clear i
hate drugs and i i hate drugs for you
and i hate drugs for him i hate drugs
for everybody so i can be wrong but
right now i'm gonna hate drugs why
because i quit drugs
now if you're hating on grant cardone
and i hadn't done anything to you i'm
over here minding my own business or
building my own business
you know minding micromanaging my own
business so it grows so so if i'm doing
that okay and you're hating on me why
are you hating on me
now he uses social media too much these
are every example i go over it's because
you don't use it enough he works too
much because you don't use you don't
work enough
he doesn't spend enough time with his
kids you don't even have kids like i got
people hating on me because i got my
kids on my plane oh you're gonna ruin
your kids if i'm gonna ruin my kids i'm
gonna ruin them private
you know so so um what are you quitting
on like so i it's very very important
for me like when i hate on somebody i
need to understand
did i quit on something or am i
legitimately hating on this person
for a reason because i'm trying to make
a i'm trying to make a statement
publicly and there are
there are people i publicly hate on and
why do you do that
uh because i want to make it clear that
they should not be doing business with
this person they should not be admiring
this person they should not
like as an opinion leader i think i have
some responsibility to tell people do
you you don't want to follow that if
you're going to follow him don't follow
me yeah
you can't follow both of us
and think that you're going to get any
place which is a huge problem today with
social media what do you think it'll
take for you to get over insecurity
moving forward
i'm not trying to you're not trying i'm
not trying to
i thought you said if you could get rid
of it you'd be able to do bigger the
unbelievable but but it's not it's not
it's not a target i have
letting go of insecurity no i think it's
just a human condition i think it's part
of the game i think it's part of being a
human being any more than i want to get
rid of my arms you know or my legs or
my arms and my legs my body my body is a
limitation
yeah you know so um how do you manage it
better then like for people that are
saying i you know i want to 10x but i
always have insecurity and fear that i'm
going to fail and people are going to
show up and yeah the deal is going to
i'm going to go broke
how do you personally
get a conversation to yourself to the
insecurity and fear yeah it's not stop
it's come
you know for me for me fear fear the
things i i'm scared of i'm like
come on you know
it's calling me says hey come play over
here
it's an indicator it's a good indicator
not a bad indicator lean into it lean
into it come play with me okay so i
either have fear because it's really
dangerous
and stupid
or like physically dangerous yeah like
let me get to the edge of this thing i'm
gonna get on the other side of that
thing i'm probably gonna be scared yeah
now
why am i gonna be scared though
like
because i don't know what it feels like
to fall
you know this many floors and hit yeah
maybe it does maybe there's no big deal
about maybe dying is not even a big deal
right but i don't have the exp i don't
consciously have the experience
so
you know i used to be like
i can't buy a 78 000 house i was
terrified the first house i bought
i don't know what i'm doing because you
have experience i don't have the
experience man
this this is the problem and you're not
going to have the experience if you
don't move through the fear
and
a lot of people do it once and then they
don't do it again you got like
it's not going away yeah it's just gonna
you're gonna get used to
you're gonna get used to the ski boots
you know the first time you put them on
man they're banging your shins
like i can't mend
but you just
we're into them let's just put this in
the business we've got great cash flow
reserves yeah yeah that's awesome and do
we take it out before have you how much
of this risk for risk for what risk
never been in business
six years six years dude in six years
you know just look back over the last
six years because this
i did the same thing i had all this
money sitting there for the thing that
was gonna happen
okay if you believe in the law of
attraction
you're planning for the thing and it
will happen like you're planning for it
it's going to happen right man we're
pushing hard on growth too yeah yeah
right but at some point you know you can
only spend so much you're like okay i
can't spend any more here we could spend
more you could yeah then there's your
answer spend it dude don't sit on it you
had no reason to have a reserve why
don't we spend those reserves because a
little bit of doubt
a little bit of doubt it's going to pay
off so you start you start you start
believing in the money more than that
right start believing in the money more
than the possibility a high risk man huh
i hate risks i hate risk too that's why
that's why i buy the kind of real estate
i buy
like every day the first sheet of paper
i get every day is how much cash i have
the reason i'm looking at that is not
bragging
rights it's because i want to get rid of
it
it's like trash i want to get rid of
this money
i want to get that money to buy
something that has babies
right so i'm every day i'm looking i got
to get rid of this cash i had this much
cash i want to push it money's being
devalued worldwide right now the way i
lead is i go do stuff
first time
and when i talk about doing stuff i'm
talking about i move the bar the only
thing i look at every day
is did i move the graph up
i'm just i like
i love that the the symbol of hercules i
think it was hercules holding the world
yeah
and and i imagine if he if it was a live
character he'd be pushing it up more all
the time that that's what i when i see a
graph i look at we graph everything i
look grass and i'm like i want to go be
hercules
i want to lift it and that's all my
people see me doing every day i don't
i'm not an organizer i'm not a planner
i'm not the meeting guy
um i'm the i'm i'm i'm hurt i move the
i'm hercules constantly moving that bar
moving the bar moving the bar i'm i'm
the one making the points right and so
i'm like look i don't steve i'm gonna
make 40 points today put 20 on the board
dawg i don't need you to do because you
can't steve you can't make
okay
right
so
me and ryan i'm like right right i'm
gonna raise i'm gonna raise two million
dollars today i bet you can't even do
half of what i do
and what happens is
you know they see my energy is toward
activities that get results
not not ideas or concepts
people will listen to three or four or
five influencers
four of which don't make any money
like they're they're more interested in
likes and comments than they are a bank
account
i'm not interested in the influence like
i've never considered myself an
influencer i've considered myself a
businessman
so
i want to make money i want my companies
to make money i want the department to
make money i want the division to make
money to the degree that the company the
division the household is profitable the
country's profitable it means we're
doing good things
and so um
when john comes and listens to me
and then listens to another guy says oh
you need to save your money and i'm like
you need to use every penny you have to
grow your brand
if you got to go into debt to grow your
brand do that if you got a if you got to
borrow money
to to get connections do that and this
other guy's saying don't borrow money
well the guy's going to do nothing
little dave's going to do he won't do
anything because there's a conflict in
his mind grant said do it dave said
don't yeah
i won't do anything.
so what the problem of maybe too much
information
too
too much information that's conflicting
so he would be better off so i got to
make it clear dave's wrong
to my public
dave's wrong
but maybe dave's right for you but day's
wrong for me because i want to expand
dave's right for you because you want to
stay small oh by the way staying small
never works there is value in having a a
a partner in your relationships that is
not stuck in mechanics because the
mechanics stop people from the dream
yeah
you know if the new year you know i want
to do this i want to do that the
resolution stuff the big mistake that i
make in my goal setting is the moment i
set a goal i want to move to how to do
it and when i do that when i move to how
to
it stops me really yeah
immediately because i don't have the
money to do it
i don't have the time to do it
uh i don't live there i'm too old i'm
too young
i don't have the connections
uh
i don't know how to write a movie make a
movie get a tv whatever right i want a
netflix deal okay i don't know anybody
at netflix
so you move into the mechanics and the
moment you move into the mechanics you
you shatter the dream people are so
uncertain about their decisions
you don't want to give them any evidence
to be uncertain yeah
the presenter's job is to reinforce
certainty over and over again
you're doing the right thing people have
made so many mistakes
in their decisions that they become
they basically become people that make
no decision
which is a decision by the way right
no decision is a decision yeah choosing
not to act
and and and people don't choose to act
because they've lost certainty because
of previous
uh decisions
you guys got to get hard
you need to get hard okay it doesn't
mean you need to be mean i was telling
this guy this morning he's running a
company he's got 14 people he's like man
you know
he's like every time i come to you come
here i i see the way your people look at
you i see the way your people respect
you how do you do that i said dude i'm
hard
people don't respect soft in fact they
resent softness they resent being in
soft environments they start showing up
late they leave early the softer the
environment gets the less dangerous the
environment is the softer the
environment is and the less happy they
are i'm telling you when people get hard
people get happy
people are happier in dangerous
environments than they are in soft
environments you shouldn't listen to
your family
you just you know they already had their
shot at you yeah okay
i mean
you did i didn't listen to you when i
was seven
well all of a sudden i'm gonna start
taking advice from you yeah like my
sister my sister's like you're you're
too social i'm like dude please stop it
like
you're you're you you your whole life's
on social media they can see it all like
you don't know that number one you don't
even know that yeah
right that's her
she's not talking to me
even though your family members i just
i'm i just want the best thing for you
no they don't do they don't even want
the best thing for themselves
right
if they want the best things for
themselves explain their physical
condition explain why they got seven
different meds in their in their
medicine cabinet explain to me why their
marriage is suffering explain to me why
they don't they're not they haven't read
a book or been on a course or done
anything to improve their life in the
last 10 years they don't want the best
for you they don't want the best for
themselves don't tell me what you want
for me show me that your life is getting
better yeah that's the only people i
listen to
like i i listen to people that are doing
better than i do
and i go places where people are doing
significantly better than i am yeah and
the things that i measure is
you know a number of things your
spiritual condition is important to me
yeah what do you believe
if you got all the money in the world
and you you you are certain that there
is nothing else going on in this
universe i am not going to take material
advice from you because i believe
that the material and the spiritual are
just indicators of one another yeah if
you're rich or you're a godly man and
you're in terrible physical condition i
am not going to listen to you
when do you go all in
you go all in when you write a check
anybody that thinks they're going to go
all in in their head you're
this thing is not all mental i
understand you know i hear this all the
time on instagram dude is is 99 mental
yeah write a check for 10 million and
find find out how mental it is
you know because if you haven't if
you've gone from mental to physical
physical is i'm writing a check i have
an obligation i got a responsibility
buying a 140 million dollar real estate
complex that is not mental gotcha that
has nothing to do with mental that has
something to do with commitment
and i my belief is this there is no
commitment without time and money if
time and money are not present you have
not made a commitment yet and and i i i
know instagram is a beautiful place to
live
uh in your bedroom and and and and get
great great quotes and have people
inspire you with their beautiful
phenomenal plagiarisms but the reality
is look look this is not just an
attitude game it is a physical game okay
success is a physical
game it is a contact sport it requires
people to do something some people think
i'm just a social media guy okay you
know some people think uh know me from
the g e show some people know me as the
sales guy some people know me as
probably a huckster
and then you know but once you get in
some people see me as a really hard
person
most of the interviews i've done here
everybody's been very interested in my
spirituality
so uh a lot of people are starting to
call me the money guy now you know you
talk about money all the time so it's
fine with me dude it's it's what door
you know this this place has got 11
rooms in it
they're all very different
so it's like what door are you going to
come in and maybe you might come in that
door but not like it is there another
room that grant fits
because i want to be more than one thing
you know i think i think everybody wants
to be more than just
i imagine bruce lee wanted to be more
than just
you know the karate guy
absolutely so um hopefully i i you know
hopefully i figure out who i really am
and i and i think everybody has the
ability to be a lot of different things
not not just one thing the first company
the first real job i had was my sixth
job
i was fired from my first five
fired from my sixth job six times but
wouldn't leave the last one i just would
not leave so literally like
i'd wreck stuff i i have a
terrible driving record and i was in the
car business
and i'd wreck their cars and and they'd
fire me and i said okay okay okay
and i had a bunch of other problems as
well but
and then before i would leave
i would go sell something and then they
would keep me on if selling something
was always forgiveness as you're
starting to take 10x global you're
trying to go to all these countries
you're trying to do all of these things
like
why why are you doing that yeah i want
to meet people man
i want to meet everybody yeah i want to
meet seven billion people yeah
i want to meet people in nigeria and i
want to meet people in singapore and i
want to meet people in africa and
i think these are my friends i just
don't know them yet
you know i want i want to make i want to
put these little anchor points all over
the planet
so so that i have friends my family my
my kids have friends all over the world
having money is one thing but if you
don't have anybody to to have fun with
you know to have conversations with
to to to mix it up with then you're just
going to be a whole lonely person yeah
see this is crazy like like for me to
see as much as i use instagram and
facebook and youtube and snapchat and
all that stuff what a lot of people
don't see you guys out there is like i
still use this walk over say hi to
somebody walk out be seen you still have
to work the physical universe you can't
just work a virtual universe so
uh i could get you know
100 000 views uh on a
uh
on a post
but meeting one person face to face and
put him in my car to drive him to an
event to his next appointment can be
more valuable than than um
than
118 000 people seeing a post on that
post yeah instagram of me and mike tyson
yeah that one deal could be worth
hundreds of millions that one drive this
morning it could be worth hundreds of
millions of dollars when somebody's
depending on one income
first of all you're gonna hate that
you're gonna hate that one flow because
you need that one flow i talk about this
and sell or be sold if you only have one
customer you're going to end up
resenting that one customer
because you're having to kiss the ring
all the time and and you're going to
resent that at some point you're going
to be like i'm tired of kissing the ring
and when you have one flow of income
you start to resent it okay the more
flows of income a person has the more
they can actually work
and not be resentful
so
jared for instance he's got one flow
coming his wife works he's got a second
flow he's got real estate pain and he's
in almost every deal i've ever done i
think he is in every deal i've done he's
got like nine checks coming in from that
he doesn't resent this
he's doing everything he can to support
this and make sure this
keeps working
right because because he's not dependent
and if he died tomorrow
at 35 years old it's happened before
um
his kid jake
would keep getting checks from the real
estate we would quit paying him right
here i mean if i brought him in right
now he said don't you die this weekend i
ain't paying you money
you're done
so there's no nothing there's no life
insurance there's no i'm paying you a
severance fee because you died that we
out this weekend but the real estate
i'll just keep paying him forever so
that gives him security and most people
76 of americans don't have that they go
to work they collect a check they send
it to cheerios
or to starbucks or to a vacation
marriott appreciation depreciating asset
yeah or whatever to the to the nissan
motor company and the money's gone again
and no wonder they're pissed off no
wonder people got depression
you know i can't even go out dude i go
out i got to drink myself to death just
because i can't you know they're going
to vegas and they're coming back with
four or five thousand dollars worth of
debt for their one vacation
if they had the income from other
investments rather than a house that
they had to feed again next month that
that that would change their financial
situation my first company was working
for somebody else you know like until uh
it wasn't until i figured out how to
make somebody else rich that i could be
rich like
i hear a lot of guys saying i don't want
to work for somebody else i don't want
to keep making other people
when i became successful in another
company
and then left that company and went and
worked for another company and made them
super successful to the point to where
these companies were literally dependent
upon me
like that that's the thing that's the
muscle
and the grit
the the uh
persistence and fortitude
are like you know what i don't my ego
wasn't like i need my name on it but my
ego was strong enough to say i want to
be the best
in the company like i want to make this
company dependent upon me success is so
important success is my duty
responsibility and obligation to myself
forget my family for a second
i need success for me to feel good about
me so i can be good with my family
and um i think a lot of people are
trying to do their life without having
success be part of it success is part of
my mental
like i think i think success actually is
the best medication for my mental health
because because when i'm successful dude
i'm happy i'm a good father i'm a good
dad you know a good husband um
so
yeah just you know it's vital that
people are successful that's what i
would tell people man you need to make
it a priority you need to make it as
important as everything else that's
important to you in your life i was
selling cars okay you can only make so
much money selling cars you can only be
i would have probably bought car
dealerships yeah i would have had
somebody saying dude look come up with a
plan here
you know you hate your job because
you're thinking too small
you know when i was at mcdonald's i got
fired from mcdonald's
because i was thinking too small i hated
flipping french fries i should have been
thinking about owning 50 or 60 or 100 or
200 mcdonald franchises
because then it becomes interesting
now your audience is going to say i
don't need all that yeah i know because
somebody told you you don't need all
that this couple came in here this
morning and says bro how'd you develop
this hardness you got
i said i don't know i didn't know that i
did develop a hard thing my dad died
when i was 10 though that's pretty
permanent
like you're 10 years old and you're like
okay that's a that's something you
cannot negotiate with
gone is gone
all the things you wanted to say all the
things you wanted to do all the fishing
trips you wanted to have with your pops
you ain't gonna have them bro
okay so you guys out there that are
lucky enough to have a dad that's alive
maybe we want to do the hard thing this
weekend
you know call him
call him up maybe y'all been having this
fight for 12 years maybe you call him up
man maybe you just go ahead and eat it
you know quit arguing about something
dumb that happened a long time ago
do the hard thing hard thing is always
the right thing
whether it's making decisions in a deal
to get the best deal people are like man
you're so cheap i'm buying a 168 million
dollar piece of property dude i ain't
cheap i'm smart
my good you don't want to pay us
anything i am the only one buying
anything here
i'm buying this office building right
now the the seller's like god damn you
you you're so slippery dude i ain't
slippery i'm the only one here trying to
buy a damn place from you
right
you calling me slippery why you calling
me slippery cause you slippery
i'm trying to buy the damn place
okay
what you slipping on dawg
i ain't slippery i'm renegotiating right
now with some new data i think i was in
bogota i was in bogota speaking to a
church
and i went into the to the grocery store
and coca-cola was there i don't know why
that impressed me so much
but i was like goddamn coca-cola's in
bogota
you know
and then i think i was in cancun on the
way coming on the way back in mexico and
i was like oh cancun's
front and center in the shop in the
grocery store there
then i got back to miami i was in the
the uh
movie and i'm like coca-cola i'm like
[ __ ] everywhere dude these they're
everywhere why am i not everywhere
you know so all my answers have come to
me because i look it's not really me
hearing somebody say something i'm
looking i'm watching what people do or
companies do not listening to what they
do
because there's a big difference between
what people say and what people do
like warren buffett what warren buffett
tells people on tv every day and what he
does they're almost like completely
different the problem that people need
to complain about right now is not the
billionaires they need they need to
understand that the
because what they're saying is there's
income inequality
wealth inequality but the reality is
there's education inequality okay the
billionaires play by a different set of
rules than everybody else
so do i blame
the guy playing by a different set of
rules or do i blame the game
you know the the old saying about uh
don't hate the player yeah hate the game
you need to learn how to win at the game
don't hate anybody don't hate the game
don't hate the player
learn the game and the game of the
wealthy the the rules are stacked for
wealthy institutions and and wealthy
families yeah and and people need to
like understand what those rules are
yeah and those games are those rules
those games investing yeah not spending
yeah i'm gonna i'm not gonna buy i'm not
gonna buy a house
i'm gonna buy a company
yeah uh you know donald trump everybody
hates jobs huh create jobs yeah i'm not
gonna have a job
i'm gonna create jobs
like the difference is donald trump he
he buys a building in new york he lives
in it
he doesn't buy a house and live in it he
buys a building and lives in it rents
out the whole place he literally gets
paid to live where he is
right and then moves into the white
house
so
same thing with the queen okay
like like look look at the play man yeah
i mean are you going to take the queen's
stuff from her
this is not me nobody is nobody is
people been trying to take her stuff for
70 years ain't nobody taking their stuff
so this is not a new thing this is not a
new problem like this is thousands of
years old play the game of the wealthy
own things own businesses don't spend
money yeah invest money
don't waste it on cars and bicycles and
like if you look at the average family
in in in the uk
they will spend
ridiculous money on things their kids
want
look i take care of my kids
but i don't just frivolously buy them
junk yeah
like okay it's only eighty nine dollars
i'm gonna get it for them and it's worth
nothing the next day that's where that's
where the difference is yeah
and then and then the wealthy they
invest money to connect with people okay
most people most people go home at night
so they can be with their family
the thinking's different
so these guys are going to go to devos
and meet with bill gates and and and
warren buffett
and spend millions
making connections not
tens of thousands millions of dollars
where the average household in the uk is
like i just want to go home tonight
watch tv and you get people are getting
punished for that he took that 45
caliber and jammed it in my face cracked
me right here in the forehead this guy
had to be this big hovered over me with
a gun in my face and when he did my
reaction was to hit him with the plate
in the face thing breaks and he becomes
like
a monster
blood's coming down
every wall in this apartment in this
room and the ceiling has blood on it
this was the exclamation mark on where
my life had gone from being a good kid
to this far from dying i spent three
days in the hospital
and i'm like i'm done no more drugs i'm
done using drugs okay guess what happens
i'm using drugs 15 minutes later 10
times a day in the hospital
my mom
says to me you're no longer welcome in
my home you're no longer welcome in my
business
i don't want to see you anymore
24 hours later i was in a treatment
center
because my mom had the courage to say
enough is enough i'm done
i go to this treatment center i'm there
30 days for the first 30 days in seven
eight nine years
i don't use drugs
and before i leave the counselor grabs
me and the counselor says to me look
dude i'll see you back here probably you
know if you don't die i'll see you back
here and i'm like what are you talking
about dude i'm not coming back here and
he's like oh no you're coming back all
you're ever going to be is a drug addict
you need to give up all the ideas of
writing books speaking to audiences
being rich i always wanted to be rich i
wanted financially to be rich my whole
life i wanted to be my dad i wanted to
be the guy that could take care of his
family they said you need to give up all
those ideas and settle for one thing
not using drugs again
25 years old moved back into my mom's
house tell my mom let me live back in
the house i'm coming back i'm not using
drugs and i'm going to rebuild my life
from that day on to 25 i made some
commitments number one was
i cannot afford free time every time i
had free time i got in trouble
so i knew i had to one eliminate the old
bad friends two i had to keep all free
time busy
and i said what are you good at grant
and and i'm like what are you good at
what are you really good at and i'm like
i'm good at going all the way
because even with the drugs i was an all
the way kind of guy right i need to 10x
everything like like 10 was that number
my dad died when i was 10. i was using
drugs 10 times a day i was trying to
quit 10 times a day i'm like you got to
start liking something man and more
importantly you got to get good at
something so i said i'm going to take
the job that i don't like
and i'm going to get great at it it was
a sales job that i hated every day
i would go to work
early i'd stay late
okay i was doing 10 hour days at least
10 hours
if i needed to make one call i would
make 10.
if i needed to see one customer if i
thought i need to see one customer i
would fill it up with 10 customers
whatever i thought i needed to do
i literally
took this drug problem and poured this
obsession with destruction
into an obsession with
i'm going to just ten times everything
keep myself busy i studied everything i
became a fanatic some therapist some
psychiatrist is going to say oh this
dude this dude's got add i've already
been told that please i've had every
label that the sykes put in books
i've been labeled that okay look i never
had any of those problems
i had potential that was being unused so
i wake up early i get a workout in and i
get to the office when i get to the
office a calendar is laid out and i need
to see every 30 minutes something filled
in that calendar the counselor back in
the treatment center said to me dude
aren't you worried about because he's
seen my success now and he's like aren't
you worried about burning out i'm like
dude you're the burnout bro you're the
burnout you're the one that said i was
going to come back you're the one that
said i would never make it you're the
one that said uh don't write books i've
written seven of them man
i'm not worried about burnout i am not a
candle
candles burn out spiritual beings don't
my message to you is that
you're not doing enough okay if you
could do it once or twice then you can
do it 20 times just multiply
and and i hear a lot of people say when
is enough enough
those of you who ask that question when
is enough enough maybe you haven't have
enough had enough failures because if
you get disappointed and disgusted
enough with your life you will not ask
when is enough success enough i want to
give people permission
to be complete addicts junkies obsessed
maniacs all in
freakazoids that do everything 10 times
more than you think you need to i want
to see how hot can i burn
okay how far can i go how much light can
i bring the world how much positive
truth message can i bring this planet
how much more can i do do not try
[Music]
the competition thing
it's overrated and it doesn't work and
i'm going to prove it to you right here
in a second
okay this is a private
what's called an fbo
everybody that flies in here
owns their own aircraft
you don't want to try to be the biggest
jet okay
you don't want to try to beat up most
money you don't want to try to be the
like the best of the best they'll always
be somebody faster and stronger
and richer okay don't play the game oh i
got to be number one what does that even
mean man i gotta be the biggest what
does that even mean i gotta have the
biggest car the biggest watch the
hottest chick
what does that mean it's a game you
cannot win at okay you will get your
brains handed to you i'm going to show
you what i mean right here in a second
that plane right there that's a little
lure jet right there i think it's a
little leer or phenom i don't have all
my jets right
i don't know that you can buy that plane
for about 800 grand right next to it a
little bigger
look what's rolling up right here a
little challenger
we got a little gulf stream 4 right
there
that that's leaks
13. don't try to play the game i'm the
biggest
[Music]
game okay
it's a loser's game man i'm gonna show
you some equipment out here
because anybody like here's a little
phenom 100
that plays about 5 million bucks great
playing faster fast so fast
seat seven people okay maybe four or
five million bucks
great playing great starter plane
look at this see that right out there
that's a 20 passenger jet right there
okay now notice what's right next to it
john
[Music]
okay that's a 727 that a hotel owned
if you try to play that game the
competition game i'm the strongest i'm
the best you lose that game
you got to find what you need in life
what's enough for you you guys got to
define that i can't define it for you
most people are coming up short on that
game
but there's a lot of other people that
are making the mistake when they get in
the game and they start playing they got
to keep reaching
not because they need it
but because their ego
is like oh i gotta be the biggest
and you know what
you are you're gonna turn into it like
that a hotel owns that
that plane's probably 200 million
dollars back there the point is don't
play i gotta be the strongest
because sooner or later you won't be
[Music]
find out what you need
look look look on that plane over there
hey look at my little plane look at my
little plane see you're like man grant
man man your little plane
and i'm now flash over to this one
see
if i'm doing the comparison thing the
competition thing it's a loser's game we
were talking before the cameras went on
and uh something you said was really
interesting and that is um you're a
micro manager yeah and that's not the
popular speak at the moment so why do
you love micro managing and what i kind
of love it more why do you have to do it
i don't love it it's just survival like
it's like like like if you have a heart
attack
do you want to be micromanaged yeah
probably i'm like dude put put
everything on me put you put things on
me on top of me in me you do whatever
you got to do make sure every vital i
got going is working
so you know i operate my business like
it's it's a it's a
it's an organism that needs
um
it's vitals checked you know and it
needs some prodding
to operate by you all the time
well because because i i tend to be the
one most interested
you know i'm the one most interested and
i have an eye for things that other
people for whatever reason don't say
so rather than me getting furious about
them not doing it or not seeing it
or
quitting okay just turn it over to them
i mean what does that mean turn it over
to them who turn it over to who the
idiots
the crazies
i worked at a company
okay turn it over to grant
i'm i'm 20 26 years old
i'm worried about one thing paying my
bills this month i'm not worried about
the company man how are you going to
turn that over to me i'm not ready to
have something turned over to me
you've met enough managers and ceos and
vice presidents
you know jared jared's a good guy
jared's been with me 10 years
i ain't turning it over to it
10 years he just got a new baby so what
does he have now he's got a company he's
got me he's got his wife now he's got
jake
he doesn't see some stuff because his
mind's filled with okay i gotta take
care of my wife this month i gotta j i
can't wait to see jake this afternoon
when i get home it's 3 30 in the
afternoon we set up a landing page it's
not right he didn't see it
he he told bob do the landing page and
never looked at it again see i tell bob
to do the landing page i'm like bob do
the landing page
show me the landing page i mean i trust
no one
i trust no one your wife to do their job
uh no no show me how much did you spin
at chanel show me
i want to see it dude like because if
you don't know because most times she's
going to be like if you if you see her
you ought to try to get this clip okay
say hey what is the one thing that
drives that guy crazier than anything
when you don't know yeah
and and if you if you go back to your
staff and just say hey what are the
stats today dude what do we do today
they don't know
so if it's a really important stat
look i don't micromanage everything okay
it's not like i do everything but the
important things
i want to know every detail yeah okay
and and
i think that a lot of a lot of
executives have checked out
you know they've checked out of the
company yeah and they're not paying
attention anymore no they got it
i'm delegating it so so what i do is i
get graphs on every important statistic
in the organization every day okay my
like my cash accounts i see them every
morning is that micro managing every
cash account i have
or maybe it's transparency of what's
going on in your business i want to see
it dude show me show me
statistics i want to know
the more important the graph is the more
important the statistic is the more
often i want to see a number an update
on it so like we're getting ready for
our growth conference okay we're uh what
it what november december january we're
about 90 days out
somewhere in the next week or so i'll be
like i want to report every 15 minutes
every 15 minutes i want to report now
what's that going to do to jared and the
team you know i have another baby
zero we did we got zero this 15 minutes
okay hey move that bar move it move it
man
okay i want to get this thing sold out i
do not want to be worried about this
thing later yeah so i either micromanage
now or wait until the thing's in cardiac
arrest i was making some money like in
my 30s and 40s i made you know i made a
lot of money
what other people would call a lot of
money yeah
but i was not a business you know what i
mean i was just what do you mean by that
well i was just hustling
training just because you're hustling
everything was a transaction yeah
everything everything was a transaction
to get money pay the taxes have a little
bit of money left over everything was in
a transaction yeah and um
and this guy's like well you know you're
not a business
and i was like i know man i know don't
tell anybody i know that okay like i
knew it
and because because to me a business is
i can walk away from it'll still operate
i was i was a guy i was no different
than when i was 30 just pounding doors
and which was good which was good and i
think a lot of people need to you don't
need to skip that spot either because
once i put the two together okay i can
pound the door i can learn e-commerce
um i can be i can be a one-product sale
i could sell to companies like today
we'll sell we'll sell a product to a
company for
80 grand
on a on a three to five year contract 80
grand a year
and i'll switch immediately and sell an
eight dollar product online or i'll give
something away for free
to speaking to 4 000 people today in
hopes that i can meet you know maybe 40
of them that i can do have a partnership
and a collaboration with
in the future
so what like you said 10 years ago
people someone said to you you have a
you don't have a business what what
changed like like how have you built
what you've built now like
yeah well is that when the whole 10x
philosophy well yeah yeah exactly 10x10x
10x woke me up 10x was not for for the
public 10x was for me i was trying to
figure out why am i i work hard i got
great products got a great reputation
great reviews people like me they like
my content
they like my content actually better
than they like me and that might have
been an exaggeration you know what i
mean
and and uh
but but even if they didn't like me
they're like dude your content's so
ridiculous it's so good like whether
it's sales closing marketing promotion
and a lot of it i wasn't even taking my
own advice
like like i was given advice and not
taking it so when the economy crashed
which was i guess almost 10 years ago
in america particularly
it was so devastating that if you had
any weakness in a business like every
weakness
was shown you know warren buffett talked
about hey what are you wearing when the
tide goes out well dude in 2008 9 and 10
when the tide went out
every weakness that i had exhibited
hard work did not did not
leave you
less vulnerable in 2010
you could have worked hard and still
you'd be upside down in your house you
could lose everything your cash accounts
are garbage
stock got wrecked everything right so
2010 was really the whisper you're not a
business son
that that that was the big you're not a
business and and that's when i made a
decision okay i'm gonna build a business
i hope you're gonna have a great day
today because i am
i'm gonna have a great day if it's a bad
day i'm gonna turn it into a great day
because that's what i do
take a bad day turn it into a great day
some of the some of some of the days
that have started off bad for me have
been the best days of my life
you just got to hang in there you got to
stay in there
you got to keep pushing and shoving and
saying dude i'm gonna make a bad day a
great day
i'm gonna flip this thing i'm gonna turn
it on its head it's just a day
just today let me turn this thing you
turn enough bad days into great days
you'll end up with a great life
that's it man nobody they don't teach
that in school
how do you flip how do you flip how do
you stay in deals how do you turn bad
deals bad customers bad relationships
how you turn bad situations
into into into moments in your life
where you're like dude i turned around
right there
you know i was a
i walked out of a treatment center when
i was 25 god told me i would never make
it
that i was just a drug addict that i was
a junkie for life
that if i if i ever like this dude tell
me man you don't give up every idea of
being a star
famous rich
an author
superstar businessman you know
you don't give up all those ideas
you'll never make it he's like any
expectations all these big giant dreams
and expectations you have or why
uh you're having problems in your life i
walked out of there i'm like that dude
i was in the treatment center i'm the
one who went to the treatment center
with the problem
that dude
had a bigger problem than i had people
got to keep working on themselves yeah
you're trying new things you got to give
something up like i'm always giving
stuff up
my life changed when i gave stuff up
when i was 25 and i gave drugs up i'm
like okay i'm done
and then you give up your friends
right because when you start
changing they're going to go people
don't like it
they're going to go or you're going to
come back
and if you're not i i truly believe that
if you're not changing your friends
you're not changing
your friends should be they should be
like
every few years a cycle yeah or they
should be changing growing with you
they're not going to grow with you
really
well i hope they'll grow later i hope
i'm friends with you in 10 years yeah
but but we will be yeah we will be you
know but
but like i know i know i dated this girl
her friends were her childhood friends
[Music]
she never changed yeah it's tough
none of them changed the whole group
never changed like for me to change you
can't i can't think of being your best
friends that me and are going to have
we're going to change at the same time
[Music]
we have different reasons to change
throughout life right right and and
elena and i we'll have different times
when we want to change my kids like my
kids are going to change and they're
going to leave
one hundred percent they're gonna leave
right
i don't want i don't wanna do this
anymore right they're gonna go flying
private back to flying commercial
until they coach yeah until they figure
out how to fly private if if they even
want to do that yeah
but but i've always said i've changed so
many times i've moved i've been five or
six different cities that's been great
for me every every move has been better
for me
i've changed friends i've had lifelong
friends that
i know him but
you're not hanging out every day no i've
moved on when i was a kid glenn i was
like
i knew i was going to do something great
and had zero
reason to believe that right
like it was a total fantasy
or maybe not
i think everybody has that i would
imagine that every kid
um
has this idea that they're they're
they're meant for greatness
i know i did i always thought i was
gonna be something great i remember my
twin brother uh he he would he'd be in
the mirror man he's like eight years old
we're eight years old he's singing in
here like he's a rock star right i had
to listen to that all the time
and and then i started thinking man man
if he's going to be a rock star
what he's going to go on and be a big
rock star
and and and i can't you know
because i that that that wasn't my deal
i said what am i gonna be
and then i thought i'm gonna be a
baseball player
i actually believed i was gonna be a
baseball player right dude i wasn't fast
enough i wasn't strong enough i didn't
have the arm i mean i had no talent
i didn't have the work ethic you know i
didn't have somebody pushing me so
i've just always underestimated what i
could do i think everybody does that
that's why this 10x thing that's why i
keep telling people man you're you're
thinking too small when i talk to people
about real estate don't do two units
gotta start somewhere no you don't have
to start with two units
you could actually start with 32
right
and and by the way it's going to be a
lot easier to make money on 32 than it
is to sure
if if you could just believe that you
can
you know and right now is a time where
people are going to have to start
believing they can do something else
because we're going to move into a
period of time now
where there's going to be massive
transition enforced transition on
everyone what's your attitude to fear
and risk
uh yeah you got it you got you got it
you got it you gotta you gotta take risk
the the the best way to stay out of
harm's way is to be the most dangerous
person in the room right i like that you
know yeah like
yeah do you ever though sometimes think
man i'm taking two bigger risks every
scenario every deal i do yeah every deal
in it to make you feel alive
no i know i'm alive i i just i just um
you know like when you take on an arena
and you're like i'm in a book there's 5
000 people here okay
my my my gig did had seven times that
many people 35 000 people yeah i mean i
sold out an arena as big as jay-z and
beyonce would sell out
the difference is i had them there for
three days they have them there for two
hours
on super bowl weekend
our biggest
football
you know
you guys laugh at our football but we
love it right so so
the biggest
sports weekend
in the united states of america super
bowl weekend i held my event on that
weekend
getting insane a year ago
the last time i was on this interview
i think i just started working out every
day and my body was hurting all the time
i was in pain constantly
you didn't want to do it you were
struggling dude my ankles hurt my knees
hurt my back hurt my like like i had
constant pain in my body why'd you keep
doing it
doing what working out no that that
that's no that i wasn't working before
you started working but you were in pain
i wasn't using my body i didn't use it
and it started to abandon me
like i wasn't paying attention to it you
know and it's like okay dude
you know you don't want to pay attention
to me
i'm going to make you baby i don't pay
attention to you
you know or maybe i'll make you pay
attention to me yeah and then i got i
went to a pt uh three days a week that
really didn't do anything and i said you
know what i need to take responsibility
for this if i want to fix something that
that that that's the code of my life do
you want to fix something take
responsibility yeah you take
responsibility don't give it over to the
physical therapist the masseuse i was
trying the masseuse the masseuse never
helped me
i needed to put muscle on my bones
so i
i hired a guy named anthony he came i
said you come to the you come to my
place every day
same time every day here's the money
here take the money here's the schedule
i'm never gonna miss a day wow and he
travels with you too or no no no
this was in the first year got it
and um
you know it's been 14 months i have
almost zero pain in my body i had a guy
the other day asked me for some advice
okay you know these people that ask for
advice i know you know
you give it to them and they they don't
do it yeah
he knew it was true it hit him
he's like i know that's right and then
he went and did something different this
is a big mistake people make man things
the best things that have happened to me
did not require
any more thought
the best decisions i've made in my life
were instant
so like my wife and i like when i've
decided to buy something i go buy it i
don't check with her because that adds
thought
it adds time
and and
this is another bad piece of advice i
was given like take time
think about it don't move too fast take
baby steps
uh you don't know nobody on this planet
ever took baby steps
they went fast
and and the faster you can go you know
my plane is safest when it's up in the
air when it's landing slowing down it's
in trouble when it's taken off it's at
risk that's interesting at flight at
full speed it's almost the safest that
thing wants to fly
you know and and people people are being
conditioned to slow down think about it
take your time take a drug i was put on
lithium when i was 20 29 years old
because the the psychologist thought i
needed to slow down
she was scared of speed
i wasn't and at that time were you doing
well financially or doing i was doing
great but everybody was saying hey
you're doing too much of this and you're
doing too much of that and you're going
to burn and you're going to do this and
people were worried about me around me
they were going slow i was vibrating
faster than they were
but a hummingbird vibrates bumblebees
vibrate right they do things that are
impossible
so
you don't want to slow down
and and you want to move with speed and
certainty that means people need to know
what they're doing
if i know what i'm doing that's why
confident people tiger won today tiger
one today he'd been fighting man been
efforting ten years he hadn't had a win
he won today that guy moves with speed
and certainty
you know winners move with speed and
certainly because they practice they
train they educate i'm a student of
observation i i observe things i
remember being being selling cars saying
this is stupid
first i learned how to do it right
customer the 12 steps right and then i'm
like if i do 12 steps with everybody i
can't get 30 units a month
and then i'm like i started skipping
steps right
uh i mean because i wanted i wanted
those 10 car car weeks
and the only way to do that was walk out
there and just start offering people
what they had what they what they were
going to ask me for anyway right can i
get you a price a payment a down payment
a monthly bank can i get you everything
you need right i knew that it was just a
matter of about 30 seconds they were
going to ask for it all no doubt so i
just basically intercepted the customer
sped up the processes and and then i'm
like man i started hitting 30 36 units
31 units in 14 days i'm like this is the
way to do it and then when i lost my job
because the dealer wasn't big enough
didn't think big enough himself didn't
10x
when i left him i didn't have any place
to go
in his company or his organization i
couldn't be a star there
um
i went out and started teaching that
what would you say is the best advice
that you could give other people from
what you learned about making their
first million bucks so say somebody's
making six figures scaling up and that's
just do the math you know what's what's
first of all do you want to make a
million
or do you want to keep a million
they're completely they're like 60
percent difference between those two
questions right so specificity and the
goal you want to make everybody's
everybody watching is going to make a
million dollars i mean if you live
25 years you're going to make a million
dollars 25 times 40 000 bucks bang you
made a million dollars if that's your
goal so this is what i talked about in
the 10x rule the goals people are
setting
are incorrect and that's why people give
up on their goals
because
i know so many guys that hit a million
dollars like i've had so many people
come to me and say i hit a million
and i lost the juice
yeah it got comfortable almost yeah a
lot of guys in network marketing tell me
this like i was in network marketing i
became a million dollar producer
just lost it because the goal was wrong
the goal was wrong first of all it
wasn't your goal
anybody's got a million dollar target
it's not your goal you adopted this goal
this idea from somebody else
because the number any number that ends
in zero is a lazy number
the chance is a number ending in zero is
almost mathematical what a great point
what a great point so it's a lazy
concept you just adopted somebody else's
idea i want to be a millionaire would do
you have even done the math do the math
on a million dollars it's no money this
is why people they they like god hate
grant
because your target was a million
you're struggling making 200. you think
a million is impossible
you don't want me to tell you the truth
and the truth is it is no money as soon
as you get it i read the book the
millionaire next door almost everybody
read that book back in the 90s
it was the best book for me
because it taught me
i don't want to be a millionaire
it lifted the lid i'm like i don't want
to be the guy buying a ford truck
i don't want a ford truck man
right i got to buy a ford truck a used
ford truck f-150
so one day i could be a millionaire yeah
and i can't go get coffee i need to
bring a brown pack to my office every
day
not drink coffee at the shop
in order to be a millionaire well the
reason i knew that was not good for me
was because my dad died at
with a little bit of money
and i'm like i don't want to die
with money when i'm old
i want to have enough money
and that that undid everything for me i
want financial freedom i don't want to
hit a quota
you know and i think everybody's
struggling for the quota they're
struggling for the bills they set their
financial plan based on what their
spending is or what their apartment
costs or what the mortgage is rather or
what their kids need rather than i want
freedom i don't want financial literacy
i want financial freedom you know so i
hear people say oh we need to teach
financial literacy no you need to teach
financial freedom the possibility of it
what would i need how much
you know this whole cash flow thing that
i talk about all the time cash flow is
the holy grail of finance
that's why his business works that's why
he's able to enjoy the lifestyle he has
he has
financial freedom not a money number two
weeks ago i went i went uh plant only
plant-based plant-based that for you i
dropped the meat dude that's so i want
to do i did that for a week last week
yeah and i thought amazing i had a lot
more gas just from all the plants i
think but cleaning it out
that's really too much information for
me
but i've had uh way more energy yeah but
like and less inflammation and less pain
yeah i had noticed i have a little bit
of inflammation in in my hands but yeah
that hadn't hadn't changed but
the plant-based thing i watched the game
the the game changes yeah and uh when he
said
dude you're eating the middleman
like when i heard that that was enough
for me right eating the middleman you're
eating the middleman
meaning the cow the cow eats the grass
right you can go eat go right
the source is the grass yeah and as soon
as i heard that i'm like what the [ __ ]
am i doing eating the middleman
i ain't the middle man guy i want to go
directly to the source
where all the energy's at yeah i mean
like like
that was the line in the show that did
me and i had been thinking about it too
i've eaten meat for 60 years i grew up
on bacon
four pieces of bacon every day so good
uh oh yeah totally
the eggs i i have not eaten any meat
in 12 days
and my energy is
this all day long oh wow
3 30 in the afternoon for the last 25
years i crashed at 3 30. hard crash i
mean like
i'll see you guys uh call me later okay
what you doing at 3 30. i got him i got
a meeting yeah that meeting was on that
nap dude and when i hit it i'm talking
coma
[Laughter]
deep sleep
better than
sleep at night sometimes it would be 30
minutes sometimes it'd be an hour and a
half
like comatose 12 days i can't take a nap
i try to go take a nap i cannot fall
asleep
so i'll give my energy do you think
you're gonna stick with this do you
think you'll have meat sometimes you
think i mean i'm not i'm not like i'm
not a fanatic guys so so it's a little
meat here and there or something i'm
just gonna eat what makes me feel best
yeah so i don't care if it was meat if
it was pork it was bacon but right now
um
as long as i can find the greens
and i haven't met i haven't missed the
meat wow
my digestion's better
you know
my energy is great
so
i don't know man our goal at the 10x
growth conference and all the events i
do even the free events i do around
we're going to do 50 free events this
year that's crazy man and uh the reason
i'm doing that is because i know guys
that i don't like can't do it
yeah
like you go try to do a free event
right
now
people don't bleed out dude i'll bleed
the guy out that's the proper way to use
money by the way
[Laughter]
this is straight out of it if you're not
first your last you know do what your
competition cannot get the fastest way
to grow a business is to collaborate
with other people is to find uh these
ferries that are going back and forth
b-roll okay uh the ferries uh dude i
mean i could build a boat or i could
just go on one of those exactly right
and
what what we're doing today is we are
drafting or just collaborating with yeah
um
cardone capital
i don't go build apartments no i buy
apartments that are already built
that way i can scale faster if i if i
was trying to do the building thing now
now construction
teams right
um
now along the way i'm fixing i'm
adjusting as i go okay but but i need to
get in the water start swimming in some
direction i think too many people are
trying to figure out where they're going
yeah
and by the time you figure it out
somebody's already there what would be
um
a few non-negotiables yeah everyone
should take with their money like if
okay if you don't know if you got a
hundred thousand you want to get to a
million you got a million went to 10.
pay attention to it okay pay attention
you should look at your money every day
look at it every day look at the bank
account look at the bank account how
many what are your cash accounts and
what are your investments
look at it every day every single day it
takes what is that five seconds what
does that do for you where am i
inventory
personal inventory mm-hmm
so where am i it's measurable you can
see it yeah if it's zero look at it
until it makes you sick
okay and then you see some money sitting
in a bank okay you got 100 grand sitting
in a bank account or 50 grand okay you
need look look what's what is it earning
people are unconscious they don't know
where their money is this is the scam on
on on this planet you get money you work
your ass off and then you give it to an
institution and you forget that it's
there
wells fargo is paying you nothing bank
of america is paying you nothing
you send it to chase they're not paying
you anything you sent it to to the
mutual fund you don't even know what
it's invested in it's invested in stuff
you don't even believe in right
it's invested in war stocks tobacco
stocks drug companies
like you that's not things you even
believe in like like people have their
money like
that's that's not even
conducive with the things they believe
in in their life yeah
so um
you know if you don't drink alcohol why
would you invest your money in alcohol
stocks true
so so pay attention to where the money
is what is it paying you
where is it look at it every day it
takes literally two minutes or less i
was in tokyo tokyo said 20-year
i appreciate this conversation by the
way
because not enough people talk about
economics but you know japan's had a
20-year
contraction
[Music]
the the population's getting older the
young people are moving out but the real
estate in japan in tokyo particularly
you could have been invested in the
tokyo real estate for the last 20 years
the economy is going like this and that
property is still doing this because it
produces income and and it won't go away
it's still going to be there tokyo is
going to be tokyo 20 years from now yeah
and and you just can't get this hub
right here this spot is going to be here
and so people need to start positioning
themselves for a bigger much bigger
thing
and it's what keeps people from doing
more business with you because the think
is so small this depression thing like
this this is a topic that interests me
so much have you ever dealt with it at
all totally okay almost my whole life
still a little bit uh
no well what happens is socially we say
it's depression
but what if
okay what if
it wasn't depression and it was just
truth
that i'm having to sleep with my own
truth that i can do
more right so why wouldn't i be a bit
depressed
if i have this potential and i'm
operating here every individual knows
what they're capable of
right so if i know i have this much
potential
and i'm living here
wouldn't i be like a little bit
disappointed with myself
now where did where what happened where
because back in the 50s
there was no depression nobody was
talking about depression people were
talking about how do i get to the next
level
right today in our in our psychiatric
community where where drugs are where
the average american has eight
prescriptions sitting in their medicine
cabinet like i'm on one drug i gotta
take a second drug to handle the third
drug because of a blood pressure drug
because of this drug and dude i'm
stacking out like
why
because i was depressed why am i
depressed
because i don't look like i don't have
his arms
i have the potential to have his arms
maybe not
okay pretty close but but but it would
require me to go to work right or or i
need to look a different way or i'm i'm
aging or whatever the deal is right like
so for me i have always struggled with
depression
but it was more because people were
telling me i was depressed when the
truth is i was just disappointed man me
too i was disappointed with me me too
you know my mom my mom would always tell
me my mom was always the first person i
would call
anytime i scored
and she was my best friend
and and she passed when when about nine
years ago when sabrina was born five
days later sabrina was born and um
every score i had i was 51 years old man
between 25 and 51 every score i had my
mom was the first person i called mom i
did this every time she had the same
response
son that's great but i love you just the
way you are
over and over she told me that and then
one day i'm like
but i don't
now i can't really say that a whole
bunch of people are going to say why
don't you love you just the way you are
something wrong with you because there's
that whole culture out there this this
uh i don't know what the term is but
it's a um
this
this this holistic idea that you should
love yourself the way you are i would
tell everybody dude if you know that you
can do more do not love who you are
achieve who you can be
because you can be more
he's done it
i've done it
and and i did it by by by replacing the
depression concept not doing the drugs
by the way i was put on them like five
or six times
and threw him away and just said you
know what i'm going to go for my goals
i'm going to go for the think my
potential if i'm going to screw this up
i'ma i'm going to screw it up grant's
way not that way
i saw a video post the other day about
millionaires are broke or something yeah
on instagram well i can't remember
exactly what it was like never never
take advice from you never take advice
from a millionaire and and the reason
why is because
you know millionaires are not
they're not certain about their money
yet they're scared actually i mean if
you ask them just go ask them hey
what got you a million dollars i was out
there hustling working deals da da then
when you got a million what happened
you started worrying about losing it
what's what do i do with this money and
you start saving it and protecting it
you were taking risks when you were you
had nothing
you took a risk when you had nothing you
took risks when you had 100 took risk
when you had 300 then you quit taking
risk in a million
so that's why i said never take advice
from a millionaire
because they're going they go into
conservation mode yeah
the billionaire never goes into
conservation mode
like all the way up he's just like
expansion
look at elon
sells paypal
walks away with three million dollars
puts it all on a bang bang bang and
rinse
right
rinse where he lifts bored money to rent
yeah shoved it all in it's crazy
millionaire never do that why takes all
his chips off the table
then it then looks at his chips and he's
scared he's going to lose him again the
idea here is look commit
okay and this is the problem with the
schooling system everything's got to be
figured out first i got to read the
instruction first like nobody really
does read this i never read the answer i
wrote an article about it i don't read
any instructions you know and so
i mean i can't i can't read them because
they're so small
so so uh and even when i could read them
i'm like i don't want to read the
instructions can't they make this
simpler yeah so and that is the premise
there yeah can't it just be simpler yeah
and and the way to make it simple is and
we see this happening today i mean this
is happening on a global scale where
picking a car up now is simple
pick me up it's crazy i don't have to
put the address in it should locate
where i am
car picks me up i put in the destination
tells guy where to go don't even need to
pay for it either it's already i know
that's set up like simple you guys got
everything should be simplified and the
way to simplify things i remember
mercedes benz years ago i heard about
this when they had first figured out how
to put a drop back a hard top
uh convertible into the trunk they had
never they couldn't figure it out it
used to be these old you know they'd
hang them up in the garage and take them
off and it was like very laborious and
somebody at mercedes-benz said
don't tell me what it's going to cost
tell me when it's done
just get it done no matter what this is
how the elon musk are thinking today you
know this is why apple keeps creating a
crazy product while this will go away
somebody's going to come along one day
and say get rid of the phone
and i still want to communicate yeah and
it'll probably be on a headset more like
this we'll probably we'll probably go in
here right where i'm popping i mean the
watches yeah they're they're moving
there right it's crazy
so to where i don't even need a watch i
won't need anything it's like okay i
want to call bye-bye we're moving in
that direction of less and faster and
simpler so the way the human being does
that he's in brisbane this morning the
gold coast
i got to get down there he's committed
he doesn't figure he he just gets a
flight
no research
no no you weren't researching it last
night no not at all if you didn't if you
didn't know about this last night you'd
have been you'd have been doing work
about it last night planning negotiating
with the airlines when you get
compressed on time and you got a
commitment you're like i got to be there
at 2 30 everything works out
yeah as i was walking out my assistant
she goes oh where where are you going to
stay
and i was like
book me a place we're close to you know
to the park or where you're staying you
won't put that out but um we're on this
trip we went to tokyo
because things don't work out as planned
anyway yeah so i'm not saying go through
life unplanned i have 500 employees so
there's got to be some planning there's
got to be is it stretched over it
doesn't need to be me doing the planning
though yeah
like i need maybe i need somebody else
to do that
i don't have to do that no i just need
to know where i want to go so we were
coming to sydney i knew i had this
commitment with success resources to
come here and do these events good tell
me when the events are bang bang bang
um okay i got to get there right so a
week ago i'm like okay hey lanny i
called my pilot
i want to let route to sydney but
let's stop in hawaii
uh let's go to kauai
uh kids have never been there we'll stay
there for three days acclimate for a
second and shoot down to sydney i had
enough data to know that i would need to
do a route like that storm comes in i
can't get a i can't for some reason i
can't get a the place i want in kauai
storm comes across the south the pacific
and
uh landing said hey we might want to be
careful with this storm coming down
there i said okay well let me just let's
reroute to fiji double storm pops up
double-headed cyclone
okay in our path he's like grant we
can't go that way we'd have to go all
the way around this storm i said no we
don't go to tokyo
now the point of that story is look just
keep moving forward keep moving in a
direction that you want to go to we go
to tokyo i made all these friends in
tokyo i would have never done that but i
was committed to going to sydney
and and so again commit move in the
direction that gets you closer to where
you're going to go there's this whole
thing about
success that people label on top of are
they happy but they still have problems
they're probably yeah dude i still have
problems it's the same problems
everybody has so does jay-z and beyonce
right everybody's got problems like
question is are you going to keep
looking for bigger problems to solve
rather than little small problems that
you have is there any daily disciplines
that you have in your life daily
routines that you would attribute to
your success
uh
yeah i try to beat the sun up
i write my goals down every day
and i try to get i try to hit the gym
so i don't do it perfect every day sure
um some things throw me off and and um
you know unfortunately i have a i
created a lifestyle where where some
things are taking care for me that that
that um
most people don't have that that option
you know somebody drives the kids to
school i don't have to do that that
would change everything
if i had to do that who knows maybe i
need to maybe i need to start driving
the kids to school it seems like a
complete waste of time to me but
um i live two two minutes from my office
so when i bounce out of here i gotta go
do a live a live stream on real estate
but but uh
yeah that that's the first three things
if i can get that done in the morning
man i know i'm gonna have a good day
yeah pretty simple to beat the sun up
make sure you write down your goals yeah
make sure you take care of yourself get
the blood flow and get the heart pumping
yeah and goes down fresh a new unit like
in a new unit of time like i write them
down today like i had never written them
down before thanks
yeah
that's um so so so simple on the outside
but so many people won't do
those three
i dare i dare everybody listening here
to try to do it for 30 days in a row see
if you could even make seven you
mentioned that
whilst writing 10x raw something changed
for you yeah yeah
what was that was it was that sort of
the look
it was just the awareness of i had been
dependent upon one vertical right and
i'm sitting there looking okay i worked
myself
uh i i was good at my craft
i saved my money
what did i do wrong here dude
51 years old
i should have
i should be like so rich right now
i got i mean i should be late not even
huh where's my jet i wouldn't even think
about it right i wasn't thinking about
jet i should just be like
i was still having to do business with
people i didn't like
i'm like why am i still kissing it
and i don't mind kissing
like i don't mind i'll do whatever it
takes but i'm like why am i still flying
three million miles every three years
like i was banging miles down i wasn't
150 000 miles a year wow you know away
from my family like like my life was
miserable i'm like what
it's fine that you do that for 20 years
it's not fine if you do it forever
and
i'm like oh my god dude i wasn't scaling
now i didn't know that until the economy
basically served up the lesson right all
right we're gonna take your three
businesses
and we're gonna show you that we you
really only have like maybe
a half of one business
took took the first business and just
cut it in half took the second business
took it down to like 90
like just killed this partner i had
and the third business was real estate
and it was frozen it was literally like
they put it in a freezer and said you
can't
you're not going to lose any of this but
it's worth nothing to you today yeah and
i was a life support
and i'm like i'll never do this again i
will never be dependent upon one
vertical one partner
or a handful of real estate never do
business with somebody you don't feel
good about
the deal's never going to be good it's
not worth it can't get a good deal from
a bad guy
it's impossible
if i don't feel good there's no way i
will not give a person a penny i don't
care how good the deal is deal will
never be good if the guy's bad doesn't
matter how bad you want it what they
have do not do it yeah so i like i have
a list of like six things
yeah and if if if one of those boxes
checks off i know i shouldn't do this
deal wow more than one for sure i won't
do it if i sit with a hundred dollars in
my pocket folks there is no economy
if you want to be economic you let money
flow it has to move you got people in
your company managers and executives
that are saving money they save their
money i'm like what are you doing dude
we're saving money how can you grow a
department if you go home and all you do
is save
you know you open up somebody's freezer
and they got ice cream that's three
months old it's got this much left in
you you got you got diet coke that's
four days old it's got that much left in
it okay you got ziploc containers you
have whole cabinets of ziploc containers
and little plastic things where you in
case you had some leftover corn or peas
or potatoes you're like
don't throw it away
save that
save that that much pork chop maybe i'll
hit it tomorrow
see somebody put this back in here
that's probably elena doing that there's
no reason to put this back here it
reminds me of my mama
reminds me of when i grew up save
everything
it's a terrible product anyway why you
want to save it look at this she put two
apples in here don't put them back in
the refrigerator man
eat them or toss them
you're not gonna go broke
or get rich
saving leftovers
what are you guys doing man you got [ __ ]
in your closet that you ain't ever gonna
wear it don't fit you it ain't fit you
in in years
right how many of you got stuff at your
house you could get rid of
you're trying to save stuff dude how can
you how can you have new stuff come in
when you're holding on to stuff that you
don't even use
right so you have to use this it only
becomes valuable when it's used
now the question is what are you going
to use it on and the other question is
why don't you use it
why are you so compelled to hold on to
it
what do y'all think that is
you don't know how to get more number
one reason i don't your mother did not
know how to get a new shirt
that's why she took so much put so much
time and energy in cleaning the shirt
you got a stain on
okay you broke a toy your parents got
upset with you can't believe you did
that
what did what man dude
toys are to be broken
that's what a good toy is for
right
right i lost a quarter when i was eight
years old and i would have thought i
would have thought my house
was going to get torn apart because my
dad became so upset about the quarter
you're playing with money never play
with money what are you doing playing
with money and that that that lesson
pounded on me so hard it kept me from
making real money for 20 years it does
not matter
who you know
it matters who knows you
so i'm going to go up i'm going to go
i'm trying to get to feed you right
okay look i mean i could know some i
could know some people that own places
in fiji but what if it's already booked
they can't kick them out
but what if people in fiji knew i was
coming they're like hey mr cardone i
want them calling me i don't want to
call them
and so who knows you we're back to the
question who's got my money who's got
your money is who knows you people do
business with people they know
it's how businesses have been done for 2
000 years in this place not people don't
do business with people they trust they
do but they first do business with
people they know
i got to know you before i trust you
and i would rather do business with
somebody i know
and don't trust i do business with
people every day i don't trust
every day i have to don't you think
there's there's an element of so for
example but i know that would have been
a deal i know they can get the deal done
with me right like the real estate
broker i know i'm not getting quite the
truth from him on this or that but you
know what he's got the deal i just did
two deals i did 120 million by the real
estate deals with the same guy
i don't really like him right but i'm
doing business with him
and and this is not a new thing for
anybody anybody that's not doing
business with people they don't want to
do business with is lying
there's somebody you got people that
work for you you don't like i think
people need to define what commitment is
for me when i commit to something the
next two things that will happen is it
will be on a schedule requires time and
i will invest some money
all commitments
for me require time and money
if i don't write a check i'm not
committed
if i don't have if i don't take time out
of my calendar i'm not committed so if i
want to work out okay my body started
starting to cause me some problems right
so i'm like i'm committed to taking care
of my body
what did i do wrote somebody a check
show up at my place every day at seven
o'clock
and i'm gonna work out okay that was
four months ago i've missed five days in
120 days
that's commitment if you're having
problems right now
okay like like if you're having
recurring problems
just make a list
make a list of
make sure you guys do what grant says
remember he's a t-rex
yeah yeah make a list
make a list of your recurring problems
that you're sick of
the same stuff over and over again man i
don't have enough time i don't have
enough money
uh i i don't get to take whatever the
recurring problems are i can't good good
people uh uh i i got a i got one person
in my office that i depend on and i'm
sick and dependent on him even though
he's a producer
those recurring problems that you have
over and over again
you lose deals you lose you don't you
don't like your clients you actually
have clients that that you'd like to get
rid of you know how you get rid of bad
clients get more of them
okay so what i do is if i have problems
let's say i'm making a million dollars a
year i'm making one million and i'm like
okay next year this is what this is what
business owners do
they're like i'm this year i'm going to
go from 1 million to 1.2 million i'm
going to get a little growth and then
covid cracks you
and then you're like okay i'll settle
for 500 grand now
the problem was you were looking for
incremental growth okay you know the old
thing about three steps forward two
steps backward you only get one step out
of that by the time by the time a week
or two goes you're like i'm sick of this
i'm tired i'm bored
i'm beat up and your life doesn't change
the trick is
that if you would plan out how to get to
10 million even though you're not let me
just go ahead and asterisk that right
now
don't have a plan to go from one
to one point two
build a plan to go from one to ten
million because it's going to give you a
new set of problems
okay and a takeaway for you today get
new problems
because if you keep
working on the set of problems that you
have you will never solve them
okay watch uh i got a handful of
problems i'm making a million dollars a
year or 200 grand or whatever your
number is pick your number and i'm like
i'm gonna get me incremental growth how
do i do that with the people i have the
time i have the office i have
well what you do is you're like i'm
gonna go from one million to ten million
oh i need a new office new problem
oh i need ten people not two people
oh i need to spend
a hundred grand a month on advertising
not five thousand see got all of a
sudden i got new problems
i'm no longer thinking about pete the
the the the uh
uh what do they call the guy that you're
so the diva the diva
jessica i gotta put up with jessica's
because she's a diva comes in when she
wants leads when she wants
uh she runs the business even though i
own it she tells me what to do she's
really the boss even though i write the
checks
okay so i'm like i'm gonna go get 20
jessica's you follow what i'm saying i'm
going to build
like a lot of you are worried about debt
i remember in 2008 i owed 50 million
dollars to the bank
and i'm like i told my wife this will
never happen to me again the bank was
pushing me around like bullying me
around like a punk
and and i said elena this will never
ever happen to us again and she's like
what are you gonna do to prevent it i
said the next time this country goes
upside down i'm gonna owe a billion
dollars in debt what's your main message
on your heart right now to people in
this time
i would keep i would pay people
i would look at the things just like i
said about number one find out what and
who you need to cut
same thing i would tell a household what
and who do you need to cut from your
life
is there some obligation you have that
you don't need going forward cut it
yeah financial is there people in your
life that you could afford to have in
january and you can't afford to have
many more you got to cut them you got to
boss up right now you got to be you got
to do the tough thing if you want to
take care of your tribe your group your
family
you have to do
leadership is it requires tough
decisions
unpopular decisions a meridian bank in
the united states hit me today and said
can you share our
st our instagram post i said yeah you do
you know i can't
question is will i
and and and you know do you want to know
how much
exactly so
they they just gave me a loan for 93
million dollars they're paying attention
to my social i've raised 200 million 223
million dollars in 20 months using
instagram and facebook yeah so they
should be sharing your posts
well they are they are sharing my posts
they want to go the other way right so
you guys out there that are like should
you lean into social listen what i'm
telling you one guy
without a big name no i'm not merrill
lynch
raised 223 million dollars in 20 months
i paid no fees
what i did pay was
the right to be on instagram i paid a
lot of energy building up an audience
giving content and delivering content to
that audience
to
to a point to where people are like hey
i like what you're saying right there i
want to give you some money for it i
want to fund your project i want to be
involved with you i want to partner with
you i want to know more right
then i need a landing page boom built a
new business
so that that came out of charity yeah
the cardone capital was created out of
charity i just wanted to educate people
how to buy real estate
and then i realized how many people were
like dude i want to invest in real
estate i don't want to go do it yeah
that's what most people realize they
don't want to do the work so
man social media has been
like everything right it has been
unbelievable that i could be known in
sydney
and i haven't been here in 20 years
like that is the magic of social media
there's a lot of 40 and 50 and
six-year-olds just getting into business
you know their first round of
entrepreneurship getting beat up and
they're like man the younger guys do i
have the energy to compete right can i
keep up with them so what would be your
advice to somebody like that maybe in
their 40s 50s 60s just getting starting
entrepreneurship my best run has been
the last nine years me too not not like
i was 51 i mean i have more energy now
than i i got a reason i got i was
talking about a friend me and
ed and i
have in common and i'm like he's got a
big advantage though
and he's like what's that i'm like came
from another country
we're in america we've been here the
whole time there's an entitlement i was
born here raised here i don't know i
don't know what goes on in other
countries until i go there so there's a
drive from the immigrant that comes here
right he's got that drive my drive now
is time
and how do i use it like i was talking
about how do i use my time who do i use
it with
right so
um where do i play my carts
i got a hand how do i play it out
something that you've been saying a lot
is never waste a good crisis or never
waste a good recession what do you mean
by that
well what what happens in in
contractions like the one we're
experiencing now probably probably the
most severe contraction certainly in my
lifetime and maybe in the history
the last hundred years possibly right
um
is
everybody does what they do in a
contraction
not everybody not every everybody but
almost everyone
goes into
non-acceptance of the situation
they go to blame conspiracy theories
uh denial they get angry about it uh
they lose their job they lose their
position they lose their targets
they become consumers more than ever
before
and and they lose track of hey where
were you going
you know and so if seven billion people
yesterday let's say seven billion people
a month ago were on track big dreams big
goals like everybody wanted to expand a
month ago everybody had big dreams big
goals they're going to change the world
they're going to get their finances
right they're they're going for whatever
they're trying to go for whether it's a
dream house a vacation more freedom
and then boom this thing hits and
they're like oh good i just want to go
back to the way it was
so immediately there's a contraction
mental contraction
yeah and and people give up i was just
having this conversation yesterday i'm
like look i've been thinking too small
the whole time
i'm telling myself this with my with two
key staff people
and
i should be thinking bigger right now
not smaller how do i expand out into
this not contracts smaller into this so
so the first thing that happens is when
you when you have
26 million people in the united states
were let go in the last four weeks
i read something today that says the uk
housing sales will get cut by 50 to 70
this year yeah
when that happens all of a sudden you're
like oh i just want to sell the 12 homes
i sold last year now if i could just
hold on to those 12. no you should be
thinking about how do i expand into this
because if you're not asking the right
questions you will go in the direction
of your journey
and
if you're like i got to pull over right
now that your journey wasn't to pull
over
you were on a journey a month ago you
had dreams and goals and so when a
crisis comes it's like a speed bump a
flat tire
uh you ran out of fuel what do you do
dude you fix you you you keep rolling
you fix the tire you refuel and you keep
going and so so don't waste this moment
because we're gonna pass this is gonna
pass elena
she has a very very magical kind of like
think
okay she she's not stuck in mechanics
and this is something that everybody
should
um
try try to understand if you're
if you're running something if you're
going to do something big you cannot get
lost in mechanics
mechanics is how much does it weigh
how far does it have to be carried
who's going to carry it how long is it
going to take it's all that pickup the
weight the heaviness of of an activity
i'm a doer i'm a i dig holes like you
tell me what to do
um i go to the gym i work out every day
like it's effort
so i'm an effort i'm in the f that
effort ban that push
uh the force okay 2008 happened i had
nothing to do with 2008 i had two
businesses and i was starting to buy
real estate and i was not buying the
real estate to cause the problem in this
country any of you remember when lehman
collapsed
uh your business if you were in business
your business probably got hurt
i wasn't doing the mortgage-backed
securities i wasn't doing the no money
down houses
you know i wasn't selling that stuff i
wasn't doing mass development on the
backs of the bank
uh with bad loans
but
because i lived in america
and i was doing business at the time
i got greatly affected by that my first
two businesses got cut in half and my
real estate was frozen up i owed 52
million dollars to a bank that went
upside down new bank came in they
started making demands on me i ended up
in a lawsuit aren't there a bunch of
lawyers in here yeah i ended up i ended
up in one of these crazy lawsuits where
the guy was going under he had done some
things wrong and he decided to pull me
down with it
it was a frivolous lawsuit that was
costing me 200 grand a month to fund i
had never been involved in a lawsuit in
my career
so that being said um
i looked at that situation and said hey
what did i do wrong here
like i always look
at how am i responsible responsible
able to respond that is the definition
of responsible able to respond
now in my case i was being forced to
respond
it wasn't a lot of able in it
so uh
but the one thing that i walked away
with was i had a baby on the way i just
been married i just got married maybe
three years before that so the marriage
was very new
we were we were really still in the
honeymoon phases of our marriage
not really understanding
who we were as a team my wife and i new
baby coming along
i lived in los angeles i lived in a
beautiful house up in the hills
uh overlooking all of l.a and i pretty
much thought my life was great until
2008 happened
now i'm taking a second to get you to to
what i want you to hear i didn't plan on
2008 i didn't think about a lehman
collapse i didn't know
40 million people were going to go
upside down in their homes i did not
know it would affect me i didn't know
one of my industries was the automobile
dealers i was working with automotive
meal dealers around the united states
that was my primary business
i was making a couple million bucks a
year i didn't know
9 000 car dealers would go out of
business
who would plan on any of that
now what's that got to do with today
who in their business plan had coved as
part of your business plan
let us know in the chat put put it put a
no in the chat if you didn't have a plan
for that
yeah i need to see 316. i need to see
one
one guy in here say oh yeah
i planned on mask
oh yeah i had i had myself going out one
week buying
400 worth of toilet paper
okay
uh
oh yeah in 2020 by the way how many of
you in 2020 january first you're like
this is going to be the best year of my
life
oh yeah
yeah everybody gave that up on march
23rd the entire nation of america
gave up
surrender 2020.
look the news the media by by april was
saying 2020 is over how many of you
heard that [ __ ] i'm throwing 20 20
away fortune 500 companies 100 companies
carnival cruise lines general motors
ford motor company like mass companies
were like i'm done i'm tapping out
this year's over
a wall street every day i'm watching
bloomberg right now wall street's like
hey just throw away all the earnings for
2020 let's reboot for 2021. the entire
nation surrendered
uh your kids aren't going to schools
you didn't plan on that did you
see this is the problem with the concept
i think i saw somewhere in your promo go
big or go home
go big or go home ain't nothing at home
folks
they ain't nothing at your house you're
not gonna make your business work at
home
okay go big or go home or home you need
to scratch that out and say look i got
to go big or i got to go bigger because
going home cannot be a choice now and
the whole country went home we've been
quarantined you're going to have 10
million probably 8 to 10 million
bankruptcies by the end of this year the
the other shoe has not dropped yet the
stock market's going crazy the rich are
getting richer and and i don't include
us on this call as the rich the rich
will get richer
okay you why because they think big
they think big they never waste a crisis
and we are in a crisis
and the crisis if you were in trouble
before kovid you are in more trouble
today and the reason we're in trouble is
because people in this country are
satisfied complacent
comfortable these are the enemy so if
you can take anything away from me it's
like look you have you and your wife you
and your husband you and your kids must
give up ideas of comfort why is donald
trump the president of the united states
because he played around the edges of
politics
go back and watch go back and watch the
republican watch him destroy those
republican old-schooled politicians
watch him destroy them because he's like
i'm playing by a new set of rules
um
you know i don't like the hand i don't
like the way this game's played i'm
gonna play a different game and they
won't know how to respond to it but if
grant cardone had to give us top three
relationship tips off the top what would
they be
the the beans have to have a similar
vibration
okay i know they people say it likes and
what is it uh likes to try no no uh
opposite of tracks yeah well i don't
believe that i think that's just a bunch
of
i think people need to vibrate similarly
i can't go 500 miles an hour and expect
to be with somebody who wants to go 80.
they're going to be uncomfortable
they're going to be like you need to
slow down and be like you need to speed
up and we're going to have this thing
so so
you know if if one person's on the brake
and the other person's on the
accelerator you're going to wear this
vehicle out and that's what i see happen
in a lot of relationships
and and so the people have to figure out
who's doing what
who's driving where are we going
and and and and admire that in each
other do you think from a marriage
perspective or from a partner
perspective where
you've got this hunger to go and build a
business because i speak from my own
experience here in the sense of
if i'm not in a good space with my wife
or we might argue or something's not
right i couldn't give a [ __ ] about
building yeah yeah big business right
like that i agree with that i agree with
that
what it brought me to have fun
if i didn't care i mean if my marriage
was falling apart right now
i would still care about my business
because my business is like my business
like
my dreams
are
so native to me
meaning they're innate they're they were
with me before the kids and before her
i'm not giving those up
and that's all i told her when i got
married to her i said look i will give
anything up but i will not give those up
she's like i don't want you to i want i
want to see if i can make them bigger
i'm like now
you're my girl
so so that's what i want like i don't
want to give up and i don't want her to
give up on her dreams
right and then if the two dreams can
come together right
yeah and then and then the marriage is
going to be cool there's going to be
bumpy spots and working all that out and
who's doing what and you said this and
we correct each other all the time and i
wish you wouldn't have said that and
whatever you know i i got a big mouth
um
but you know i think the spiritual
condition it should be first
and and and then that'll that'll handle
the marriage thing because for me my
dreams are a spiritual condition they're
like the things i want to do the things
i've always dreamed of the things that
satisfy me and make me feel with filled
like are of a spiritual nature it's not
really about money for me keep take care
of yourself every day you got to do the
work
some things you cannot delegate
taking care of your body food you eat
somebody can cook it for you you still
got to put it in
and then you got to take care of
yourself
and then you got to take your ideas and
your dreams
only you know what they really are
and only you and you alone
know what your real potential is
your wife can't do that for you your
husband can't your boss can't your
manager can't
god's not gonna even do it for you folks
you gotta do that
you wanna be in good shape you can pray
for all you want
you wanna get your money right you can
pray for it but you gotta do the work
your destiny is waiting for you
but you got to do the work
how do you maintain
a positive
opportunistic upbeat attitude during
times like this
you know i look i struggle with it just
like everybody else this is not an easy
time it's scary uncertainties everywhere
bad news everywhere
uh the thing the thing that i continue
to do is
i was just telling jared a few minutes
ago we're just thinking too small
you know let's let's we're thinking too
small
and so like i'm like where am i going
where am i trying to get to
uh because i could be seduced into a
beach right now pretty easily
i'm gonna go lay on the beach
and i don't need to do all this
you know and then i'm like wait a minute
there's no beaches open either like
there's the caribbean shut down the damn
st bart's is shut down there's uh
everywhere you go there's problems right
so there's no getting away from that
where am i going yeah
so so i the thing i need to wake up
every morning hey i'm still going for 10
billion worth of real estate maybe 20.
yeah
why not 30.
so how do i do that got to stay relevant
got to keep paying my bills got to take
care of my properties got to show people
that i know how to get through tough
[ __ ] you can't expand if you if you fold
every hand you can't win if you fold
every hand
so you got to play the cards you got
right now it's tough
and then but i have to keep making
contacts with people that can actually
benefit me in 21 22 23.
i got i got to be i got to be a beacon
of possibility and potential and future
uh so so that when we go when things
start lifting off and we can do deals
um
i'm relevant to the conversation and i
gotta cross my fingers dude and just
believe that
i gotta believe that things are going to
get better success is a contact sport
you cannot be successful if you don't
make contact
you guys interview people and then you
never follow anybody up man nobody
follows anybody up
i spent i spent two million dollars with
a lawyer that's never called me back
same thing for the bar birth same thing
for the cosmetologist same thing for the
plumber same thing for the roofer dude
you guys don't call people back because
you think they're not interested
do you think i'm only going to have one
car accident people that have one car
accident end up in three of them
okay divorcees god gets a divorce
everybody here knows somebody's got four
of them
but he ends up with four different
attorneys
like you guys don't follow up you are a
business not a lawyer
the chiropractor has the same problem he
goes and spends all this money on
equipment he knows how to do an
adjustment he doesn't know how to build
a business
what's your biggest tip for anyone who
you know they obviously have all
intention purposes to to want to
collaborate what are some of the
the the best ins or the best ways around
money money of course pay money pay to
play money works yeah pay to play yep
universal language planet earth pay to
play
you know
whatever people i was doing before our
last conference and maybe we wrap it up
with this before our last conference a
guy came in my office from a big bank
and said hey i want to uh i want to talk
to you about lending you some money for
multi for your apartment building so i'm
like great
have you bought a ticket to my
conference no i haven't i said i don't
have time for you
so it's like pay to play man it is the
simplest hack on planet earth i'm gonna
take garbage pieces of paper
dumb little pieces of rectangle paper
and give them to you to speed up my
process i don't know why i don't know
why i didn't know this for 45 years yeah
and and i don't know why i was so hung
up
on trading paper for access
it's what all the big players do yeah i
mean i even had this arrogant thing i'm
not paying i'm not paying to connect up
like dude this is how everything works
on this planet every city i've ever been
to
when i work with ceos they say number
one problem here is the people
i said then you need to get better
so to the degree that you're having
problems with people you got to get
better and it starts with you
and you're only going to hire the people
like we we have people come to us i'm
turning resumes down
i'm like i can't see enough people like
i got people that to so so many people
want to work with us because we're
successful right
if you want good people
get big yeah everybody wants to work at
facebook
okay the average person at facebook
makes 250 just under 250 a year
which by the way if you do any kind of
financial literacy you would know that
guy walks away with 60 grand
250 in silicon valley converts to 60 000
bucks after all its expenses he's broke
he might not have 60 by the way
so um
you know just you're going to have to go
through a bunch of people recruiting
should be the number one thing for every
company out there every entrepreneur
first thing you should look for is not a
sale that's what i did wrong i was
looking for a sale i should have been
looking for a recruit
so focus more on team building than just
sales sales sales now well you need to
recruit recruit recruit recruit and that
means you need to pay people now we're
back to that other ugly problem that
nobody wants to talk about i need some
money everybody wants to be the boss
nobody wants to pay the invoice you're
trying to run a business the way you
would your marriage
is people gonna quit they're gonna quit
your business easier because they don't
know there's no culture
and once you have those kids it's hard
to walk out on the marriage because you
can't get rid of the kids the moment
they turn 15 or 18 and they leave you're
like the marriage is over same thing in
a business man the business falls apart
every day you gotta train your people
daily part of the issue with salespeople
is that they're not they don't take
ownership of the business
i was having this conversation with a
guy the other day i'm like
he's 50 mid 50s he he's together
supposedly knows how to sell a pen
i'm not going to mention his name but
so he's a crook he's a
complete criminal i'm like dude you got
to quit you got to elevate the game all
salesmen need sales people need to
elevate the game and start thinking
about managing a team running a business
running a a big business not just
selling a pin
and and i think that's where the the
there's no passion in me selling one
condo i picked the wrong careers
i picked the wrong careers like three
times now
okay
and and they made me money and then i
got trapped in them
okay so i made it picking the wrong
careers uh me and him talk about some a
business that i'm in i'm like ed there's
nothing there
like it's just full of illusions
told you that 20 times now
full of illusions there's nothing there
okay
um my first business second business
third business man they were all just
there's nothing there there
and so and i and i pushed so hard in
them i worked i overworked all my spaces
so that's a big mistake i've ever i've
underestimated my
how much energy it takes and i've also
underestimated because i underestimated
what it would take to do it i overworked
the space
i literally overworked all my spaces i
was telling around this today i
constantly overwork because i trust
nothing
i don't trust any effort like i think
everything will not work
and so i'm like okay add one more add a
second one add a third one the next
thing i do is i make a mess
like i make constant messes everywhere i
go
so um
constant there's messes everywhere i go
somebody's having a pickup
and and um but
hey
you know
next thing you know we figured it out
right and now now all that being said
it's also been easier than i've ever
imagined
i never thought
i would get where i'm at
i underestimated
like i am so far
so far beyond anything i ever dreamed of
like i heard barbara streisand say this
that she had dreamed everything that
happened in her career she dreamed it
for i dreamed none of this
never in my lifetime me either did i
think i'd fly on a private jet of
anybody's private jet what do we got
there tell us a bit more about the book
that you've brought with you oh the next
rule man this absolutely this is the
book that everybody knows about where
did that come from 10x
this this was after the collapse
i was working hard
and i kept telling elena what am i doing
wrong
i think a lot of people have this
conversation like what am i doing wrong
i'm working hard
i'm take care of my customers
i'm fair to everybody and i can't get
ahead why can't i get my break i'm a
talented guy
i'm working hard i'm talented i'm
working hard i'm tired like it was like
this like and i cannot get i can't punch
through
and then i saw a lot of people that were
less talented
not taking care of their customers
didn't have as good a product that we're
just
flying
and so i sat down every book i've ever
written except for one
was about
me trying to solve a problem for me and
the 10x rule i didn't know it was going
to be the 10x rule when i finished it
until until i finished it
it was about hey why am i working so
hard not getting ahead and the whole the
premise of this book is
my
my multiplier was broken i wasn't
multiplying i was adding
i was doing a little bit more i was
never doing a lot more
i was never doing enough more
to to expand so that i wasn't a slave to
my business i worked at mcdonald's i got
fired i worked at a furniture store i
got fired i worked in a car dealership i
was fired six times from the same guy i
just quit leaving and uh i've been fired
so many times i finally figured out how
to get fired and keep my job i mean
really
so talent uh i'm i'm a sales guy because
not because i wanted to that was not
something i wanted to do
uh my dad my dad was a sales guy my dad
told my mom before he died tell those
boys to learn how to sell he knew he was
going to die and he's like tell those
boys to learn how to sell and they can
go anywhere uh i i didn't know that my
mom didn't tell me that until i was like
uh 25 26 years old
and i had to take a sales job
she she wanted me to be a more a
professional
uh so i went and got an accounting
degree
got out of college there was 25 percent
unemployment i didn't know it
i i you know i didn't know anything
about sales i didn't i didn't go to
college to become a salesman
but it was the only job i could get when
i was 25 years old it was be unemployed
or take this job selling toyotas
i didn't even know what a toyota was to
this is this is years ago toyota wasn't
even
uh a thing yet
and um
so i took this job that i did i thought
it was just going to be a temporary job
i said okay i'm going to do this for
until i can get a real job
and
that ended up becoming my career i
actually hated sales
because all the jobs i had outside of
mcdonald's were
part-time sales jobs i sold clothes
you know i remember selling clothes i'd
sell i'd sell an outfit i'd make six
bucks on it
so kind of hard to get excited about six
dollars but it was six dollars more than
i had and i was trying to put myself
through college and
and pay for all kind of ridiculous
things i was doing at the time
and um
i i leaned into the sales thing and
started learning it i was just shooting
some material today for cardone
university we we have probably without
me
over
um
over promoting my own product we we
probably have the most
viewed
sales training system in the world today
and i'm saying that not to brag but to
tell the viewer
this came out of a job i didn't want and
didn't like
but when i leaned into it and said hey i
need to commit to this thing because i'm
just gonna i have to learn how to do
this
i have to learn how to bring revenue in
and whether i liked it or not i need to
learn i need to learn the money game the
money game starts with
in accounting and it might have been the
thing i learned in accounting as i sit
here and tell you the story because in
accounting the top
i remember studying financial statements
in accounting classes uh it was
accounting um the principles of
accounting i thought i was gonna learn
how to make money
that's not what they're teaching there
but i remember there was on a page
in the accounting book the blue
accounting book that i
tested and hated there was a page about
an income statement and then they would
compare income statements to these
companies well the top thing of every
page was income revenue or gross sales
and later looking back didn't know it
then but looking back later i'm like oh
that's the most important part of a
company
if it wasn't the most important part of
a company they wouldn't put it at the
top of the income statement
on every income statement everywhere in
the world it doesn't matter whether
you're in china or chicago
the top three lines they might be
different words there it is all
describing gross sales
uh revenue revenue by department
uh gross demand domestic product how
much
revenue is coming through a country that
is what determines whether or not a
household
a department or a company is viable
and i have been fighting
the top three lines of my personal
financial statement which everybody has
one
and it's called sales so once i leaned
into it boom i started making money man
it was it was literally that simple i'm
going to learn how to bring revenue into
my household
i was 25 years old had no money lived in
a lived in an apartment and my rent was
275 a month i was late on it four times
a year
every three months i was late because
i'd go up and down
and when i leaned into it i was saying
hey i made an extra thousand dollars
when i was 25 years old i'm like wow
that was the most important money i've
ever made in my whole life because it
gave me an idea that i could control my
income when you kind of look back now
what would you say are the traits that
that you know when you do look back that
you needed to kind of turn your life
around
you you need to know you need to you
need to under you need to be honest with
yourself right like like i am i am
brutally
honest with
and maybe why the people in in the uk
like me
like i just tell the truth to myself
okay and the fact that whether other
people can handle it or not it's up to
them
money's important
if you're broke you're selfish
if you're broken you're even more
selfish
uh anybody can make it
no matter what your troubles are how you
what side what side of town or city the
city you were born in what class you
were born into if you went out and
you're not and you're not going to make
excuses about how to get out
um
you can do it
if i can do it anybody can do it like
today
i have two billion dollars worth of real
estate today
one deal at a time putting one deal like
that is an amazing
feat for anyone but for someone that
came from where i'm at
no credit when i was 25
nobody's taught me really how to do any
of this stuff
but once you make a decision you got to
make the decision you got to make a
decision not to be comfortable you got
to make a decision and say look i want
to have so much
that i can take care of not just myself
and my family my two kids and my wife i
can take care of communities
and that's what i've always wanted i
always wanted to be a hero dude
i'd watch batman superman
wonder woman you you you know i read
those cartoon books and i'm like i want
to be the hero
and um and i think it's important that
people
understand they can be the hero when
you're running a business let's say
you've got a business that's doing three
or four hundred thousand dollars a year
i've done that
and then i'm like okay all my problems
are around 300 grand and the two
employees uh and the few customers i
have and so i'm like okay this year my
new plan is going to be i'm going to go
from 300 to 400 000. the problem with
that thinking is when you're adding 100
you're stuck with all the same
barriers
and you're thinking
that
if you went from 300 grand to 3 million
all of a sudden you're like whoa whoa
wait a minute i got a different
questions i got to ask
where am i going to get my manufacturing
where am i going to store my supplies
who's going to do all this work all of a
sudden everything's shifted when you're
going for 300 400 you're like oh you got
sherry works for me and she's no good at
this i'm gonna have to replace her my my
solutions are small but when you start
thinking okay i'm doing 30 million
because you'll just keep doing this
until you get to 30 million now i want
to go to 300 million imagine the
difference oh i need global offices i
got to go to dubai and make some
connections
oh i need a plane to go there like
you're seeing me just run out this 10x
rule right now like if people were just
tracking what we've been doing you're
going to see us go from 3 million to 6
million 6 to 10 10 to 50.
like we've been doing that and look at
all the things that have been added in
the last three or four or five years
that we weren't doing unfortunately
because we have so much attention on our
physical capacity and limitations five
eight
you know i've been a little guy my whole
life got to feed myself three times a
day because i'm hungry i got to urinate
you know sometimes with my buddy
um i gotta i got i gotta sleep
nine hours a day eight to nine hours a
day i'm reminded i'm a body
which has been a deception for me
because that's not what i'm i'm not
limited to just that and so it's been a
big trick
thinking oh i just got to take care of
this i got to clothe it i got to protect
it i got to worry about it the older you
get the more you worry about it kids can
do almost anything
you know kids can jump off a
they can jump out of a car roll around
on their damn grass and pop up and say
yeah that was fun let's do that again
you do that to me man i'm like dang that
hurt right so you can see a kid flying
down the mountain at 70 miles an hour
man i'm i'm terrified because i'm gonna
break something so it's that it's that
concern about me as a like is something
going to happen to me
if i wouldn't have been concerned about
myself
my god i could have done anything man i
would have already done it
so so that's how i would just that's
been a big limitation what i was talking
about the the capacity of the individual
is
i don't think i've even like remotely
scratched
hopefully if i come back if i can come
back if anybody believes in that kind of
stuff like then i can come back with oh
my god man maybe i'm not just five eight
170 pounds
you know little little tiny little tiny
ones got some good guns right now okay
uh but maybe i can do more than just the
physical limitations that that that i
impose on myself i know great sales
people have the potential to be really
really like
i mean
world changers
but
that their goals are so small they they
they settle you know i i spoke at your
event i was really just talking to the
front row he was talking about
successful people i was like hey i just
want to talk to the most successful
people in the room you guys quit
you settled out
you stopped i've created a fund called
cardone capital and it's changing the
way people can invest in real estate so
when i was growing up
and even earl in my early real estate
career i could not buy the best assets
the the best properties
are left for institutions and banks
and and it's super super wealthy i'm not
talking about
i'm done with the kind of wealth y'all
you're familiar with out and read about
here and i'm not talking about people
that have hundreds of millions but
billions and hundreds of billions and
even trillions of dollars of available
money to them
and so
most people
most even real estate professionals get
the leftovers
everything after that
and so i've been playing the real estate
game for 30 years and in the last seven
years figured out okay i'm gonna start
buying what jp morgan buys and
blackstone and i'm going to use my
audience on instagram and facebook and
i'm not going to go get my money from
the institutions i'm going to get the
deal from the institution
and the money is going to come from my
friends and we're going to crowdsource
this money
without paying brokers the brokers never
like to hear me say this
but we've raised 300 million dollars
bought a billion dollars worth of real
estate in the last 30 months i've paid
not one penny to a broker
wow so that means all that investor
dollars ends up in the investment
saving the investor money and then we
distribute cash distributions every
single month
not every quarter like the banks
distribute every quarter or a reit a
reit will distribute every quarter it's
funny you know people talk about the
power of social media and they they dis
it a lot but
last week uh last week kylie jenner 600
million dollars 51 stake in her business
you have raised 300 million dollars
through crowdfunding because a lot of
people are wasting time on social media
they're getting likes and comments i
know there's a guy flying into town
tomorrow and he's big on free and don't
monetize and and
he he's looking at his likes and
comments and i don't look at likes and
comments i look at hey i have an offer
this is what you could do it's a great
deal for you it's a great deal for me
it's a great deal for everybody that
plays and we want to monetize so i think
i'm going to raise 3 billion i'm going
to create a 10 billion fund
crowd funding and then the banks are
going to come to me and say we want to
buy that thing handler you're 24 inches
you can't handle your 24 inches don't
don't try to handle your neighbor's
problems
don't criticize me criticize yourself
like like
you know so many people like want to
give me advice i'm like dude you you get
handled your own life i'm i'm i've got
my hands full handle on mine i'm not
handling yours just handle your 24
inches until you got that handled
then
it could be anything could be money it
could be weight it could be uh
maybe you're cheating maybe you're
taking shortcuts you're you don't wake
up sooner whatever your problems are
everybody's got them handle i still got
my 24 inches i worry about my 24 inches
every day you had a kind of a tough
start in life there was kind of drugs
there was job losses a lot of kind of
things happened to you what was that
trigger that made you say enough was
enough i want to turn this around
yeah well there was you know i
i was i just hated my life man i hated
my life i hated
that i was a disappointment to myself my
family my community
i knew it
they knew it
um
look at myself in the mirror i was
praying meditating begging like like
um
and and i just kept making the wrong
moves like so uh at some point
you know when you when you try when you
try and you don't quit enough times
sooner or later it's going to click now
i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day i want to know what was your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week the science says that when you just
watch a video you get motivated to get
inspired you have a 35 chance of
following through on your goals 35
that's not enough that's not enough just
to get motivated believe nation we're
here you're here today matters you're an
action taker
when you commit to a plan of action of
when and how you're going to follow
through when you write it down you have
a 91 chance of following through and
when you commit publicly to somebody
else it jumps to 95 chance from 30
something percent to 95 chance of you
following through believe nation we need
to make this happen so question of the
day your single biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action
specific for the next week put it down
in the comments below and i'm going to
show on screen
sometime next week to celebrate you i
don't want to talk to you about
execution and management and business
planning and
culture i want to talk to you about
money because money we believe is the
number one problem in your business
it's not mission it's not purpose it's
not all these beautiful things everybody
tells you it's not planning and
organizing
i have seven businesses there's seven
little companies there's been no plan
there's been minimal organizing
tremendous speed
tremendous speed to market okay it's one
of the things that has made us
successful but mostly
in all the businesses every business was
created
around the concept
it needs to make money
[Music]
because if it doesn't make money
you'll call yourself an entrepreneur
[Music]
because you're not gonna be able to call
yourself a business person
[Music]
and so this industry of entrepreneurs
that that is now
so popular
i never even knew the term until like a
year and a half ago
okay before that i was in california
somebody said i was an entrepreneur uh
15 years ago i'm like well that's that's
code for
i don't have a job
okay
today today look if you want to be an
entrepreneur good but really what you
want to do is evolve to being a business
person that makes money
and that provides a good living for a
lot of other people right
so number one problem in your business
is employee disengagement it is not
actually money
money is their problem
employee disengagement how many of you
here own a runner department let me see
if you run or manage more than more than
just yourself let me see him
how many of you here run or manage a
household
okay good well if you can't manage the
household
by the way
you have disengagement at a household
level would you agree
husband and wife are disengaged
one's doing their own plan this one's
doing their plan 50 of those marriages
are going to fail okay that's what they
say they're going to divorce truth is
way more than 50 percent fail people
should not be looking at the divorce
rate they should be looking at the
failure rate if you want to see the
one-on-one i did recently with grant
check it out right there next to me i
think you'll love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there i'll tell
everybody right now i didn't hit the
target spoiler you got kovitz yeah they
are testing me every week the first week
i test positive now i'm calling home
every night
on my new phone to my wife crying